[CAPTIONS MADE POSSIBLE BY MLB
NETWORK]
[CAPTIONING PERFORMED BY THE
NATIONAL CAPTIONING INSTITUTE,
WHICH IS RESPONSIBLE FOR ITS
CAPTION CONTENT AND ACCURACY.
VISIT NCICAP.ORG]
>> IT IS THE MLB GAME OF THE
WEEK LIVE ON YOUTUBE PREGAME
SHOW PRESENTED BY YOUTUBE TV.
WE'RE SPENDING TIME IN THE JUICE
BOX DOWN IN HOUSTON, TEXAS.
THE HOUSTON ASTROS AND THE
KANSAS CITY ROYALS AND A LITTLE
RUBBLE MATCH OF -- RUBBER MATCH
OF THIS THREE-GAME SERIES THAT
CONCLUES ON THIS WEDNESDAY.
IT'S WEDNESDAY?
SEAN: THE PLAYERS ARE LIKE, IS
IT AUGUST, IT'S OCTOBER?
STEPHEN: I DID NOT GET THE MEMO
FOR BUSINESS.
SEAN: I GOT THE MEMO OF BEING
AWESOME.
I DID A LITTLE "MLB CENTRAL."
STEPHEN: WHAT DID GAME TWO OF
THIS SERIES LOOK LIKE?
LET'S SHOW YOU THE SERIES FROM
TUESDAY NIGHT.
>> HERE IS DIAZ ON THE GROUND.
LOPEZ, THE DIVING STOP AND GETS
BY O'HEARN.
THAT BALL HIT WELL TOWARD CENTER
FIELD.
HE'LL WATCH THIS BOUNCE OFF THE
WALL.
R.B.I. DOUBLE CORREA.
>> ONE OF HIS FINEST OUTINGS OF
THE YEAR.
HE WILL GET A 90'S HAND WHEN HE
GETS INTO THE DUGOUT.
STEPHEN: HE'LL GET SOME ROOKIE
OF THE YEAR, GARCIA.
THEY SHUT OUT THE ROYALS 4-0.
HOUSTON HAS WON 4-6.
CASE, THEY GET A HUGE BOOST
TODAY WITH THE RETURN OF ALEX
BREGMAN.
IT'S BEEN A MINUTE SINCE WE'VE
SEEN HIM PLAY.
AND I THINK EVERYBODY WHO
WATCHES ASTROS BASEBALL IS
JACKED UP ABOUT HIS RETURN.
SEAN: THIS GUY IS GAME CHANGING.
HE'S A SUPERSTAR, ONE OF THE
BEST PLAYERS IN THE GAME.
YOU PUT HIM IN THE MIX WHEN YOU
ARE ON THE POSTSEASON PUSH,
COULDN'T BE BETTER TIMING FOR
THE HOUSTON ASTROS TO GET ALEX
BREGMAN BACK.
HE BRINGS SO MUCH TO THE TABLE.
THE THIRD BASEMAN THAT REPLACED
HIM SINCE HE'S BEEN OUT REALLY
HAVEN'T GIVEN THEM THE
PRODUCTION THE ASTROS NEEDS.
WHEN YOU HAVE BREGMAN IN THE
LINEUP TOP TO BOTTOM, IT MAKES
EVERYBODY BETTER.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT CORREA.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT ALTUVE,
GURRIEL.
BREGMAN NOW IN THE MIX MAKES
THEM SO MUCH DANGEROUS.
STEPHEN: DUSTY BAKER DID NOT
NEED A LOT OF HELP FILLING OUT
O
THE LINEUP CARD.
BREGMAN MISSED 59 GAMES WITH
THAT LEFT QUAD STRAIN.
HOUSTON IS ALSO 35-24 WHEN
BREGMAN APPEARS IN A GAME THIS
SEASON.
BUT YOU TALKED ABOUT THAT HOT
CORNER BEING RELATIVELY COLD.
NOW, DIAZ, SINCE HE CAME OFF THE
I.L., HAS DONE QUITE WELL.
BUT 93 WEIGHTED RUNS CREATED
PLUS WITHOUT BREGMAN AND SO HE
FIGURES TO BE A MASSIVE BOOST IN
THAT DEPARTMENT.
SEAN: MASSIVE BOOST.
HE PLAYS GREAT AT THIRD BASE.
ENERGY-WISE, WHEN YOU'RE NOT --
WHEN YOU'RE HURT, YOU DON'T
BRING THE SAME ENERGY.
WHEN YOU'RE BACK IN THE LINEUP,
BREGMAN IS THAT ENERGY GUY.
HE'S ONE OF THE -- ONE SWING
AWAY FROM CHANGING THE GAME.
HE'S ONE PLAY AWAY FROM -- HE'S
LIFTING GUYS UP.
ENERGY IS DIFFERENT WHEN YOU
HAVE BREGMAN THAT'S HEALTHY AS
OPPOSED TO BREGMAN THAT'S ON THE
D.L.
STEPHEN: HE'S BRINGING BACK A
NEW LOOK.
HE HAS A BEARD NOW.
SEAN: LOOKS LIKE HE HUNG OUT IN
THE MOUNTAINS IN THE LAST TWO
MONTHS.
I'M A BASEBALL PLAYER?
STEPHEN: HE SAID THIS IS THE
BEST HE'S FELT IN HIS CAREER.
SO, AGAIN, IF THAT -- IF THIS IS
THE BEST WE'RE GOING TO GET OUT
OF ALEX BREGMAN, IF WE HAVEN'T
SEEN ANYTHING YET, THEN IT WILL
BE A SHOW.
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THIS
MATCHUP, CASE, K.C. IS A TEAM ON
PAPER YOU THINK, OH, THIS IS AN
ASTROS W, BUT AGAINST THE
TOPNOTCH COMPETITION, AGAINST
CURRENT FIRST-PLACE TEAMS,
KANSAS CITY IS NOT A TEAM FOLKS
SHOULD BE SLEEPING ON.
SEAN: NO, THEY PLAY WELL.
STEPHEN: AND AGAINST THE ASTROS,
TOO.
SEAN: YOU LOOK AT SAL PEREZ,
HE'S ONE OF THE BIGGEST BATS IN
THE GAME RIGHT NOW.
DON'T SLEEP.
LISTEN TO THIS, I PLAYED ON A
LOT OF TEAMS THAT WERE OUT OF IT
LATE AUGUST, END OF SEPTEMBER.
THESE ARE THEIR PLAYOFF GAMES.
YOU DON'T THINK THE ROYALS WANT
TO FACTOR IN ON WHAT TEAMS DID
AND WHAT TEAMS WON'T?
I'VE BEEN THERE BEFORE.
THIS IS THEIR POSTSEASON GAME.
SO THE ROYALS ARE LOOKING AT
THIS, HEY, LET'S GET THIS SERIES
WIN.
LET'S FIND A WAY TO GET IN
HOUSTON, COME IN, SLAP THESE
GUYS AROUND A LITTLE BIT, AND
MOVE ON.
SO THESE GUYS GOT -- LISTEN,
THEY CAN PITCH IT.
THEY HAVE SOME GOOD ARMS.
WHEN THEY THROW WELL, THEY CAN
SHUT ANYBODY DOWN.
BUT THEY GOT SOME BATS IN THAT
LINEUP, ESPECIALLY SAL PEREZ IN
THE MIDDLE THERE, AND
BENINTENDI, WHO'S BEEN HOT
LATELY, THAT CAN DO SOME DAMAGE.
STEPHEN: I WATCHED THIS
EXHIBITION A LOT.
THIS YEAR WE HEAR THE COMEDY
A.L. CENTRAL BECAUSE THE REST OF
THE DIVISION OUTSIDE THE WHITE
SOX HAVE BEEN ON THE STRUGGLE
BUS FOR GOOD POINTS.
BUT IF YOU LOOK BEYOND THE
SURFACE LEVEL RECORDS AND YOU
LOOK AT WHAT K.C. IS DOING, WHAT
THEY'RE DOING AGAINST FIRST
PLACE TEAMS, WHAT A.J. HINCH AND
THE TIGERS ARE DOING, CHANGING
THE CULTURE IN DETROIT, THIS
DIVISION IS GOING TO BE A FIRST.
AND K.C. ARE TRYING TO TAKE THE
NEXT STEP, DEVELOP AS AN
ORGANIZATION DEVELOPMENTALLY.
WE HAVE MIKE MINOR AND LANCE
McCULLERS JR.
THERE HAS BEEN HISTORY WITH
LANCE McCULLERS AND THE KANSAS
CITY ROYALS.
HE MADE HIS PLAYOFF DEBUT
AGAINST K.C. BACK IN 2015.
GAME FOUR, HOUSTON HAS A CHANCE
TO CLOSE OUT THE SERIES AGAINST
THE ROYALS.
AND HE PITCHED QUITE WELL.
THE BULLPEN DID NOT HOLD ONTO
IT.
WE KNOW WHAT HAPPENED AS THE
ROYALS CAME BACK TO WIN THAT
GAME, WON THE SERIES AND THEN
WON THE WHOLE DARN THING.
WE'VE SEEN LANCE McCULLERS JR.
DEVELOP INTO A POSTSEASON
PITCHER SINCE THEN.
PART OF THE GAME SEVEN IN 2017.
THIS IS WHAT HE DID BACK IN
2015.
WHAT DO YOU EXPECT TO SEE FROM
HIM TODAY, CASE?
SEAN: HE'S GOTTEN BETTER SINCE
2015.
LANCE McCULLERS JR. THROWS A LOT
OF BREAKING BALLS, A LOT OF
OFF-SPEED PITCHES.
THIS GUY IS A VETERAN NOW.
IT'S SO FUNNY WHEN YOU LOOK BACK
FROM WHAT HE WAS BACK THEN TO
WHAT HE IS NOW.
HE'S GOT SINKER, SLIDER, THAT
KNUCKLE-CURVE, CHANGEUP, CUTTER.
HE THROWS A LOT OF BREAKING
BALLS.
I THINK THAT'S THE BIG THING
ABOUT McCULLERS.
LIKE, YOU CAN'T SIT ON THE
FASTBALL WITH THIS GUY.
HE WILL GET YOU OFF BALANCE.
HE'S GOT A GREAT 12-6 BREAKING
BALL, TOO, THAT HAS SOME BITE
THAT GETS HITTERS OFF THAT
FASTBALL.
IT WILL BE INTERESTING TO SEE
HOW McCULLERS MATCHES UP TODAY
AGAINST THE ROYALS.
STEPHEN: ONE THING THAT'S
DIFFERENCE ABOUT LANCE
McCULLERS JR. NOW AND THEN IS
THE LETTUCE.
THE SALT AND PEPPER.
SEAN: I HAVE THE SALT AND
PEPPER.
HE HAS THE NICE FLOW.
STEPHEN: I'M WITH YOU, DUDE.
THE SALT AND PEPPER.
YOU TALK ABOUT SOMEBODY THAT'S
ON THE MOUND.
NOW LET'S GO BACK IN YOUR HOME.
YOU'RE A CAREER .300 HITTER IN
YOUR CASE.
SO TELL THE PEOPLE WHO WHO IS
WATCHING THE -- WHO IS WATCHING
THE YOUTUBE PREGAME SHOW TO GET
OUT OF THE SLUMP IN YULI
GURRIEL.
SEAN: BEFORE THAT, GOT INTO A
LITTLE BIT -- THIS IS WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN YOU START
STRUGGLING.
YOU GET OUT OF THE STRIKE ZONE.
YOU'RE OFF THE BASEBALL A LITTLE
BIT.
TIMING IS OFF A LITTLE BIT.
WHEN I SEE GURRIEL GETTING
JAMMED, GETTING OUTSIDE THE
ZONE, HE WAS 1-20 IN THE SIX
GAMES PRIOR TO HIM GETTING HOT.
WHEN YOU THINK GURRIEL, MAN,
THIS GUY RIGHT HERE, WHEN HE'S
ON THAT OFF-SPEED PITCHES, HE
GETS THAT PITCH DOWN IN, HEATER
MIDDLE IN, THIS IS WHAT HE DOES
SO GOOD.
HE'S GOT SUCH GREAT HANDS,
NELLY.
THIS GUY IS SO GOOD BECAUSE HE'S
A LINE-TO-LINE GUY.
HE'S GOING AGAINST MIKE MINOR
TODAY AND HE HAS HISTORY AGAINST
THIS GUY.
YOU KNOW WHAT, IF MINOR MAKES
MISTAKES TO GURRIEL TODAY, HE'S
MADE HIM PAY IN THE PAST.
AND I -- MINOR KNOWS THAT.
HE'S GOT TO KEEP THE BALL DOWN.
YOU SEE THOSE THREE PITCHES
RIGHT THERE, ALL OUT OVER THE
PLATE AND UP.
GURRIEL RIGHT NOW HITTING .317,
LEADING THE A.L. IN HITTING.
THIS GUY IS HAVING A GREAT
SEASON.
LOOK AT THIS, THOUGH, SIX GAMES
4-5 HE WAS 1-23.
10-20 WITH SOME DAMAGE.
OVER 1.300 O.P.S.
WE TALK ABOUT BREGMAN.
WE TALK ABOUT BRANTLEY.
THEY'RE ONE AND TWO IN THE RACE.
GURRIEL GETS OVERLOOKED.
DON'T OVERLOOK THIS GUY,
ESPECIALLY AGAINST MIKE MINOR.
S
STEPHEN: THERE ARE NO HOLES, NO
BREAKS WHEN FACING THIS HOUSTON
ASTROS LINEUP.
AND KYLE TUCKER.
AND MICHAEL BRANTLEY GETTING A
BREATHER ON THIS WEDNESDAY.
NOW, IT'S TIME FOR THE MLB GAME
OF THE WEEK POLL PRESENTED BY
YOUTUBE TV.
WHO'S GOING TO WIN TODAY'S GAME?
R
ROYALS, ASTROS?
CHIME IN ON THAT AND TAKE IN THE
PITCHING MATCHUP.
FACTOR IN ALL THE STATS.
AND THINGS THAT YOU NEED TO TO
MAKE YOUR PICK.
WHEN WE COME BACK, WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE A SPECIAL GUEST JOIN US.
.
THAT'S COMING UP NEXT ON THE
HOUSTON PREGAME SHOW.
>> RUNNER ON THE GO AND THE
THROW A LITTLE BIT -- OH, IN
TIME.
HOW ABOUT THAT?
HE GETS HIS FIRST CAUGHT
STEALING OF THE YEAR.
THERE GOES THE RUNNER.
AND ANOTHER GUY THROWN OUT.
DYSON CAUGHT STEALING.
ASTROS HAVE NOT LED IN THIS
GAME.
DIAZ WILL TRY TO CHANGE THAT
HERE WITH THE BASES LOADED AND
NOBODY OUT.
THERE IS A LINE DRIVE INTO
CENTER FIELD.
THAT'S DOWN FOR A BASE HIT.
INTO SCORE IS GURRIEL, AND THE
ASTROS TAKE THEIR FIRST LEAD OF
THE GAME.
IT'S IN THE TENT.
IT'S NOW 4-3.
SWING AND A MISS.
ODORIZZI NOW WITH SEVEN
STRIKEOUTS MATCHING THE TOTAL
AGAINST SEATTLE IN HIS FIRST
START AGAINST THEM THIS YEAR.
FIRST STRIKE.
THROWS IT ON THE FASTBALL.
THAT'S NOW EIGHT STRIKEOUTS FOR
ODORIZZI.
>> THE WIND-UP.
1-2.
SWING AND A MISS.
GOT HIM ON THE CURVEBALL.
SAEG AR DOWN ON -- SEAGER DOWN
ON STRIKES.
EIGHT PUNCHOUTS FOR McCULLERS.
>> THAT'S GOING TO BE DOWN.
FOUR-HIT GAME FOR ALHUFA.
R.B.I. SINGLE.
WILSON CROSSES THE PLATE.
IT'S AN EVEN DOZEN FOR THE
SECOND STRAIGHT GAME.
12-0 ASTROS.
STEPHEN: YOU ARE WATCHING THE
MLB GAME OF THE WEEK ON YOUTUBE
PRESENTED BY YOUTUBE TV.
CASE, FIRST SPECIAL GUEST, ONLY
SPECIAL GUEST, AND HE'S A
SPECIAL ONE AT THAT, KENDALL OF
THE HOUSTON ASTROS JOINING US
HERE ON BALLPARK CAM.
KENDALL, GREAT TO VISIT WITH
YOU.
THANKS FOR DOING THIS.
FIRST AND FOREMOST, AS A PRO
BALLPLAYER, I KNOW YOU GUYS
TRAVEL QUITE A BIT.
YOU'RE USED TO GOING AROUND
SEEING NEW PLACES.
KENDALL, OUTSIDE THE SHOW
CIRCUIT, WE'VE HIT UP YOUR
MEDIAS OF SOCIAL, AND WE SEE
THAT YOU, TOO, LIKE TO GET OUT
AND TRAVEL AND HEAD OUT THE
OUTDOORS.
TELL US YOUR FAVORITE SPOT AWAY
FROM THE GAME.
KENDALL: WE WENT TO THE GRAND
TETONS LAST OFF-SEASON AND IT
HAD TO BE ONE OF MY FAVORITES.
MY WIFE AND I GO TO THE BAHAMAS
EVERY YEAR.
WE'VE GONE SEVEN YEARS IN A ROW.
THAT HAS TO BE A SPECIAL SPACE
FOR US.
WE GOT TO KNOW THE LOCALS AND
SOMETHING THAT'S REALLY NEAR AND
DEAR TO US IS THE BAHAMAS.
STEPHEN: NICE.
CAN WE GO THERE WITH YOU?
KIDDING.
[LAUGHTER]
SEAN: KENDALL, YOU'RE HAVING
SUCH A GOOD YEAR.
YOUR E.R.A. IS SITTING OVER
1.00.
THAT MEANS YOU'RE NASTY BOYS.
CAN YOU TELL US HOW YOU'VE HAD
SUCH SUCCESS?
KENDALL: YEAH, FOR ME, THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE SLIDER THAT'S
PAIRED REALLY WELL WITH THE
SINKER.
BEFORE WHEN I WAS A STARTER I
HAD A SINKER AND CUTTER AND
EVERYTHING WAS KIND OF SIMILAR.
AND TO ME THE SLIDER HAS REALLY
CHANGED THE GAME FOR ME.
TO RIGHTIES AND TO LEFTIES TO BE
ABLE TO THROW THAT, I THINK
YOU'VE SEEN BATTING AVERAGE FROM
MYSELF GOING DOWN AND THE E.R.A.
HAS DEFINITELY GONE DOWN.
TO THROW 15, 20 PITCHES IN AN
OUTING AND LET IT RIP HAS BEEN
PRETTY FUN THIS YEAR.
STEPHEN: I LOVE HEARING ABOUT
THAT SIDE, THE BETWEEN THE LINE
STUFF, KENDALL.
I FOLLOWED YOU WHEN YOU WERE
BACK AT HAIL STATE IN 2013, TO
SEE YOUR GROWTH AND DEVELOPMENT
THROUGH THE SHOW HAS BEEN PRETTY
COOL TO WATCH.
BUT IT'S NOT JUST THE
ON-THE-FIELD STUFF.
I THINK MOST OF THE TIME MOST
FANS FORGET ABOUT THE FACT THAT
BALLPLAYERS ARE PEOPLE, TOO.
AND YOU WERE THE FACE OF THE
TRADE DEADLINE IN TERMS OF
HUMANIZING YOU GUYS AS PRO
ATHLETES.
LOOK, I KNOW YOU'RE FOCUS RIGHT
NOW IS GETTING OUTS FOR THE
HOUSTON ASTROS.
HOW MUCH TIME DID YOU GIVE
YOURSELF TO KIND OF SIT WITH THE
EMOTIONS OF BEING TRADED FROM A
PLACE THAT YOU WANTED TO STAY?
OR IS IT SOMETHING THAT STAYS
WITH YOU AND YOU WANT TO KEEP
WITH YOU EVERY TIME YOU GO ON
THE BUMP?
KENDALL: YEAH.
THERE'S -- I'M SOMEBODY THAT I
LIKE TO EXPRESS EMOTIONS, I
THINK, FOR PEOPLE TO BE
VULNERABLE IS HUGE.
WE DON'T GET THAT A LOT IN
SOCIETY TODAY.
JUST TO BE ABLE TO SHOW THOSE
EMOTIONS AND EXPRESS IT IS
SOMETHING I THINK FANS
GRAVITATES TOWARDS.
I NEVER WANT TO HIDE THAT.
SO IT WAS SITTING AT THE HOUSE
IN SEATTLE, THE PLACE I WAS
RENTING WITH MY WIFE AND
DAUGHTER AFTER THE GAME KNOWING
I WAS PLAYING FOR ANOTHER TEAM.
THERE'S A LOT OF EMOTIONS THERE.
KIND OF A SLEEPLESS NIGHT.
IT'S SOMETHING I'M BLESSED TO
PLAY THIS GAME FOR A LIVING, AND
I HOPE PEOPLE UNDERSTAND OUTSIDE
OF THE GAME, WE ALWAYS TRY TO
PERFORM ON THE FIELD, BUT WE
HAVE A FAMILY AND WE HAVE A LOT
OF THINGS THAT GO ON.
I JUST -- I LOVE THAT ASPECT
THAT I'M JUST THE SAME AS THE
PERSON SITTING IN, YOU KNOW,
SECTION 22 IN A GAME.
AND WE'RE JUST HUMANS JUST LIKE
YOU.
WITH THE ABILITY AND BLESSED TO
DO WHAT WE DO FOR A LIVING AND
THANKFUL THAT FANS SHOW UP TO
WATCH US PLAY.
SEAN: MAN, KEN, I'VE BEEN THERE
BEFORE.
GETTING TRADED FROM CINCINNATI
AFTER EIGHT YEARS THERE.
HEY, LISTEN, WE'RE HUMAN BEINGS.
YOU MAKE A LOT OF FRIENDS IN
THIS GAME.
YOU GET CONNECTED TO THE CITY.
I UNDERSTAND THOSE EMOTIONS.
YOU'RE WITH A GUY I'VE GOTTEN TO
KNOW REALLY WELL OVER THE YEARS,
WHO I THINK IS ONE OF THE BEST
MANAGERS IN THE GAME, ONE OF THE
BEST GUYS IN THE GAME, DUSTY
BAKER.
HOW HAS YOUR RELATIONSHIP BEEN
WITH HIM SO FAR AND WHAT HAS
IMPRESSED YOU THE MOST?
KENDALL: HE'S AWESOME.
JUST TO GET TO KNOW ME.
I'M EIGHT HOURS SHORT OF A
MECHANICAL ENGINEERING DEGREE.
HE WAS INTERESTED IN THAT.
HECK, HE WAS TALKING ABOUT
GARDENING.
HE GARDENS AT HOME.
MY FAMILY HAD A GARDEN GROWING
UP.
JUST AN OUTSTANDING PERSON.
IT SPEAKS -- IT'S A TESTAMENT.
WE WENT TO THE NEGRO LEAGUE HALL
OF FAME TOGETHER WHEN WE WERE IN
KANSAS CITY AND IT WAS SOMETHING
I'LL CHERISH FOREVER THAT MOMENT
TO BE ABLE TO SPEND WITH HIM AND
EXPLORE THE HISTORY OF BASEBALL.
AND I THINK WE'VE BECOME CLOSE
OVER THE PAST COUPLE WEEKS BEING
HERE.
THAT'S A TESTAMENT TO HIM AND
WHAT HE DOES.
HE'S A PLAYERS' MANAGER.
HE CARES ABOUT PEOPLE AND YOU
CAN SEE IT DAY IN AND DAY OUT.
STEPHEN: WE TALK ABOUT HUMAN
BEINGS.
DUSTY IS ONE OF MY FAVORITE IN
BASEBALL, IN SPORTS, FOR SURE.
KENDALL, BEFORE WE LET YOU GO,
YOU'RE TRYING TO GET TO KNOW ALL
THE HUMANS IN THAT ASTROS
CLUBHOUSE AND YOU HAVE A BIG ONE
COMING BACK IN ALEX BREGMAN.
CAN YOU SPEAK TO HIS RETURN AND
MAYBE THE JUICE THAT'S SUPPLYING
THE CLUBHOUSE EARLY?
KENDALL: YEAH, QUICK STORY.
I PLAYED AT MISSISSIPPI STATE
WHEN BREGGY WAS A FRESHMAN AND
HE MADE AN ERROR AND COST HIM A
GAME AT L.S.U.
THE LIGHTS ARE STILL ON.
HE HAS A GRAD ASSISTANT HITTING
GROUND BALLS.
FROM THAT POINT ON, I'VE ALWAYS
SEEN THE WORK HE'S PUT IN AND
THE PREPARATION AND THE ENERGY
FOR THIS GAME.
IT'S A BOOST FOR THE LINEUP.
IT'S SOMEONE I ENJOYED THE
BATTLES BUT GLAD HE'S ON MY SIDE
NOW AND GET TO WATCH HIM ON A
DAILY BASIS.
SEAN: THAT'S A STORY RIGHT
THERE.
STEPHEN: BREGGY BUMPS, ALSO.
YOU HAVE TO TRY THAT NOW YOU'RE
WEARING THE ASTROS UNIFORMS.
YOU'RE ONE OF THE FAVORITES TO
TALK TO IN THE GAME.
STAY HEALTHY.
KENDALL: THANK YOU.
SEAN: GOOD LUCK, BROTHER.
STEPHEN: ALL RIGHT, FRIENDS,
IT'S TIME FOR OUR "CREATOR
SPOTLIGHT."
260,000 SUBS ON HIS CHANNEL.
THAT'S NOT HIS NAME.
IT'S MATT MEYER.
LET'S BRING IN MATT JOINING US
NOW.
THE FIRST THING I NOTICE -- IT'S
NOT THE WORK ON YOUR CHANNEL
WHICH IS INCREDIBLE.
IN ALL SPORTS.
NOT JUST MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL.
YOU KNOW, PLAYING THE SHOW.
ALSO "MADDON 2-K" AND PREVIEWING
DAILY CONTESTS AND SHOWING FANS
WHAT MIGHT HAPPEN IN REAL LIFE.
I NOTICE THE JERSEYS YOU'RE
WEARING.
YOU HAVE THE TWINS BEHIND YOU.
I KNOW YOU'RE BORN AND BRED IN
MINNESOTA.
BUT YOU'RE WATCHING A RED SOX
UNIFORM.
CAN YOU EXPLAIN WHAT IS
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW?
MATT: I KNOW IT'S A LITTLE
STRANGE TO AMERICAN LEAGUE
CLUBS.
MY LOVE FOR BOTH GOES WAY BACK.
BORN AND RAISED A TWINS FAN HERE
IN THE TWIN CITIES.
BUT GOES BACK TO ABOUT THE --
RIGHT ABOUT THE 1986 WORLD
SERIES.
AND JUST IDENTIFYING WITH THE
CURSE OF THE BAMBINO AND KIND OF
LATCHING ONTO THAT FAN BASE AND
THEIR PAIN AND THAT QUEST TO
FINALLY BREAKTHROUGH AND GET
THAT TROPHY.
SO IT WOULD HAPPEN YEARS LATER.
BUT, YEAH, I LATCHED ON THEM AND
THAT ONLY BECAME CEMENTED WITH
MY FIRST TRIP OUT TO FENWAY AND
JUST KNEW THAT WAS WHERE
BASEBALL WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
PLAYED.
I WAS USED TO GAMES IN THE
METRODOME.
SEE A WHOLE LOT OF OUTSIDE
BASEBALL, ESPECIALLY IN THE
MAJORS.
THAT JUST BLEW ME AWAY.
I'VE BEEN GOING BACK EVER SINCE.
LOVE IT AT FENWAY.
STEPHEN: WE'VE TALKED ABOUT HOW
I'M A WHITE SOX FAN.
WE'LL BE FRIENDS DESPITE THE
WHITE SOX-TWINS THINGS.
DESPITE THE HATRED BETWEEN THE
TWO, FRANCHISES AND FAN BASES, I
HAVE IMMENSE RESPECT FOR THE
MINNESOTA TWINS AND I WISH I HAD
A CHANCE TO GO SEE THE GAME AT
THE METRODOME BECAUSE I ALWAYS
HEARD STORIES ABOUT HOW LOUD IT
GOT IN THERE.
SO I APPRECIATE YOU PAINTING
THAT PICTURE FOR ME AND OTHERS
WHO HAVE NOT BEEN THERE.
AS FOR THE RED SOX, IT HAS NOT
BEEN THE SECOND HALF THAT
EVERYBODY IN NEW ENGLAND AND RED
SOX NATION WAS HOPING FOR.
WHAT HAS GONE WRONG?
ARE YOU STILL KEEPING THE FAITH
THAT THE SHIP CAN BE RIGHTED?
MATT: DEFINITELY KEEPING THE
FAITH.
YOU HAVE TO KEEP THE FAITH.
I THINK PITCHING HAS GONE WRONG,
MAINLY.
PITCHING HAS BEEN REALLY TOUGH.
THE BATS ARE WAKING UP.
THEY WOKE UP AGAINST THE TWINS
LAST NIGHT.
HOW MANY GAMES CAN YOU COUNT ON
OUTSLUGING AND WINNING 11-9?
YOU HAVE TO HAVE THAT PITCHING.
I KNOW PEOPLE ARE REALLY EXCITED
CHRIS SALE IS BACK.
HE CAN PITCH ONE OUT OF FIVE
DAYS.
EVERYBODY IS GETTING A LITTLE
NERVOUS ABOUT MATT BARNES
CLOSING OUT GAMES.
I THINK IT STARTS WITH THE
BULLPEN AND THE PITCHING IN
GENERAL TO STICK WITH THIS AND
THE YANKEES ARE ON THIS STREAK.
11 IN A ROW NOW.
IT'S LOOKING LIKE TROUBLE.
YES, DEFINITELY KEEPING THE
FAITH.
STEPHEN: I'LL SEE THIS, THE GEN
Z OF BOSTON RED SOX FANS, THEY
DON'T KNOW THE PAIN AND THE
SUFFERING THAT YOU CAME UP IN.
SO THIS IS A ROUGH SWOON IS
NOTHING COMPARED TO WHAT YOU
EXPERIENCED IN YOUR LIFE AS A
FAN.
NOW, LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
CONTEST WE'RE ABOUT TO SEE ON
THE MLB GAME OF THE WEEK LIVE ON
YOUTUBE.
HOUSTON AND K.C.
THE ASTROS HAVE, WHAT, A 4
1/2-GAME LEAD IN THAT DIVISION,
BUT THEY HAVE OAKLAND, WHO YOU
KNOW THEY'RE STRUGGLING RIGHT
NOW.
THE A'S HAVE SOME MAGIC WHEN
SEPTEMBER COMES AROUND.
AND THEN THE MARINERS HAVE THIS
MAGIC THIS YEAR.
DO YOU FEEL LIKE THE ASTROS ARE
GOING TO HOLD OFF BOTH?
MATT: I DO, ACTUALLY, FEEL LIKE
THEY ARE.
I THINK THAT'S MAINLY BECAUSE OF
EXPERIENCE.
THEY'VE BEEN THERE.
THEY HAVE A LOT OF GUYS ON THE
ROSTER THAT HAVE DONE THIS
BEFORE.
EVEN TODAY THAT ALEX BREGMAN IS
SUPPOSED TO BE BACK, THIS IS
HUGE FOR THEM.
I THINK THAT'S JUST THE RIGHT
TIME TO GET BREGMAN BACK.
IF HE CAN BE HIS NORMAL SELF AND
THAT'S GOING TO BE A HUGE BOOST.
I REALLY LIKE WHAT THE MARINERS
ARE DOING.
OAKLAND'S ALWAYS SEEMING TO MAKE
THAT RUN.
I LIKE HOUSTON TO HOLD THEM OFF.
STEPHEN: LET'S TALK ABOUT
ANOTHER BIG STORY IN THE SHOW IN
REAL LIFE.
NOT JUST THE SHOW THAT I KNOW
THAT YOU SPECIALIZE IN.
MIGUEL CABRERA REACHING THE 500
HOME RUN PLATEAU.
ONE OF THE GREATEST HITTERS
RIGHT-HANDED OR LEFT-HANDED.
NOW EVERYBODY'S THINKING ABOUT
WHO'S NEXT.
WHO DO YOU SEE AS THE NEXT
CURRENT BIG LEAGUER TO HIT 500?
MATT: OH, MAN.
THERE ARE SO MANY GOOD ONES.
FOR ME IT'S GOT TO BE VLAD
GUERRERO JR.
36 HOMERS THIS YEAR.
HE'S ALREADY GOT 60 AT, WHAT IS
HE, AGE 22.
YOU HAVE TO LOVE TATIS JR.
YOU HAVE TO LOVE SOTO.
FOR ME IT'S VLAD.
IT'S GOT TO BE VLADDY.
STEPHEN: THAT'S A STRONG PICK.
NELLY CRUZ IS THE CLOSEST.
HE'S GETTING UP THERE.
NOT SAYING NELLY CAN'T DO IT.
YOU SAW HIM BREAK AGAINST THE
TWINS AGAINST MY WHITE SOX.
MATT: SO SAD TO SEE HIM GO.
STEPHEN: HE'S ONE OF THE
CLUBHOUSE GUYS, WHEREVER HE GOES
IS A GAME CHANGER AND THE RAYS
ARE HOPING HE CAN BE THE PIECE
THAT PUTS THEM OVER THE HUMP AS
THE REIGNING PENNANT WINNERS.
LET'S END ON THIS NOTE.
YOUR FAVORITE CHERISHED MEMORY
AS A FAN OF THIS GAME, MATT?
MATT: THE 2004 WORLD SERIES WITH
THE RED SOX FINALLY BREAKING
THROUGH IS GREAT.
BEFORE THEN I HAVE TO THROW IT
BACK TO 1991 AND THE SECOND OF
THE TWO TWINS WORLD
CHAMPIONSHIPS WHICH I WISH I
CHERISHED.
KIND OF FELT LIKE IT WOULD HAVE
HAPPENED A LOT.
CERTAINLY NOT.
BUT I WAS AT GAME TWO
PERSONALLY.
THAT WHOLE SERIES WAS JUST
GUTWRENCHING THE WHOLE TIME IN
THE BEST WAYS.
AND THE TWINS CAME OUT ON TOP.
I WAS THERE FOR THE HERBACH AND
GANT AT FIRST BASE.
HERBACH, HE FELL OFF THE BAG.
THAT'S ALL I CAN SAY ABOUT THAT.
STEPHEN: JOHN SMOLTZ IS
SOMEWHERE IN THE BUILDING RIGHT
NOW.
I'M GOING TO LEAVE THIS
CONVERSATION -- THIS PART OF OUR
CONVERSATION OUT OF MY
CONVERSATION WITH SMOLTZY.
BUT IN ALL SERIOUSNESS --
MATT: THAT MIGHT BE BEST.
STEPHEN: FOR EVERYBODY IN THE
BUILDING, FNOT JUST ME.
IT'S GREAT TO LINK UP WITH YOU,
ALBEIT DIGITALLY.
SPORTS GAMING UNIVERSE,
E
SUBSCRIBE TO MATT'S CHANNEL ON
YOUTUBE, AGAIN, ALONG WITH
260,000 OTHERS.
YOU CAN GET THE BEST OF THE
GAMING WORLD.
HOPEFULLY WE CAN RINK UP IN --
LINK UP IN REAL LIFE DOWN THE
ROAD, MATT.
MATT: IT'S A PLEASURE.
STEPHEN: THANKS TO MATT.
WAIT A SECOND.
HE SHAVED.
THAT'S A PROBLEM.
I HAVE ISSUES WITH
HE CUT HIS HAIR, TOO.
DIDN'T HE HAVE LONG HAIR?
STEPHEN: NO!
[LAUGHTER]
>> HE'S HUNTER DOZIER.
THERE'S A DRIVE.
DEEP TO LEFT FIELD.
THAT ONE IS LONG GONE!
HUNTER DOZIER!
>> A TESTER.
>> OH, BABY, NICKY LOPEZ!
[LAUGHTER]
>> THAT LOOKED LIKE THAT WAS
DROPPING.
IT WAS A LITTLE DOINKER TRYING
TO SNEAK IN THERE BUT LOPEZ GOT
A GREAT JUMP.
THERE IS A LOOPING LINE DRIVE TO
CENTER FIELD.
THAT WILL GET AT LEAST ONE.
TAYLOR WITH THE THROW HOME.
IT'S A GOOD ONE.
AND THEY GOT IT!
HIT SHARPLY.
LOPEZ FROM HIS KNEES.
OH, HE GOT HIM.
GOT HIM!
WHAT A PLAY!
THAT BALL IS STRUCK WELL.
DEEP TO RIGHT, AND IT IS NICKY
LOPEZ'S FIRST HOME RUN OF THE
YEAR!
DID I SAY THE ROYALS WON'T BEAT
YOU WITH A LONG BALL?
JOSE ALTUVE.
BASE HIT, LEFT FIELD.
MCCORMICK COMING AROUND.
THE THROW TO THE PLATE.
GOT HIM!
BENINTENDI UNLOADED.
A CANNON SHOT FROM LEFT FIELD.
STEPHEN: SALVY STRETCHING.
PREGAME SHOW PRESENTED BY
YOUTUBE TV.
TIME NOW FOR PICKS THE CLICK
PRESENTED BY BET M.G.M.
SEAN CASEY, YOU ARE IN THE HOT
SEAT.
FANS WATCHING WANT TO KNOW YOUR
THOUGHTS ON SOME POTENTIAL PLAYS
HERE ON THIS WEDNESDAY
AFTERNOON.
LET'S START WITH THIS GAME.
TOTAL RUNS BETWEEN THE ROYALS
AND ASTROS.
EIGHT.
OVER OR UNDER EIGHT?
SEAN: I WILL HAVE TO SAY WITH
THIS LINEUP WITH BREGMAN COMING
UP, I'M GOING TO SAY IT'S GOING
TO BE OVER EIGHT TODAY.
I JUST FEEL THAT WAY.
THERE ARE A COUPLE HOT GUYS IN
THESE LINEUPS.
MINOR, THE HISTORY VERSUS
GURRIEL, THERE COULD BE A
THREE-RUN BOMB.
EIGHT OVER.
STEPHEN: 4.1 RUNS PER GAME FOR
THE ROYALS.
DIFFERENT ENDS OF THE MAJOR
LEAGUE SPECTRUM.
Y
DOESN'T MATTER.
OVER-UNDER 6 1/2 K'S FOR LANCE
McCULLERS PUNCHIES?
SEAN: I WILL SAY IT'S GOING TO
BE UNDER TODAY.
I THINK HE WILL PITCH WELL.
IT WILL BE UNDER 6 1/2.
STEPHEN: HE HAS STRUCK OUT.
FOOD FOR THOUGHT.
S
SEVEN-PLUS.
THE ROYALS PRETTY GOOD WHEN IT
COMES TO ELIMITING K'S.
HOW ABOUT SOME OF LANCE
McCULLERS JR.'S COUNTERPARTS IN
THE AMERICAN LEAGUE?
CY YOUNG FRONTRUNNERS.
YOU HAVE LANCE LYNN WHO IS THE
BETTING FAVORITE RIGHT NOW.
YOU HAVE GERRIT COLE BEHIND HIM.
YOU HAVE SHOHEI OHTANI.
THERE AS WELL.
CARLOS.
SEAN: M.V.P.
STEPHEN: THAT'S WHY IT'S
INTERESTING BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE
SAYING, WELL, HE'S THE M.V.P.
YOU LOOK AT HIS OFFENSIVE
NUMBERS.
YOU LOOK AT HIS PITCHING
WHY IS IT NOT THE SAME
CONVERSATION FROM THE OTHER
STANDPOINT?
LOOK WHAT HE'S DONE PITCHING.
LOOK WHAT HE'S ALSO DOING
HITTING.
I'M NOT SAYING OWE TAWNY WOULD
BE MY GUY -- OHTANI WOULD BE MY
GUY.
SEAN: WE HAVE NOT SEEN LIKE THIS
BEFORE.
HE'S CY YOUNG FOR WHAT HE HAS TO
DO TO GET READY FOR THAT TYPE OF
PLAYER.
LANCE LYNN, HAVING THE 2.20
E.R.A.
HE'D HAD TO REALLY FALL OFF, I
THINK, TO NOT WIN THE CY YOUNG.
STEPHEN: I'M WITH YOU.
HE'S A BEAUTIFUL SPECIMEN OF A
MAN.
LET'S GO TO THE ANOTHER GAME IN
THE CENTRAL BUT IN THE NATIONAL,
THE REDS NOW IN A POSTSEASON
SPOT.
THEY'VE BEEN GREAT.
THE BREWERS HAD A STRANGLE HOLD
ON THAT DIVISION SEEMINGLY SINCE
THEIR FIRST SERIES COMING OUT OF
THE BREAK.
YOU KNOW THE REDS.
DO YOU KNOW HOW MANY RUNS
THEY'RE GOING TO SCORE TODAY?
3 1/2, OVER-UNDER REDS RUN, JUST
TOTAL IN THIS GAME, CINCINNATI?
SEAN: REDS RUNS, FOR SOME REASON
I WILL SAY OVER.
I KNOW THEY HAD TROUBLE AGAINST
WOODRUFF AND HE'S PITCHED WELL.
IN THE LAST FEW STARTS HE'S NOT
BEEN AS SHARP AND THE REDS ARE
SWINGING RIGHT NOW.
I AM GOING TO SAY OVER 3 1/2.
STEPHEN: I DON'T KNOW FATHER YOU
KIDS OUT -- I DON'T KNOW FOR YOU
KIDS OUT THERE, HE'S A BIG DEAL,
SEAN CASEY.
SEAN: THAT'S HOW I FEEL.
VOTTO WILL CONNECT.
THEY HAVE SOME THUNDER.
STEPHEN: THOSE ARE PICKS TO
CLICK PRESENTED BY BET M.G.M.
NOW, LET'S SEE YOUR POLL
RESULTS.
WE ASKED YOU THE QUESTION -- WHO
WILL WIN TODAY'S GAME, KANSAS
CITY OR HOUSTON?
AND 67%, CASE, THEY DID NOT CARE
ABOUT THE ROYALS' RECORD AGAINST
FIRST PLACE TEAMS.
SEAN: THEY KNOW BREGMAN IS BACK
AND THEY THOUGHT HE HAD A BEARD
LIKE YOU AND I.
THAT'S WHY IT'S 67.
WITHOUT 55.
STEPHEN: SO WE HAVE SCOTT BRAUN
ON THE CALL BETWEEN JEREMY AND
GEOFF BLUM.
YOU KNOW BOTH GUTHRIE AND
BLUMER.
SEAN: WELL, BLUMER AND I PLAYED,
I PLAYED AGAINST HIM WHEN HE WAS
WITH THE ASTROS AND I WAS W
CINCINNATI.
OUR BOY, BRAWNY DOES A GREAT
JOB.
DOES A GREAT JOB BEING JACKED.
STEPHEN: WE HAVE A TWEET?
WE HAVE SOME BREAKING -- SOME
BREAKING TWITTER NEWS.
OK.
JAMES CLICK TELLING SEAN
UNFILTERED ON SPORTS TALK 790
THAT JUSTIN VERLANDER WILL NOT
RETURN AT ALL THIS SEASON FOR
THE ASTROS.
DOCTORS -- DOCKERS -- I DON'T
KNOW -- BUT DOCTORS RECOMMENDED
NOT THE BEST MOVE FOR HIS
RECOVERY.
SEAN: WELL, YOU KNOW WHAT ABOUT
THAT PLAYING WITH VERLANDER,
I -- YOU KNOW HE WANTS TO COME
BACK.
AND LIKE TRY AND MAYBE GET BACK
AND GET BACK NOW THIS SEASON.
HELP THEM WITH THE PUSHBACK WITH
THE ROYALS.
THE DOCTORS ARE COMING OUT
SAYING, UH-UH.
LET'S PULL THE REINS BACK.
LET'S NOT GET YOUR HOPES UP COME
OCTOBER.
WE'LL LET YOU KNOW LATE AUGUST.
STEPHEN: HE WANTS TO BE THE
BRADY OF BASEBALL.
HE WANTS TO PITCH FOREVER.
I THINK AS ATTEMPTING AS IT
WOULD BE TO JOIN A POTENTIAL
WORLD SERIES RUN WITH THE ASTROS
RIGHT NOW TAKING IT SAFE IN
HOUSTON WITH JUSTIN VERLANDER.
CASE, YOU KNOW I LOVE YOU.
THANKS FOR HANGING OUT WITH US
LIVE ON YOUTUBE.
ENJOY THE BALLGAME DOWN IN THE
JUICE BOX.
[CAPTIONS MADE POSSIBLE BY MLB
NETWORK]
[CAPTIONING PERFORMED BY THE
NATIONAL CAPTIONING INSTITUTE,
WHICH IS RESPONSIBLE FOR ITS
CAPTION CONTENT AND ACCURACY.
VISIT NCICAP.ORG]
>> WE'RE IN HOUSTON.
I'LL USE DUS BAKER'S WORDS ON
HOW K.C. HAS PLAYED THE ASTROS,
THEY'RE PUNCHING US AND WE'RE N.
LAST NIGHT THEY HAD DOMINANT
PITCHING.
THIS IS THE MLB GAME OF THE WEEK
PRESENTED BY YOUTUBE TV.
KANSAS CITY ROYALS AND HOUSTON
ASTROS.
THE WEDNESDAY MATINEE.
LET'S GO, EVERYONE, WATCHING ON
YOUTUBE, I'M SCOTT BRAUN ALONG
WITH JEREMY GUTHRIE AND FORMER
ASTRO GEOFF BLUM.
THE ENTIRE LIFE AND EVERYTHING
AND STAY TUNED.
GEOFF WILL LET US KNOW ABOUT THE
A
ASTROS TEAM THAT'S IN FIRST
PLACE PRETTY MUCH ALL SEASON
LONG AS WE TAKE A LOOK AT THE
POSTSEASON PICTURE.
PLEASE STAND BY.
>> HE'S COME OUT WITH RECKLESS
ABANDON.
HE CONTINUES TO BE FANTASTIC
BEHIND THE PLATE.
HAVING ANOTHER GOLD GLOVE TYPE
SEASON AND HE'S UP THERE IN
STEALING.
HE'S THROWN OUT THE MOST IN
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL.
HE'S JUST A FORCE BACK THERE.
THIS GUY HAS RETOOLED HIS SWING,
WORKING WITH THE HITTING COACH,
TERRY BRADSHAW.
AND HE'S RELENTLESS.
HE'S RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE AND
DOES EVERYTHING.
HE'S THE HEART AND SOUL.
SCOTT: STAT CAST POWERED BY
GOOGLE CLOUD.
OK, FASTBALLS, HE HANDLES THEM
LIKE MANY OTHERS.
HE HAS 14 HOMERS OFF
NONFASTBALLS THIS YEAR ADDING TO
HIS CAREER HIGH 33.
>> HE WAS KNOWN AS A GUY THAT
CAN HIT TO ALL FIELDS.
THERE WAS A PERIOD OF TIME OF
TIME THAT HITTERS.
HE'S WORKED TO WHERE HIS BREAD
AND BUTTER IS.
ON PACE TO BE THE FIFTH CATCHER,
THE SIXTH CATCHER TO HIT 40 HOME
RUNS IN A SEASON.
SCOTT: WE SHOULD APPRECIATE THE
FACT THAT THIS IS ONE OF THE
BEST SEASONS WE'VE SEEN
OFFENSIVELY FROM A CATCHER AND
HE DOES A GREAT JOB HANDLING THE
ROYALS' STAFF BUT THAT ROYALS
PITCHING STAFF WILL HAVE HIS
HANDS FULL BECAUSE THE
MAGNIFICENT SEVEN DOES HAVE
THEIR SEVENTH MAN.
HE'S BACK.
ALEX BREGMAN HAS MISSED THE LAST
COUPLE OF MONTHS.
BRETT DOLAN HAS MORE FOR US.
SCOTT.
BRETT: THERE HAS BEEN A QUESTION
OVER THIS HOUSTON FAN BASE, WHAT
IS UP WITH ALEX BREGMAN AND WHEN
CAN HE BACK IN THIS LINEUP?
TODAY IS THE ANSWER.
BREGMAN FINALLY ACTIVATED.
OBVIOUSLY IN SOME PAIN AND HE
HASN'T QUITE BEEN THE SAME
SENSE.
BREGMAN HAS HAD MULTIPLE
RREHAB.
LAST NIGHT AT MINUTE MAID PARK,
PUTTING THE FINISHING TOUCHES,
TAKING SOME GROUND BALLS, AND
DUSTY BAKER HAPPY TO HAVE HIM
ACTIVATED.
BETWEEN THE HAMSTRINGS AND THE
QUADS, IT'S BEEN A PROBLEM FOR
BREGMAN BECAUSE THEY HAD MORE
PLATE APPEARANCES OTHER THAN
BREGMAN.
WITH ALEDMYS DIAZ FEELING IN SO
ADMIRABLY.
KYLE TUCKER WAS ACTIVATED
YESTERDAY.
SO DUSTY BAKER HAS THE TOP IN
THE LINEUP.
ALKEETY IS GETTING CLOSER.
SO THIS OFFENSE AND THIS TEAM
THAT'S BEEN SO GOOD THIS YEAR
STARTING TO GET ALL OF THEIR
WEAPONS BACK FOR PRESIDENT
STRETCH DRIVE.
NOW, DUSTY DID SAY HE'S GOING TO
BAT BREGMAN SIXTH RATHER THAN AT
THE TOP OF THE LINEUP.
HE FEELS LIKE IF HE CAN TAKE HIM
OUT LATE IN THE GAME, MAYBE
SOMEBODY POPS UP.
HE DOESN'T WANT TO COMPLETELY
DISRUPT THE TOP OF THE LINEUP.
AGAIN, THIS OFFENSE LEADING IN
SO MANY CATEGORIES.
WILL HAVE THEIR TOP SEVEN BATS
BACK WITH KYLE TUCKER ACTIVATED.
BREGMAN BACK.
SO THEY'LL MAKE THAT PUSH FOR
THE STRETCH DRIVE HAVING ALL OF
THEIR PIECES AT THE AVAIL OF
THEIR MANAGER.
SCOTT.
SCOTT: BREGMAN AND TUCKER AND
THE ASTROS POSTING AGGRESSIVE --
HOSTING AN AGGRESSIVE ROYALS
BALL CLUB.
WE'LL DELIVER LINEUPS AND FIRST
PITCH FROM HOUSTON, NEXT.
SCOTT: WATCH YOUTUBE TV.
TRY IT FOR FREE.
WE'RE BRINGING IT TODAY.
UNIQUE FEATURES.
YOU GET THEM EVERY WEEK.
RIGHT HERE BRINGING YOU CLOSER
TO THE GAME THAN EVER BEFORE.
WE'RE CRUISING THROUGH OUR
20-GAME PACKAGE.
JOIN THE THREE MILLION-PLUS AND
WE HAVE JEREMY GUTHRIE, IT'S THE
VETERAN, MIKE MINOR AGAINST
LANCE McCULLERS JR. WHO HAS BEEN
IN HIS PRIME AND THRIVING.
JEREMY: HE'S INVENTED HIMSELF A
NEW PITCH.
HE HAS A NEW TOY OUT THERE.
HE SURE LOVES USING IT AGAINST
THE RIGHTIES.
THAT'S A SLIDER.
HE'S BEEN FANTASTIC.
HE'S ALREADY MADE -- HE WILL
MAKE HIS 22nd START OF THE YEAR.
SCOTT: IT'S A CAREER SEASON FOR
HIM.
THIS IS MIKE MATHENY'S ROYALS
STARTING LINEUP CARD.
WHIT MERRIFIELD PLAYS EVERY DAY
AND I MEAN LITERALLY.
NICKY LOPEZ HAS HAD A BOUNCEBACK
SEASON.
SALVADOR PEREZ HAVING THE BEST
OF HIS YEAR.
ANDREW BENINTENDI WILL CLEAN UP.
NORTH PICK BY THE RED SOX.
HUNTER DOZIER.
RYAN O'HEARN IN RIGHT.
MICHAEL TAYLOR AND HIS SPEED IN
CENTER.
EMMANUEL RIVERA MAKING A NAME
FOR HIMSELF LATELY OVER AT THIRD
BASE.
AND CAM GALLAGHER WILL DO THE
CATCHING.
OK.
A LITTLE MORE ON LANCE McCULLERS
WITH OUR PITCHER BREAKDOWN
PRESENTED BY YOUTUBE TV, THIS IS
THEIR TOP GUY.
>> YOU OBVIOUSLY HAVE GROOERNGY.
LANCE McCULLERS -- YOU OBVIOUSLY
HAVE GREINKE.
LANCE McCULLERS CAN BE THE ACE.
IF HE CAN PITCH LIKE THAT TODAY
HE WILL GET HIS CAREER HIGH IN
INNINGS.
HE NEEDS TO BE THAT FOR THE
ASTROS MOVING FORWARD.
HE'S LIKE THE COBRA KAI.
HE WILL COME AT YOU AND WIPE YOU
OUT.
NO MERCY FOR McCULLERS TODAY.
YOU'LL SEE A LOT OF BREAKING
BALLS, CURVEBALLS TO THE
LEFTIES.
SLIDERS TO THE RIGHTIES.
SCOTT: COMING OUT, WHIT
MERRIFIELD, PITCH IS LOW AND IN.
WE'RE LIVE ON YOUTUBE TO A
GLOBAL AUDIENCE TODAY.
KANSAS CITY AT 56-59 ON THE
YEAR.
THEY'VE WON 7-9.
HOUSTON CHECKING IN AT 74-52.
WHIT IN THE AIR RIGHT TO THE
SHORTSTOP CARLOS CORREA FOR OUT
NUMBER ONE.
HE'S GOT --
JEREMY: HE'S GOT A PRETTY GOOD
UNDERRATED DEFENSE.
THAT DEFENSE IS SO GOOD WE HEARD
FREE AGENT PITCHERS TALKING
ABOUT SIGNING WITH THE HOUSTON
ASTROS BECAUSE OF THE DEFENSE
BEHIND HIM AND IT'S BEEN SINCE
JUNE 16 THAT WE'VE ACTUALLY SEEN
A BREGMAN, ALTUVE, YULI GURRIEL
IN THAT STARTING LINEUP BEHIND
AN ASTROS PITCHER SO A GREAT
LUXURY TO HAVE THOSE GUYS BEHIND
HIM.
SO YOU TALKED ABOUT, JEREMY,
LANCE McCULLERS HAVING THE GREAT
WIPEOUT, STRIKEOUT TYPE STUFF.
HE'S A HIGH GROUND BALL GUY AS
WELL WHICH KEEPS THE DEFENSE ON
THEIR TOES.
JEREMY: IN THE LAST START IT
FELT LIKE HE WAS 0-2 TO
EVERYBODY AND THAT'S INDICATIVE
TO EVERYBODY PITCHING INTO A
LINEUP THAT IF THEY PUT IN PLAY
HE KNOWS THE PLAYERS BEHIND HIM
WILL MAKE THE PLAY FOR HIM.
SO THEY HAD 15 STRAIGHT GAMES
WITHOUT AN ERROR.
THAT ENDED JUST TWO GAMES AGO
AND THAT'S WHAT HE WAS DEALING
WITH.
YOU HAVE ELECTRIC STUFF WITH
GOOD DEFENSE.
SCOTT: THE STATS BACK IT UP.
IT LOOKS AT THE ENTIRE DEFENSE
HAS THEM NUMBER ONE IN BASEBALL
AT THE MOMENT.
THERE'S THE FIELDING PERCENTAGE
YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT.
SAME GUYS IN THERE ALMOST REFER
DAY WHICH HELPS.
THAT CORE THAT'S BEEN HERE FOR A
WHILE NOW.
LOPEZ MAKES CONTACT.
DIVING STOP BY BREGMAN.
HE'S BACK!
[LAUGHTER]
GEOFF: HE KNOW WHO WAS GOING TO
FIND HIM, RIGHT?
SCOTT: QUICKLY.
HE'S A SHORTSTOP OVER THERE.
GEOFF: TAKE A SLICE OF HUMBLE
PIE.
HE KNEW MOVING TO THIRD BASE HE
WOULD ONLY MAKE THIS TEAM
BETTER.
RIGHT OUT OF THE CHUTE, NICKY
LOPEZ IS TESTING HIM.
AS MUCH AS WE TALK ABOUT ALEX
BREGMAN AND WHAT HE BRINGS TO AN
OFFENSE, YOU SEE WHAT HE CAN DO
DEFENSIVELY, ALSO.
JEREMY: COMPLETE PLAYER.
JUST AN INCREDIBLE ON BOTH SIDES
OF THE BALL AND CERTAINLY
THEY'RE HAPPY TO HAVE HIM BACK.
SCOTT: NOW IT'S SALVADOR PEREZ
WITH NOBODY ON AND TWO OUTS HERE
IN THE FIRST.
ALSO, FOR BREGMAN, HE HAD TO GET
UP QUICKLY.
BECAUSE NICKY LOPEZ CAN FLY.
GEOFF: I LIKE NICKY LOPEZ.
I KNOW HE'S A LITTLE BIT OF A
THROWBACK IN THIS DIP AND DRIVE
ERA WE'RE LIVING IN, BUT I LIKE
HIS GAME.
JEREMY: HE AND WHIT HAVE BEEN
THE STRAWS THAT STIRRED THE
OFFENSE FOR THE ROYALS FOR THIS
RUN.
ON BASE A LOT.
STEALING A TON OF BASES.
SIX LAST WEEK AGAINST THE
ASTROS.
AND YOU SEE THAT BALL HIT TO
BREGMAN, HARD HIT BALL.
SCOTT: THE ROYALS AS A TEAM ARE
A BIT OF A THROWBACK.
THEY'RE AGGRESSIVE.
THEY MAKE CONTACT.
THEY CERTAINLY KNOW HOW TO RUN
AND THEY'VE BEEN DOING THAT
PRETTY FREQUENTLY AGAINST
HOUSTON IN THE PAST WEEK.
GEOFF: I THOUGHT IT WAS GREAT TO
TALK TO MIKE MATHENY.
WE'VE SUFRPGSS WHEN WE -- WE'VE
SUFRPGSS WHEN WE SEE -- WE HAVE
SEEN ASSUMPTIONS.
THEY PUT PRESSURE ON DEFENSES.
JEREMY: WELL, THAT WAS PART OF
THE BIG RECIPE IN THE RUN IN THE
MID 2010'S RIGHT, 2014, 2015,
RUNS, PRODUCE THE RUNS.
THEY'RE 27th IN HOME RUNS IN THE
LEAGUE SO THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
POUND YOU OUT OF THE PARK
ALTHOUGH THEY CAN DO IT.
THEY HIT FIVE SOLO HOME RUNS
LAST WEEK IN CHICAGO.
GENERALLY SPEAKING, THEY'LL GET
GUYS ON, NOT STRIKE OUT A LOT,
AND RUN.
SCOTT: YOU'RE LOOKING AT ONE OF
THE MOST AGGRESSIVE HITTERS IN
BASEBALL.
HE'S TAKEN A FEW PITCHES TO
RIGHT UP THE COUNT -- TO RIDE UP
THE COUNT.
IT'S A FULL BOAT HERE.
THAT'S BALL FOUR.
SO FAR A LINOUT, A BALL AND A
WALK.
AND ODDS COURTESY OF BETMGM.
JEREMY, YOU'RE THE PITCHER.
IS HE GOING OVER OR UNDER?
JEREMY: YOU HAVE A TEAM THAT
MAKES A LOT OF CONTACT AGAINST A
GUY THAT HAS 144 STRIKEOUTS PER
GAME ALREADY THIS YEAR.
I LIKE THE APPROACH OF THE
ROYALS.
I TAKE THE UNDER.
SCOTT: GEOFF, ARE YOU GOING THE
OTHER WAY?
GEOFF: OF COURSE.
SCOTT: ALTUVE.
SO THE SIDE IS RETIRED.
NO STRIKEOUTS YET IN THE FIRST
BUT I'M SURE THERE'S PLENTY OF
SWING AND MISS FROM THAT MAN ON
THE MOUND.
WE'LL INTRO THE ASTROS LINEUP.
>> RUNNER GOES.
PITCH SWUNG AND MISSED.
SAFE.
LOPEZ GOES.
THROW TO THIRD.
HAS ALMOST GOT BY DIAZ.
>> TESTER.
>> OH, BABY, NICKY LOPEZ!
>> THAT LOOKED LIKE THAT WAS
DROPPING.
THAT WAS A LITTLE DOINKER TRYING
TO SNEAK IN THERE BUT LOPEZ GOT
A GREAT JUMP.
>> A GROUND BALL UP THE MIDDLE.
THAT WILL FIND CENTER FIELD AND
THE ROYALS HAVE THEIR FIRST BASE
RUN.
>> LOPEZ GOES.
PITCH TAKEN.
THROW BY MALDONADO.
LOPEZ, 14-14 STEALING BASES THIS
YEAR.
T
>> THAT BALL IS STRUCK WELL DEEP
TO RIGHT AND IT IS NICKY LOPEZ'S
FIRST HOME RUN OF THE YEAR!
HIT SHARP LY.
LOPEZ FROM HIS KNEES.
>> OH, MY GOODNESS.
>> AND THE GROUND BALL IS INTO
CENTER FIELD.
THAT'S BASE HIT NUMBER THREE FOR
NICKY LOPEZ.
>> NOT EXPECTING RIVERA TO EVEN
RUN.
>> YEAH.
AND RIGHT CENTER FIELD.
>> BEAUTIFUL JOB.
>> SO THAT STOLEN BASE ENDS UP
BEING HUGE FOR THE ROYALS.
NICKY LOPEZ HAS TWO MORE HITS.
SCOTT: IF YOU WERE WITH US FROM
THE BEGINNING, WE WENT OVER THE
MAGNIFICENT SEVEN.
IT'S ALMOST COMPLETE TODAY.
THE ONLY MAN SITTING FROM THAT
GROUP IS MICHAEL BRANTLEY.
JUST A ROUTINE DAY OFF.
YOUR ASTROS STARTING LINEUP
P
PRESENTED BY YOUTUBE TV.
ALTUVE IN THERE.
DIAZ, GURRIEL, ALVAREZ, CARLOS
CORREA AT SHORT.
ALEX BREGMAN, FIRST GAME SINCE
JUNE 16.
HE MISSED 59.
HE'S BACK.
KYLE TUCKER BACK IN THE STARTING
LINEUP FOR THIS TEAM AS WELL
FOLLOWED BY MEYERS AND MALDONADO
GOING UP THE ONLY VETERAN IN THE
STARTING ROTATION FOR THE
ROYALS.
OUR SCOUTING REPORT PRESENT BID
YOUTUBE.
JEREMY: THIS IS A ROTATION.
MIKE MINOR, THEY BROUGHT HIM IN
FOR A TWO-YEAR DEAL.
HE'S THEIR LEADER.
HE'S MORE QUIET IN NATURE.
HE HAS TO GO OUT EVERY FIVE
DAYS, EVERY SIX DAYS NOW, PUT
OUT AN EXAMPLE.
HE WORKS THE CORNERS.
MIKE MATHENY SAYS HE PITCHES
WELL UP IN THE ZONE WHICH IS
DIFFERENT THAN SOME OF THESE
OTHER PITCHERS.
RUNNERS IN SCORING POSITION HAS
BEEN A CHALLENGE.
HE NEEDS TO DO HIS BEST TO LEAVE
THEM STRANDED OUT THERE, WORK
THROUGH SOME OF THE TROUBLE.
SCOTT: HE STARTS WITH ALTUVE.
A PITCH THAT MISSES ABOVE THE
ZONE.
GEOFF, HE SHOULD BE CAREFUL,
BECAUSE JOSE ALTUVE CAN DEAL
WITH AN ELEVATED HERETO.
GEOFF: IT'S GREAT TO SEE SOME OF
THE PITCHES.
WE'VE SEEN HIM ON HIS TIPPY TOES
TO GET BASE HITS.
WE'VE ALSO SEE HIM ELEVATE AND
DRIVE OUT OF THE BALLPARK AROUND
NECK HIGH.
SCOTT: IT'S INCREDIBLE.
NOT MANY PLAYERS CAN DO THAT.
I THINK ABOUT DAVID FLETCHER OF
THE ANGELS.
HE'S ONE THAT WILL GO AFTER THE
HIGH PITCH.
IT'S REALLY A WEAPON TO HAVE IN
A GAME WHERE PITCHERS ARE
WORKING UP THERE AS MUCH AS
WE'VE EVER SEEN.
ALTUVE SMACKS ONE FOUL.
HE'S GOT SOME WORK TO DO, STILL.
LEADOFF HOME RUNS IN ASTROS
HISTORY.
PRETTY GOOD NAMES IN FRONT OF
HIM.
GEOFF: GOOD NAMES.
ALTUVE CONSTANTLY ADDING HIS
NAME IN THAT HISTORY BOOK.
SCOTT: LITTLE FLAIR AND CAUGHT.
GRABBED BY NICKY LOPEZ IN
SHALLOW LEFT FOR THE FIRST OUT.
JEREMY: THAT'S WHAT NICKY LOPEZ
DOES.
INTERESTING, HE CAME INTO THE
SEASON AS THEIR SECOND BASEMAN.
HIS JOB TO LOSE.
INJURIES TO MONDECI, MOVED HIM
TO SHORTSTOP AND NOW IN
CONTENTION FOR A GOLD GLOVE THIS
YEAR.
MAKING PLAYS LIKE THIS EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
GEOFF: THAT'S A LEG PLAY, TOO.
THAT'S GETTING A GOOD JOB.
JUST ABLE TO STAY WITH IT.
IT WAS A GREAT PLAY.
SCOTT: HE'S A GOLD GLOVE
CANDIDATE.
YOU CAN SEE ODDS ABOVE AVERAGE
THIS SEASON.
HE'S TOP FIVE AMONG INFIELDERS.
GEOFF: THEY HAVE TWO PRETTY GOOD
SHORTSTOPS IN THIS GAME TODAY.
SCOTT: ATHLETES ALL OVER THE
DIAMOND ON BOTH SIDES.
HERE'S ONE.
ALEDMYS DIAZ WHO DID SOME WORK
FILLING IN AT THIRD BASE FOR
BREGMAN.
SWINGS THROUGH THE OFF-SPEED
PITCH FROM MINOR.
BUT DIAZ HAS BEEN ON FIRE SINCE
THE ALL-STAR BREAK HITTING .337.
GEOFF: THAT WAS AFTER HE WENT ON
THE INJURED LIST AFTER THAT
BROKEN HAND AFTER BEING HIT IN
TORONTO WHERE HE WAS TEARING THE
COVER OFF THE BASEBALL.
SCOTT: THERE IT IS SINCE COMING
BACK FROM I.L., DUSTY BAKER
CALLS HIM HIS SECRET WEAPON.
DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH OF A SECRET
IT IS.
NOT IN HOUSTON, THAT'S FOR SURE.
PULLED TO THIRD.
RIVERA.
ACROSS THE DIAMOND.
TWO GONE.
JEREMY: GOOD PITCH BY MINOR.
COUPLE OF HAND PITCHES INSIDE.
LOOKS LIKE HE HAS COMMAND.
WORKING BOTH SIDES OF THE DISH.
GEOFF: THAT'S ONE OF THE MORE
INTERESTING THINGS, TOO.
IN THIS DAY AND AGE EVERYBODY
MAX VELO AT 95-PLUS, YOU HAVE A
PLAYER LIKE MIKE MINOR WHO IS
NOT AFRAID TO GET TO THE OUTSIDE
CORNER, CUT IT A LITTLE BIT.
IT'S GOT TO OPEN THE OUTSIDE
CORNER QUITE A BIT, TOO, RIGHT?
JEREMY: IT'S ALL ABOUT THAT.
G
GET THEIR TIMING OFF.
MIX AND MATCH.
IT DOESN'T MATTER HOW HARD YOU
CAN THROW.
IF YOU CAN MIX IT.
THAT'S WHAT MIKE MINOR HAS DONE.
HE'S BEEN STRONG HIS WHOLE
CAREER.
HAD A GREAT YEAR IN 2019.
LAST YEAR STRUGGLED A BIT.
THIS YEAR HAS BEEN ONE OF THE
MORE CONSISTENT LEFTIES MAKING
EVERY ONE OF HIS STARTS BUT
STILL TRYING TO WORK THROUGH
HERE AND GIVING A TEAM WITH A
CHANCE TO WIN.
GOOD CHANGEUP RIGHT THERE.
SCOTT: IN 2019, AN ALL-STAR.
FINISHED TOP VOTING WITH THE
TEXAS RANGERS.
E.R.A. HAS TICKED HIGH THIS
TEAM.
33 YEARS OLD.
START NUMBER 207 OF HIS CAREER
TODAY.
JEREMY: I THINK HE TRAILS ROBBY
RAY FOR LEFT-HANDED STARTING
PITCHERS, WITH HIS 141.
SO EXACTLY WHAT THE ROYALS WERE
LOOKING FOR.
I MEAN, SURE, THEY LIKE, YOU
KNOW, GET SOME -- GET THE E.R.A.
DOWN, BUT HE'S DOING WHAT THEY
NEEDED HIM TO DO.
HE'S CONSISTENT.
HE'S GETTING BETTER AND STRONGER
HERE.
SCOTT: YULI GURRIEL HAS BEEN
UNPHASED WITH TWO STRIKES THIS
SEASON.
AND HE STAYS ALIVE.
GEOFF: I THINK YULI IS ONE OF
THE BETTER RIGHT-HANDED HITTERS
BECAUSE HE PULLS HIS HANDS IN SO
EASILY.
REALLY LEADS WITH THAT KNOB.
I LOVE HIS SETUP, TOO.
REMINDS ME OF JULIO FRANCO.
HOW HE'S TWESHGD IN THERE
WITH -- TWERKED IN THERE WITH
HIS BACK TO THE PITCHER.
SCOTT: HE'S HAVING A HUGE HOME
STAND.
AND HE WHIFFS.
A LITTLE CHASE.
MINOR PICKS UP THE STRIKEOUT AND
SITS DOWN THE SIDE IN ORDER.
WE'VE COMPLETED ONE.
NO SCORE FROM HOUSTON, TEXAS, ON
YOUTUBE.
>> CARLOS CORREA LEADS OFF
AGAINST CARLOS HERNANDEZ AND
FIRST PITCH, HE BELTS IT DEEP TO
LEFT FIELD.
AND YOU CAN KISS IT GOODBYE.
OVER THE BULLPEN, CARLOS CORREA
GIVES THE ASTROS A 4-3 LEAD.
>> THAT BALL IS HIT HARD INTO
LEFT FIELD.
AND THERE YOU GO.
IT'S DOWN FOR A HIT.
THAT COULD BE EXTRA BASES.
CORREA TAKES THE TURN.
BENINTENDI'S THROW NOT IN TIME.
>> HERE'S THE 2-2 PITCH.
SWING AND A LINE DRIVE INTO
RIGHT CENTER FIELD.
THAT'S DOWN FOR A HIT.
O'HEARN IS OVER FROM RIGHT TO
GET IT.
AND CORREA IS ON WITH HIS SECOND
HIT OF THE GAME.
>> 1-1.
AND CORREA DRIVES IT OUT TO
RIGHT CENTER DEEP.
ON THE WARNING TRACK.
CAN'T GET IT.
IT'S OFF THE FENCE IN FRONT OF
THE ASTROS' BULLPEN.
THIRD BASE, BRANTLEY.
HE'S AROUND THIRD AND COMING
HOME.
THERE WILL BE NO THROW.
IT'S AN R.B.I. TRIPLE FOR CORREA
AND IT'S A 1-0 LEAD FOR THE
ASTROS.
>> THIS IS A SHARPLY HIT GROUND
BALL THROUGH THE HOLE BETWEEN
SHORT AND THIRD.
CORREA, 2-2.
THAT BALL ROCKETED INTO CENTER
FIELD.
THAT WILL BE DOWN FOR A HIT.
ALTUVE AGGRESSIVELY TURNED
SECOND.
DROPS THE BALL.
SO CORREA IS GOING TO GET TO
SECOND BASE.
>> ALTUVE GOING FIRST TO THIRD,
BUT THEN CORREA GETS THE EXTRA
90 FEET.
SCOTT: TOP TWO IN TEXAS.
DUSTY BAKER LEADS THE HOUSTON
ASTROS GROUP AND HE'S INCHING
CLOSER TO AN EXCLUSIVE CLUB.
GEOFF, WE'RE NOT INVITED.
FEW ARE.
GEOFF: IT'S A VERY LIMITED
GROUP.
GOES BACK A LONG WAY.
2,800 WINS IS PRETTY AMAZING.
YOU HAVE TO BE SUSTAINABLE.
COMING BACK 37-76.
THESE ARE VETERAN GUYS.
A LOT OF MANAGERS YOU SEE ON
THIS LIST, YOU FEEL LIKE YOU GET
COMMENTS FROM PLAYERS THAT
PLAYED FOR THEM, THEY HAVE BEEN
PLAYERS-MANAGERS WHO HAVE HELPED
NOT ONLY PLAYING BUT ALSO AS
MANAGERS.
IN A IS EXCLUSIVE -- THAT IS AN
EXCLUSIVE GROUP THAT DUSTY IS
AIMING FOR.
SCOTT: 2,000-WIN CLUB.
HE'S GETTING THERE.
1966 ON THE LEDGER RIGHT NOW IN
HIS 24th SEASON AT THE HELM.
JEREMY, WE WERE NOT INVITED.
IT LOOKS LIKE A LOT OF FUN IN
THERE, PLAYING POOL, HANGING OUT
BEHIND THE BAR.
JEREMY: I WAS INVITED UNTIL I
MADE MY ONE START FOR DUSTY
TRYING TO GET HIM ONE WIN
CLOSER.
HE WITHDREW THE INVITE AFTER THE
NINTH EARNED RUN THAT I ALLOWED
IN THE FIRST INNING.
AND --
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: YEAH, WE MENTIONED IT TO
HIM WHEN WE SAID HELLO.
JEREMY: WHAT A GREAT GUY TO PLAY
FOR.
SCOTT: AND SOME OTHER MLB
MILESTONES THAT WE'RE KEEPING AN
EYE ON.
MIGGY HIT HIS 500th.
KIM BREL, CLOSE TO 5 -- KIMBREL,
CLOSE TO 500 SAVES.
NOW A DANGEROUS WEAPON ON THE
AMERICAN LEAGUE SIDE.
I'M SURE THE ASTROS ARE NOT
THRILLED TO SEE THEM IN THE
POSTSEASON.
GEOFF: NOT WITH THE WHITE SOX.
WE KNOW HOW THAT MATCHUP WENT IN
2005.
KIMBREL ALLOWS TO THAT.
ALLOWS TONY LA RUSSA WHO IS ON
THAT 2,000-WIN LIST ALLOWED TO
GET MORE WITH THE OPTIONS.
IT'S AMAZING HOW CLOSE HE'S GOT
TO THE 400 PLATEAU.
I HAD THE LUXURY OF SITTING IN
THE SEAT RIGHT HERE WATCHING
JUSTIN VERLANDER GO OUT THERE
GET HIS 3,000th K IN 2013.
THESE MILESTONES REALLY MEAN
SOMETHING TO THESE GUYS AND I
THINK THEY MEAN MORE CONSIDERING
THE WAY THE GAME IS BEING MOLDED
AND SHAPED FOR STARTING PITCHERS
AND EVEN CLOSERS.
SCOTT: 2-2 FROM McCULLERS.
DOZIER HAS A BASE HIT.
SECOND BASE RUNNER OF THE DAY
FOR KANSAS CITY.
SO WE'VE SET IT ALL UP
MILESTONE-WISE AND NOW WE NEED
HELP.
OUR FIRST POLL QUESTION OF THE
DAY IS RIGHT ON YOUR SCREEN.
MOBILE DEVICE.
YOUR COMPUTER.
WHEREVER YOU'RE WATCHING.
WHICH POTENTIAL CAREER MILESTONE
ARE YOU MOST LOOKING FORWARD TO?
DUSTY'S 2,000th WIN, MIGGY'S
3,000th HIT, MAX SCHERZER AT
3,000 K'S OR KIMBREL 400 SAVES.
JEREMY: WELL, BLUMER, WHAT YOU
SAY, YOU HAVE THESE RECORDS THAT
ARE OVER SUSTAINED CAREERS AND
THINGS ARE CHANGING SO
DRAMATICALLY WITH USING BULLPENS
MORE.
JUST THE WAY THE GAME IS PLAYED.
THE WAY IT'S EVALUATED.
SO THESE RECORDS MAY BECOME EVEN
MORE AND MORE RARE TO
ACCOMPLISH.
GEOFF: I AGREE.
THAT'S WHY IT FELT SPECIAL TO
WATCH JUSTIN VERLANDER GET 3,000
STRIKEOUTS AND 300 K'S IN A
SINGLE SEASON BECAUSE HE'S PART
OF THE OLD-SCHOOL MENTALITY,
I'LL GIVE YOU SEVEN AND YOU HAVE
TO DRAG ME OFF THE FIELD.
BUT I AGREE.
THAT'S WHY I THINK SOME OF THOSE
PITCHING MILESTONES OR EVEN
THE,000 HITS, YOU KNOW, ARE
THOSE GUYS GOING TO GET THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES?
BECAUSE MAJOR LEAGUE CAREERS ARE
BEING SHORTENED.
I DON'T GUESS, I KNOW, BECAUSE
OF ANALYTICS.
SCOTT: THOSE GUYS DON'T PLAY
EVERY DAY ANYMORE.
GEOFF: THE AMOUNT OF
OPPORTUNITIES THESE GUYS GET.
JEREMY: THERE'S THAT GOOD
CHANGEUP FROM McCULLERS.
NOT A LOT OF DEPTH, A LOT OF
LIFE TO IT.
RUNS IN THE MID 80'S, FASTBALL
AND HE'LL DESTROY THE LEFTIES
WITH THAT PITCH.
REALLY ONLY USES IT AGAINST THE
LEFTIES.
IT'S BECOME A GREAT PITCH FOR
HIM.
SCOTT: HE USED IT OFTEN WITH THE
DEPTH YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT LAST
TIME AROUND AGAINST SEATTLE,
WENT SIX INNINGS, GAVE UP TWO
RUNS, ONE WALK, EIGHT STRIKEOUTS
IN A 12-3 WIN LAST WEEK AND HE
PICKS UP A STRIKEOUT.
HIS FIRST OF THE DAY.
JEREMY: THAT 6 1/2 IS IN REAL
JEOPARDY IF THE CHANGE AND
CURVEBALL WILL BE SHARP FOR HIM
TODAY.
TRYING TO BATTLING HIM WITH TWO
STRIKES AND NOT MUCH YOU CAN DO
WITH THAT ONE.
GEOFF: AND THAT'S WHAT YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT WITH LEFT-HANDED
HITTERS.
HE WILL USE THAT CURVEBALL A
LITTLE MORE FREQUENTLY IN THE
TWO-STRIKE COUNTS BUT IT'S A
NICE WEAPON TO HAVE THAT
CHANGEUP EARLY IN THE COUNT TO
GET A SWING AND MISS TO GET
AHEAD.
JEREMY: HE LOOKS COMFORTABLE WFT
CHANGEUP -- WITH THE CHANGEUP,
TOO.
HE LOOKS LIKE A FASTBALL.
IT MISSES DOWN MOST TIMES.
SO IT IS A WEAPON MOST LEFTIES
WILL HAVE TO THINK ABOUT ALL DAY
LONG.
GEOFF: YOU CAN SPEAK TO THE
IMPORTANCE OF HOW GOOD A
CHANGEUP CAN BE WHEN YOU HAVE A
GOOD FASTBALL AND YOU DON'T
CHANGE THAT ARM VELOCITY.
YOU
HOW DECEPTIVE THAT CAN BE.
JEREMY: YOU CAN GET A REAL SENSE
FOR IT WHEN YOU PLAY WITH YOUR
KIDS.
WHEN I THROW MY KIDS A CHANGEUP,
THEY HAVE NO IDEA WHAT IS
HAPPENING.
WHY DID I LET GO OF THE BAT?
TEMPERATURES IN THE MIDDLE.
THEY START TO SWING AND REALIZE
THERE IS NO BALL THERE AND
THINGS GET FUNKY.
IF I WAS A YOUNG KID, WHAT PITCH
WHAT I WANT TO DEVELOP?
FASTBALL WITH ARM STRENGTH AS A
YOUNG PLAYER, AND A CHANGEUP.
IT IS FUN TO MAKE PEOPLE
LOOK FOOLISH.
ON A CURVEBALL, WHAT HAPPENED,
WHY DID I MISS THAT PITCH?
SCOTT: MICHAEL A. TAYLOR FOULS
THAT BACK.
I DIDN'T THINK ABOUT THAT.
BIG-LEAGUE PITCHERS GOING UP
AGAINST THEIR KIDS.
GEOFF: CAN WE DIG DEEPER ON THE
PSYCHOLOGY OF THAT?
SCOTT: STATCAST 3D POWERED BY
GOOGLE CLOUD.
HE HAS THE FULL MENU AND IT'S
BEEN WORKING FOR HIM THIS YEAR.
JEREMY: ANY YEAR --
SCOTT: TWO DOWN.
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE SLIDER
HAS BEEN HUGE.
THAT IS A PITCH THAT HAS
SUDDENLY BECOME.
MAYBE HIS BEST WEAPON THAT IS
WHAT I GEOFF: WE HAVE ASKED,
WHEN HE BROKE IN, HE WAS
FASTBALL, CURVEBALL.
HE WAS GOING TO TELEGRAPH AND
TELL EVERYONE HIS BEST PITCH WAS
THE CURVEBALL AND STILL GOT
PEOPLE OUT.
HE MESSED AROUND WITH THE CUTTER
A BIT.
WHEN HE CAME BACK, HE WAS
LOOKING FOR A PITCH TO GET
HITTERS OUT.
SPRING TRAINING, DEVELOPMENT
THAT SLIDER AND IT'S BEEN DEADLY
TO RIGHT-HANDED HITTERS.
WHAT WAS IT LIKE FOR A HITTER TO
DEVELOP THAT EFFECTIVELY.
GEOFF: YOU CANNOT GO TO
NORDSTROM AND PICK UP A GOOD
SLIDER AT THE MEN'S DEPARTMENT.
JEREMY: TO DEVELOP A PITCH ON
HIS OWN NO LESS.
HIS MOTIVATION TO GO OUT THERE
AND DEVELOP THE SLIDER IN SUCH A
SHORT TIME.
SUCH A WEAPON.
SCOTT: IMPRESSIVE SECOND INNING
AFTER THE DOZIER BASE HIT TO THE
RIGHT SIDE.
STRIKE OUT, STRIKE OUT.
LANCE MCCULLERS WITH THE GLOVE
TO FOR NOSH OFF -- FINISH OFF
THE ROYALS IN THE TOP OF THE
SECOND.
>> I HAVE THIS FROM MY TOMMY
JOHN.
I DON'T WANT TO SEE IT, SO I PUT
WHAT LOOKS LIKE A BALL.
♪
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
WE HAVE SOME GOOD MOMENTS, BAD
MOMENTS.
I AM PRETTY GOOD.
I THINK I SEE MAYBE YADIER
MOLINA HAVING THEM?
PRETTY GOOD THING TO DO.
I GOT MINE.
I GOT MY GOLD GLOVE ON THE OTHER
ARM.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
HOPEFULLY I HAVE MORE COMING.
AS A SECOND BASE, THE GOLD GLOVE
SHOULD BE ON MY RIGHT ARM.
>> WHAT IF YOU FILL THE WHOLE
ARM UP?
>> I'M A BIG BOY, SO I HAVE
PLENTY OF ROOM FOR THAT.
SCOTT: MLB GAME OF THE WEEK
PRESENTED BY YOUTUBE TV.
WATCH LIVE TV WITH UNLIMITED
DVR.
TRY IT FOR FREE.
ALSO, FANS WATCHING THE GAME OF
THE WEEK HAVE THE CHANCE TO HAVE
THEIR OWN LISTENING EXPERIENCE.
CLICK THE GEAR AND CHOOSE YOUR
AUDIO TRACK.
PRIMARY BROADCAST, THAT IS US,
HOME AND AWAY, OR SWITCH BACK
AND FORTH.
ALL AUDIO IS SEEMLY --
SEAMLESSLY INTEGRATED INTO YOUR
DEVICE.
SCOTT BRAUN, HERE.
MIKE MINOR BACK TO WORK IN THE
SECOND.
BREGMAN MAKING HIS WAY BACK TO
THE STARTING LINEUP.
FIRST IT IS YOUR GONE, SIX FOOT
FIVE, 230ISH, BIG-TIME POP.
JEREMY: LIVING HERE IN HOUSTON
THE PAST THREE YEARS, GETTING A
CHANCE TO COME TO A COUPLE
BALLGAMES, I HAVE SEEN SOME
ABSOLUTE MOONSHOT BY YORDAN
ALVAREZ THAT SOME HAVE NOT
LANDED.
THIS IS JUST A DANGEROUS YOUNG
HITTER.
IMAGINE IF HE CONTINUES TO
IMPROVE AND GETS MORE
EXPERIENCE.
JEREMY: I COMPLETELY AGREE WITH
THAT.
HE IS STILL LEARNING
WHAT PITCHERS ARE THROWING TO
HIM.
HE HAS HIT UPPER TANKS WITH
EASY, AND PUT ONE UP INTO THAT
ULTRA CLUB BEYOND THAT
RIGHT-FIELD POLE WHICH HAD TO BE
IN THE AIR FOR 35 SECONDS IT
FELT LIKE.
ONCE HE FIGURES OUT HOW TO
INSIDE OUT SOME OF THESE TOUGH
PITCHERS GOING TO THE CRAWFORD
BOXES ARE AT MINUTE MAID PARK HE
COULD BE SCARY.
SCOTT: LEVERAGING THE COUNT.
HE WILL TAKE A PITCH DOWN THE
PIPE.
JEREMY: WE TALK A LOT ABOUT THE
COLORS MIX, THE SAME THING ABOUT
MINOR.
FASTBALL, MOVES IT AROUND.
HE WILL HAVE TO USE THAT SAME
REPERTOIRE HERE AND THROUGHOUT.
SCOTT: ALVAREZ IS 3-9 WITH A
HOMER AND A DOUBLE AGAINST MIKE
MINOR.
JEREMY: WATCHING HIM, BLUMMER,
HAVE YOU FOUND A HOLE AT ALL
THAT YOU MIGHT GO TO?
GEOFF: YOU CAN STAND HIM UP UP
AND IN, DO THE OLD SCHOOL HARD
AND, SOFT AND AWAY.
SOMETIMES HE WILL CHASE DOWN AND
AWAY.
FROM A RIGHT-HANDED PITCHER ANNA
SOMETIMES THAT DOWN AND IN
SLIDER.
BUT HE IS TAKING PITCHES IN OFF
OF THE OUTSIDE CORNER.
SCOTT: MAY HAVE MISSED BY A BIT,
HE IS SHAKING HIS HEAD.
SHAKING HIS HEAD.
LET'S GO DOWN TO BRETT DOLAN.
RICK: MICKEY LOPEZ HAS HAD A
UNIQUE YEAR AND LAST COUPLE OF
WEEKS.
HE WENT 72 GAMES WITHOUT MAKING
AN ERROR, 464 AT-BAT WITHOUT
HITTING A HOME RUN.
HE IS FROM NAPERVILLE, ILLINOIS.
WENT OUT SATURDAY, GOT THREE
BASE HITS, AND TOOK HIS
GIRLFRIEND AND SOON-TO-BE FIANÉE
SIDNEY, GOT ENGAGED.
APPARENTLY WITH THE KIDS IT
DOESN'T COUNT UNLESS YOU HAVE A
VIDEOGRAPHER ON HAND.
CONGRATULATIONS TO NICKY AND
SIDNEY.
IT HAS BEEN QUITE A WEEK FOR
THIS THROWBACK TYPE UP LARRY
NICKY LOPEZ.
SCOTT: PERFECT DAY.
THREE HITS AND AN ENGAGEMENT.
GEOFF: AT WRIGLEY FIELD, HIS OWN
BACKYARD.
SCOTT: THAT IS A BIG LEAGUE
PROPOSAL.
GEOFF: A COUPLE OF SHORTSTOPS
MAKING SOME SMART MOVES.
CARLOS CORREA PROPOSING AFTER
THE WORLD SERIES CHAMPIONSHIP.
JEREMY: CAN YOU IMAGINE IF HE
PROPOSES AFTER AN O'FER DAY?
SCOTT: THAT RING HAS SOME BLING.
JEREMY: SHE WILL HAVE THE
HIGHEST FIELDING PERCENTAGE IN
THE FAMILY AFTER THAT.
SCOTT: WELL DONE, NICKY.
CONGRATULATIONS.
BREGMAN COMING UP AFTER CORREA.
JEREMY: GOOD PITCH THEIR BACKING
HIM OFF.
MAYBE A LITTLE BIT OF THAT SAME
STRATEGY YOU TALKED ABOUT
AGAINST ALVAREZ.
OPENS UP EVERYTHING FOR HIM ON
THIS NEXT PITCH.
GEOFF: SAW HIM AGAIN YULI
GURRIEL AFTER COMING IN WITH THE
BACKDOOR CURVEBALL.
SCOTT: THIS TIME THE FASTBALL
MISSES IN.
JEREMY: GOING BACK TO PITCHING
TO THE KIDS, YOU SHOW THEM TWO
HARD FASTBALLS IN LIKE THAT, I
GET SOME BAD SWINGS.
DASH WILL TAKE SOME TERRIBLE
SWINGS AFTER TWO HARD HEATERS.
SCOTT: GOES THERE AGAIN,
OFFSPEED.
CARLOS CORREA WORKS A WALK.
MY SUPPORT IN THE LINEUP TODAY
FOR CARLOS WITH ALEX BREGMAN
HITTING BEHIND HIM.
HE IS IN THE SIX HOLE FOR NOW.
HE IS BACK.
GEOFF: THEY LOVE HIM HERE.
SCOTT: I WAS JUST GOING TO ASK,
DO YOU THINK THEY LIKE ALEX
BREGMAN IN HOUSTON?
GEOFF: JUST A LITTLE BIT.
.
SCOTT: SOFT TISSUE INJURIES THE
PAST FEW YEARS.
YOU SAY IT'S BEEN A PHYSICAL AND
EMOTIONAL ROLLER COASTER BUT HE
FEELS BETTER THAN LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS.
GOLFS ONE IN FOUL GROUND.
RIVERA LITTLE BUMP AND HE HAS
GOT IT.
DON'T MESS WITH THE SHORTSTOP.
HE JUST GOT ENGAGED, TOO.
GEOFF: ALEX TRIED TO AMBUSH THAT
FIRST PITCH COMING BACK UP THE
INJURED LIST.
JEREMY: I HAVE NIGHTMARES ABOUT
AMBUSHES.
AT 2009, A-ROD CAME OFF OF THE
D.L. AFTER THE SCANDAL,
CHALLENGES HE HAD.
THE FIRST GAME OFF THE D.L.,
LET'S GO HARD IN.
HE WILL BE ABLE TO CATCH UP.
98 ON THE BLACK, NO MOVEMENT,
AND IT IS IN THE LEFT-FIELD
STANDS RIGHT NOW IN CAMDEN
YARDS.
YOU GET AMBUSHED, YOU ARE ON
BOTH ENDS OF IT.
THE OLD I.L. AMBUSH.
SCOTT: FOR BREGMAN, HIS FIRST
GAME SINCE JUNE 16.
KYLE TUCKER WAS ACTIVATED JUST
TODAY, APPEARED IN THE LAST HALF
INNING IN RIGHT FIELD.
AS NOT BEEN IN THE STARTING
LINEUP SINCE AUGUST 13, ON THE
COVID I.L., TESTED POSITIVE HE
SAYS ON THE TRIP TO ANAHEIM.
MINOR SYMPTOMS, BUT HE IS BACK
IN THERE.
THE LINEUP GETTING INTACT FOR
THE STRETCH RUN FOR THE FIRST
PLACE BALLCLUB IN THE A.L. WEST.
GEOFF: WENT ON THE COVID I.L.
AFTER  HITTING HIS FIRST
GRAND SLAM OF HIS CAREER.
SCOTT: A LITTLE BIT, LITTLE BAD.
WAS ACTUALLY ACTIVITY YESTERDAY
FOR CHAS MCCORMICK, WHO HITS THE
I.L. WITH A HAND ISSUE.
I WOULD SAY A UNIQUE STANCE.
GEOFF: UNIQUE SWING ALL THE WAY
AROUND.
A LOT OF QUESTIONS ON WHETHER HE
WOULD GET TO THE INSIDE PITCH.
THERE IS A REASON KYLE TUCKER IS
HERE.
HE IS A VERY GOOD PURE HITTER.
EVEN THOUGH THAT SWING IS
UNIQUE, HE HAS MADE IT WORK FOR
HIM.
WHEN YOU SEE THAT ARM BAR,
LEADING OUT, IT GIVES YOU THE
IMPRESSION THAT YOU CAN GET HIM
INSIDE.
SCOTT: THAT IS IN THERE, 2-2.
HE IS ALL THE WAY IN THE BACK OF
THE BOX, TOO.
DOES HE REMIND YOU OF ANYONE?
GEOFF: I KNOW WHO I'VE BEEN TOLD
HE REMIND A LOT OF PEOPLE OF.
TED WILLIAMS.
THIS IS THE MONIKER EVERYONE
GAVE HIM.
SIMILAR SWINGING, SIMILAR IN
STATURE ALSO.
KIND OF THIN FRAME BUT ALSO
PROVIDES A LOT OF POWER.
SCOTT: MAKES CONTACT INTO LEFT
CENTER.
TAYLOR RUNNING OVER.
HE WILL STOP, CAMP, AND MICKEY
OUT TO RECORD THE INNING.
BREGMAN'S FIRST AT-BAT IN ABOUT
60 GAMES.
NOTHING TO SHOW FOR IT AFTER
TWO.
NO SCORE.
>> NUMBER FIVE, EVERYBODY UP.
>> JEFFREY ROBERT BAGWELL.
>> BAGWELL WITH ANOTHER DRIVE,
WILL IT BE NUMBER TWO OF THE
NIGHT?
>> WHEN YOU PLAY 15 YEARS NEXT
TO SOMEBODY, YOU JUST GROW
ACCUSTOMED TO HE IS GOING TO DO
WHAT HE IS SUPPOSED TO DO EVERY
SINGLE DAY, EVERY SINGLE NIGHT.
>> BAGWELL BAG SOMEONE IN THE
DOME, A THREE-RUN DINGER.
>> HE WAS THE GUY IN THE LINEUP
YOU DIDN'T WANT TO FACE AT THE
END OF THE GAME, THAT IS FOR
SURE.
>> THE PITCH.
RIGHT FIELD, BASE HIT, ASTROS
WIN IT.
BALLGAME.
>> IT IS JUST FUN TO WATCH FROM
AFAR.
BUT WHEN YOU ARE PART OF IT AS A
TEAMMATE, WATCHING THIS GUY DO
THIS EVERY SINGLE NIGHT, IT IS A
GREAT SEAT TO HAVE.
>> BAGWELL DRILLS ONE TO RIGHT
FIELD.
IT IS IN THE FLOWERS, HOME RUN.
>> THE MAN JUST DID A LOT OF
THINGS ON THE BASEBALL FIELD.
HE DIDN'T HAVE THE FASTEST SPEED
ON THE FIELD BUT HE WAS A SMART
BASE RUNNER.
>> BAGWELL STEALS IT, 30/30 MAN,
THE FIRST FULL-TIME FIRST
IN MAJOR LEAGUE HISTORY.
GEOFF: GROUND OUT TO LANCE.
SCOTT: LANCE MCCULLERS JR. IS
GOING UP 9-0-2 FOR KANSAS CITY,
ALMOST WITNESSED A NO-NO FROM
KRIS BUBIC ON AUGUST 21 THIS
PAST WEEKEND.
HE WAS DEALING.
THERE WAS THE 34-MINUTE RAIN
DELAY THAT HALTED THINGS.
THINGS UNRAVELED A BIT, BUT
ULTIMATELY PRODUCED A DYNAMITE
START.
6.1, CAREER-HIGH NINE
STRIKEOUTS.
HE WILL JOIN US FOR THIS HALF
INNING.
YOUTUBE CREATORS, YOU KNOW WHAT
TO DO.
QUESTION THAT YOU HAVE FOR KRIS
BUBIC, WE WILL RELAY THEM OVER
TO CHRIS.
THANK YOU FOR THE TIME.
HOW ARE YOU TODAY?
KRIS: GOOD, HOW ARE YOU DOING?
SCOTT: NOT AS GOOD AS YOU OVER
THE WEEKEND.
TAKE US THROUGH THE ENTIRE
EXPERIENCE FROM START TO FINISH.
YOU HAD TO DEAL WITH SOME MOTHER
NATURE ADVERSITY BUT I HEARD IT
NEVER RAINED, JUST SOME
LIGHTNING GOING ON THERE.
KRIS: DEFINITELY INTERESTING.
THROUGHOUT THE WHOLE GAME,
PRETTY GOOD RHYTHM RIGHT OFF THE
BAT, JUST KIND OF ROLLED
THROUGH.
WHEN YOU ARE IN A GOOD RHYTHM
LIKE THAT, YOU DON'T THINK TOO
MUCH ABOUT ANYTHING, JUST
FOCUSED ON EXECUTING EACH PITCH.
THE RESULTS TAKE CARE OF
THEMSELVES.
THE END OF THE SIXTH INNING, THE
SKY GOT REALLY DARK, STARTED TO
GET WINDY.
I NOTICED THERE WAS RAIN IN THE
FORECAST, THE GROUNDS CREW WAS
GETTING PREPPED TO COVER THE
FIELD.
THEY PUT UP A NOTIFICATION ON
THE SCOREBOARD THAT THERE WAS
LIGHTNING IN THE AREA SO THEY
WERE GOING TO HALT IT FOR THAT,
BUT YOU ARE RIGHT, THERE WAS
NEVER ANY RAIN.
IT WAS MORE ABOUT THE LIGHTNING
THAN ANYTHING ELSE.
IT IS WHAT IT IS.
THAT IS BASEBALL AND MOTHER
NATURE.
THINGS WE CANNOT CONTROL.
GEOFF: PRETTY AMAZING THAT YOU
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT
AT WRIGLEY FIELD.
AT WHAT POINT DID YOU REALIZE
IT, WAS IT MORE SPECIAL DOING IT
IN A PLACE LIKE WRIGLEY FIELD?
KRIS: FOR SURE.
I DON'T WANT TO GIVE UP ANYTHING
ANYTIME I GO OUT, SO HONESTLY, I
KNOW FROM THE FIRST INNING,
NOTHING HAS HAPPENED IN THE HIT
COLUMN YET.
AS YOU GO ON, I WAS NOT FOCUSED
ON THAT, AND THEN YOU GET THAT
DELAY, START TO THINK ABOUT IT A
LITTLE BIT.
THAT WAS MY FIRST TIME AT
WRIGLEY, TOO.
GETTING TO DO IT AT A PLACE LIKE
THAT, AS HISTORIC AS WRIGLEY IS,
AN INCREDIBLE EXPERIENCE.
JEREMY: JEREMY GUTHRIE HERE,
FORMER STANFORD ALUMNI.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU ON.
KRIS: YES, SIR.
GEOFF: GO BEARS.
JEREMY: YOU CAN HAVE THE AX.
WE WILL KEEP THE WORLD SERIES
RUNS GOING.
NOT TOO OFTEN A PLAYER GETS TO
TAKE A NO-HITTER DEEP INTO THAT
GAME.
YOU ARE EARLY IN YOUR CAREER.
KRIS: THIS IS REALLY MY FIRST
FALL CRACK AT A BIG-LEAGUE
SEASON.
LAST YEAR I WAS UP, BUT WITH A
SHORTENED YEAR, DID NOT GET THE
FULL EXPERIENCE.
THIS YEAR, GOING THROUGH THE UPS
AND DOWNS OF A NORMAL SEASON.
I HAVE GONE THROUGH MY BUMPS
THIS YEAR, FORTUNATE TO MAKE
SOME ADJUSTMENTS, ABLE TO HOLD
MY OWN, PITCH AS WELL AS I CAN.
TO HAVE A START LIKE I JUST HAD,
EVERYTHING IS KIND OF CLICKING.
KIND OF IRONIC BECAUSE THE START
BEFORE THAT WAS PROBABLY THE
WORST START OF MY CAREER, DID
NOT MAKE IT OUT OF THE SECOND
INNING.
JUST TO BE ABLE TO BOUNCE BACK
LIKE THAT IS SOMETHING THAT I
PRIDE MYSELF ON.
THAT IS HOW IT WILL BE SOMETIMES
IN THIS GAME, SOMETIMES YOU
DON'T HAVE YOUR BEST STUFF.
YOU HAVE TO GRIND THROUGH IT AND
FIND YOUR WAY THROUGH YOUR
OUTINGS.
JEREMY: I APPRECIATE WHAT YOU
SAY THERE, COMING OFF OF THE
WORST START IN YOUR YOUNG
CAREER.
THAT SHOWS SUCH GREAT RESILIENCY
TO HAVE THAT TYPE OF GAME.
EVERYTHING FOR YOU WAS WORKING,
THE BREAKING BALL, THE CHANGEUP
WAS DIALED IN.
THE FASTBALL MAYBE EVEN HAD SOME
EXTRA UMPH, MAYBE FROM THE
PREVIOUS START.
WHAT DO YOU CONSIDER YOUR
STRENGTHS AS A PITCHER WHEN IT
COMES TO THE INDIVIDUAL PITCHES?
KRIS: YOU MENTIONED THE
CHANGEUP, PROBABLY MY VETERAN --
BREAD-AND-BUTTER.
SCOTT: WHIT MERRIFIELD IS TOAST
AT THIRD.
THIS TEAM CAN REALLY RUN.
NOT EASY TO CATCH WHIT
MERRIFIELD.
HAS NOT HAPPENED MUCH THE
SEASON.
THE ONE OUT DOUBLE AND THEN
CAUGHT STEALING FOR JUST THIRD
TIME THIS YEAR.
37 STOLEN BAGS, SECOND BEST IN
BASEBALL.
KRIS: THE BREAD AND BUTTER HAS
ALWAYS BEEN MY CHANGEUP.
I HAVE BEEN HURT A LITTLE BIT
THIS YEAR, LEAVING TOO MANY
ELEVATED, MIDDLE OF THE ZONE.
WHEN IT IS WORKING, IT IS
WORKING.
TO ADD THE CURVEBALL INTO THE
MIX, AS GOOD AS IT'S BEEN
RECENTLY.
AND THEN MOVING THE FASTBALL
AROUND, I WILL NOT BLOW ANYONE
AWAY WITH VELO, BUT JUST MOVING
AROUND THE FASTBALL, HAVING A
GOOD CHANGEUP HELPS THE FASTBALL
PLAY UP A LITTLE BIT.
THAT IS REALLY MY GAME, MIXING
AND MATCHING, USING THE
CHANGEUP, ESPECIALLY AS I PHASE
A LOT OF RIGHT-HANDED HITTERS.
SCOTT: I WILL SNEAK ONE IN
BEFORE WE HEAD TO BREAK.
PITCHER, PLAYER YOU LOOKED UP TO
MOST GROWING UP?
KRIS: CLAYTON KERSHAW.
SCOTT: LOVE IT.
QUICK INNING.
ENJOY THE COMBO.
LET'S DO IT AGAIN SOON.
ROYAL STARTER KRIS BUBIC WITH US
AS THE ROYALS -- EVENTUALLY HAD
MERRIFIELD OUT AT THIRD.
NO SCORE HERE IN MID THREE.
>> HE JUST SMOKES IT.
>> FORGET ABOUT IT.
>> GREAT BASEBALL RIGHT THERE.
>> THAT ONE IS GOING TO GO.
>> THAT BALL WAS CRUSHED.
>> THIS IS GOING TO DO IT.
>> STRIKE THREE.
>> THAT WAS A GREAT PLAY.
>> I TALKED ABOUT HIS FIELDING
SKILLS, THAT WAS REMARKABLE.
♪
>> SOMETHING LIKE THIS IS WHAT
THEY CAME FOR.
>> BACK!
>> 22 THROW IN LITTLE FLARE IN
THERE.
SURE, I BELIEVE YOU.
SICK.
NOBODY HITS THE ROYALS.
NOBODY.
SCOTT: TELL THEM, WHIT.
WE WILL HAVE EVEN MORE OF THAT
BEAUTIFUL CONTENT AND MUCH MORE
FOR YOU FROM TWO HIT WHIT.
SECOND BASEMAN WHO PLAYS EVERY
DAY FOR KANSAS CITY.
HE IS OUR MAN WITH A MICROPHONE
TODAY ON YOUTUBE.
MIKE MINOR HERE IN THE HOME
THIRD AGAINST MYERS, MALDONADO,
ALTUVE DUE UP FOR HOUSTON.
I LOVE HOW WE MIC UP THE PLAYERS
EACH WEEK.
IT IS UNIQUE FROM EACH PLAYER
BUT THE CONVERSATION THAT WHIT
MERRIFIELD HAS -- HE HAS JOKES.
GEOFF: HE IS GOOD, PLAYS HARD
OUT THERE, HAS A GOOD FEEL FOR
THE PERSONALITIES AROUND HIM.
NICKY LOPEZ SAYING YOU ARE
ADDING THE FLARE TO IT WHEN IT
IS A PRETTY MAX EFFORT TYPE OF
CATCH.
JEREMY: FOR THE YOUTUBE VIEWERS,
YOU ARE IDEAL FOR SOMEONE WHO
FORGETS HE IS MIC'D UP.
JEREMY: --  GEOFF: LIKE THE GUYS
AROUND HIM FORGETTING THAT HE IS
MIC'D UP.
JEREMY: OR THE BROADCASTERS
FORGETTING.
SCOTT: THAT IS O'HEARN.
MYERS IS RETIRED.
OUR FIRST POLL IS COMPLETE.
POTENTIAL CAREER MILESTONE YOU
ARE MOST LOOKING FORWARD TO.
MIGGY, THE MAN OF THE MOMENT,
JUST HIT HIS 500 HOME RUN, NOW
CHASING 3000 HITS.
47% SAY WE ARE LOOKING FOR
MIGGY.
GEOFF: I THINK THAT IS A GOOD
ONE TO LOOK FOR.
3000 HITS IS A UNIQUE THRESHOLD
TO GET TO, AND TO DO THAT WITH
THE POWER THAT HE HAS MATCHED
ALREADY 500 HOME RUNS,
INCREDIBLE STUFF.
ONE OF THE BEST RIGHT-HANDED
HITTERS OF ALL TIME, ONE OF THE
BETTER DUDES TO TALK TO ON THE
FIELD.
HE IS FRIENDLY AS HECK.
JEREMY: ONE OF THE QUESTIONS I
GET, WHO DID YOU FEAR THE MOST,
WHO DID YOU HAVE SUCCESS
AGAINST?
MIGGY DIDN'T FALL INTO EITHER
ONE OF THOSE.
ONE OF THE MOST FUN GUYS TO
PITCH AGAINST.
HE IS ONE OF THOSE GUYS WHO IS
COMPLIMENT YOU ON YOUR PITCHES.
WHEN YOU THROW A PITCH IN THE
DIRT -- NICE PITCH.
WHEN HE TAKES IT, NICE TAKE.
SOMEONE ASKED ME THE OTHER DAY,
DID YOU GIVE UP ANY HOME RUNS TO
MIGGY?
I AM PRETTY MUCH EVERYONE ELSE
HAS.
ONE OF MY GREATEST MEMORIES WAS
HIM IN KANSAS CITY IN 2012,
SECURE THE TRIPLE CROWN.
AS HE CAME OFF THE FIELD, OUR
GREAT FANS IN KANSAS CITY GAVE
HIM A STANDING OVATION, AND IT
GAVE ME CHILLS.
WE WERE ON THE TOP STEP CLAPPING
FOR HIM.
TO SEE THE FANCIER VOTING FOR
3000, HE IS EASY TO ROOT FOR.
GEOFF: VERY EASY TO FOR.
SCOTT: PROPS TO THE FANS NORTH
OF THE BORDER, TOO, IN CANADA.
SAME THING FOR MIGGY.
DID AN EXCELLENT JOB WITH THE
OVATION, APPRECIATION OF WHAT HE
HAS DONE FOR THIS GAME.
MALDONADO SMASHES ONE FOR THE
CRAWFORD BOXES AND BEYOND!
HOUSTON IS ON THE BOARD FIRST,
THANKS TO MALDI.
HIS 10TH OF THE SEASON.
JEREMY: HE GOT HIS FASTBALL
AHEAD IN THE COUNT,
MIDDLE-MIDDLE.
DIDN'T MISS IT.
GEOFF: PROBABLY FEELING PRETTY
GOOD AFTER CUTTING DOWN WHIT
MERRIFIELD AT THIRD BASE.
ALL OF A SUDDEN BACK AT THE
PLATE AND HE GETS THAT PITCH TO
DRIVE.
10TH HOME RUN ON THE SEASON FOR
MARTIN MONO VOTTO -- MALDONADO.
JEREMY: HOW MANY TIMES DO YOU
SEE IT, GUY GETS OUT A RUNNER AT
THIRD, HITS IT TO THE CRAWFORD
BOXES.
SCOTT: HE IS 5-13 IN HIS CAREER
AGAINST MIKE MINOR.
TOP OF THE GAUNTLET.
JOSE ALTUVE, WHO POPPED OUT
FIRST TIME AROUND.
JEREMY: BLUMMER, DID YOU KNOW
GUYS AHEAD OF TIME THAT YOU WERE
SUCCESSFUL AGAINST?
GEOFF: OH, YEAH.
MY LIST WAS A LITTLE BIT SHORTER
THAN MOST GUYS, SO I KNEW WHO I
COULD GET AFTER, BUT THERE WERE
CERTAIN MOMENTS IN MY CAREER
WHERE I KNEW I WOULD BE STARTING
WITH A PARTICULAR TEAM AND
PITCHER ON THE MOUND.
SCOTT: THAT IS PULLED DOWN THE
LINE IF IT IS FAIR --
IT IS A FOUL BALL.
PROBABLY WAS GOING TO HIT OFF
THE WALL IN DEEP LEFT IF HE DID
NOT HOOK IT SO MUCH.
ALTUVE WITH TWO STRIKES AGAINST
HIM.
SUDDENLY, THE ASTROS SEEING MIKE
MINOR FOR THE SECOND TIME IN THE
ORDER, FEELING IT LATELY.
THIS ONE IS PULLED ON THE GROUND
FOR RIVERA.
TWO DOWN.
WE DID SEE THE FULL ARSENAL
ALREADY FIRST TIME THROUGH FOR
MIKE MINOR.
IT IS NOT LIKE HE WAS WRITING
JUST ONE OR TWO PITCHES.
THE ASTROS REALLY MAKE YOU WORK.
WE ARE SEEING THEN EVIDENCED THE
SECOND TIME AROUND WHEN THEY CAN
REALLY PUNISH YOU.
JEREMY: YOU THINK ABOUT GREAT
LINEUPS YOU FACE, THAT IS THE
GRIND OF THE ASTROS.
YOU CANNOT JUST ESTABLISH THE
FASTBALL AND SAVE THE BREAKING
BALL FOR THE SECOND AND THIRD
TIME THROUGH.
HE HAS HAD TO WORK THROUGH THE
SECOND, WILL HAVE TO WORK
THROUGH THE THIRD IF HE GETS TO
IT.
HALLMARK OF A GOOD HITTING CLUB.
SCOTT: DIAZ GOES AFTER THE FIRST
PITCH.
MARY FIELD, AND THAT IS THE
INNING.
MARTIN MALDONADO STRIKES BIG,
AND HE HAS DONE IT BEFORE
AGAINST MIKE MINOR.
MY SUCCESS AGAINST THE ROYALS
STARTER.
HE POWERS UP IN A HUGE WAY, OFF
THE FACING BEHIND THE CRAWFORD
BOXES, ADMIRING IT.
HOUSTON CRACKS THE ICE FIRST.
IT IS 1-0.
♪
>> HEART IS PALPITATING.
YES!
>> 0-2 FROM MINOR TO TIM
ANDERSON.
THAT WAS A PINATA SWING FROM TIM
IF THERE ARE FUN SIZED MILKY
WAY'S FOLLOWING OUT, WE KNOW
WHY.
>> NEWMAN, OH, NO.
AND IT DROPS FAIR.
NOT ONLY IS IT NOT CAUGHT, IT
DROPS IN FAIR TERRITORY.
>> GROUND BALL TO THIRD.
BRINSON TRIPPED OUT OF THE BOX.
>> CROSSED HIM UP.
HAS TO COME BACK AND CATCH HIS
LEGS.
>> FOULED BACK.
THAT IS US.
GOT IT.
YES!
>> YOU DID IT.
CANNOT BELIEVE IT.
>> NO WAY.
>> WE CAUGHT THAT MOMENT.
SCOTT: WE ARE INTO THE FOURTH,
CHECKING OUT SOME UNIQUE
OPPONENTS OF BALLPARKS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
YOU LIKE TO TRAIN HERE IN
HOUSTON.
IT WAS JUST ON A RIDE AFTER
MARTIN MALDONADO WENT LONG.
HAVE YOU BEEN IN THE POOL
IN ARIZONA?
JEREMY: I SHAGGED FROM THE POOL
IN ARIZONA, AND I CAUGHT A BALL.
THE RIGHT FIELDER LOOKS BACK.
I FORGET WHO IT WAS.
THE ROOF WAS OPEN.
IT WAS A PERFECT STORM.
SCOTT: GEOFF, THEN ON THE TRAIN
OUT THERE?
GEOFF: I HAVE NOT.
OUR SIDELINE GIRL JULIE MORALES
WAS THERE.
SHE GOT TO RING THE BELL, DO THE
WHOLE ENJOYMENT PROCESS WITH THE
TRAIN.
I HAVE NOT, BUT I HAD BEEN ON
BERNIE BREWER'S SLIDE.
I DID NOT LIKE IT ONE BIT.
I AM  NOT A HEIGHTGUY, AND THE
PLATFORM IT IS ON IS A GRATED
FLOOR, SO YOU CAN SEE THE
BOTTOM.
JEREMY: I WOULD STICK TO THE
COCA-COLA BOTTLE.
I, TOO, HAVE BEEN ON THE BERNIE
BREWER'S SLIDE.
THE FACT THAT HE SWINGS ON IT,
YOU ARE PROBABLY FALLING LIKE
MYSELF.
GEOFF: I WAS HUGGING THE RAILING
THE ENTIRE WAY.
SCOTT: SALVADOR PEREZ ON THOSE
THAT PITCH FROM LANCE MCCULLERS
JR.
ALMOST THE SAME SPOT AS
MALDONADO.
HE GOES BIG.
BOTH CATCHERS ON EITHER SIDE
WITH ONE OF PEACE.
NUMBER 34 OF THE SEASON FOR
SALVI.
JEREMY: HE IS ON PACE TO BECOME
JUST THE SIXTH PITCHER TO HIT 40
HOME RUNS IN THE HISTORY OF THE
GAME.
CONSIDER THAT FOR A SECOND, AND
CRUSHED IT.
GOT HIS PITCH, DID NOT MISS IT.
GEOFF: WHAT I THINK IS MOST
IMPRESSIVE ABOUT SALVADOR PEREZ,
WE SEE THAT FASTBALL OVER THE
PLATE THAT HE GETS TO, THE FACT
THAT HE IS DOING AT KAUFFMAN
STADIUM.
THIS IS NOT A HITTER FRIENDLY
BALLPARK.
YOU REALLY HAVE TO DRIVE IT OUT
THERE.
HE IS NOT DOING IT JUST TO THE
PULL SIDE, HE IS DOING TO CENTER
AND RIGHT.
JUST A REMARKABLE HITTER, WHAT
HE'S BEEN ABLE TO DO.
TO BE ABLE TO ADJUST TO THE
MODERN GAME WHEN EVERYONE IS
PUMPING 90 MILE-PER-HOUR.
JEREMY: TO DO IT IN THAT
BALLPARK, IT WAS A LUXURY FOR ME
TO BE THERE FOR AS MANY STARTS
AS I GOT TO MAKE IN KAUFFMAN.
HE IS DOING IT TO ALL PARTS.
I GOT A CHANCE TO SEE HIM.
HE TALKED ABOUT THE WAY HE IS
WORKING WITH THE HITTING
COACHES.
HE IS TIRELESS, WORKS EVERY DAY
IN THE WINTER.
WHEN HE HAD TOMMY JOHN SURGERY
IN 2019, YOU BETTER BELIEVE HE
WAS WORKING ON EVERYTHING.
TO SEE HIM HITTING LIKE HE HAS
BEEN THE PAST TWO YEARS, DOESN'T
SURPRISE ME.
SCOTT: OUT TO VEGAS THE NICE HOP
FROM BENINTENDI AND PUT SOME
AWAY.
WE SAW SALVI WITH THE INSTANT
DIG ME VIDEO LOOK.
CHECKING OUT THE TABLET TO SEE
HOW HARD IT WENT.
JEREMY: WHAT WERE OUR STATCAST
NUMBERS ON THAT?
GEOFF: EXIT VELO WAS 199.
DISTANCE WAS 399.
MALDONADO BEAT HIM, COUNTS THE
SAME, BUT IF WE ARE REALLY
BREAKING THINGS DOWN.
JEREMY: HE WILL BE IN THE WEIGHT
ROOM FOR NEXT OR 10 MINUTES IF
HE HEARS THE BROADCAST.
GEOFF: WOULD YOU BE SURPRISED IF
I SAID IT WOULD ONLY GET OUT OF
28 OF 30 BALLPARKS?
WOULD NOT HAVE GOTTEN OUT IN
GLOBE FIELD OR P.N.C. PARK, THE
NEW TEXAS RANGERS STADIUM UP
NORTH.
JEREMY: I HEARD A BROADCAST NOT
LONG AGO, THE MOST SPACIOUS
LEFT-FIELD OUT AT P.N.C. PARK.
GEOFF: EVER HAD A CHANCE TO PLAY
THERE?
JEREMY: I HIT MY DOUBLE IN THAT
GAME TO RIGHT FIELD.
GEOFF: SMART HITTING.
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU ARE DOING.
OR DID YOU GET BEAT?
JEREMY: I CLOSE MY EYES AND
SLUNG IN THERE WAS A NOISE.
HE TOOK TWO STEPS IN, SLIPPED,
WENT OVER HIS HEAD.
NOT MUCH OF A HITTER.
GEOFF: HELPS YOUR O.P.S.
SCOTT: THAT IS HOW YOU HIT
BIG-LEAGUE PITCHING, KIDS.
CLOSE YOUR EYES AND SWING.
GEOFF: LET'S GET BACK TO
PITCHING TO KIDS.
SCOTT: MCCULLERS HAS TWO STRIKES
ON DOZIER, WHO KEEPS HIS AT-BAT
ALIVE.
JEREMY: WE TALKED ABOUT THE
SLIDER THAT MCCULLERS HAS BEEN
THROWING.
HE THROWS A 50% OF THE TIME TO
RIGHT-HANDED HITTERS.
HE STRUCK OUT A GUY EARLIER ON
THE FULL SLIDER.
PEOPLE WILL THROW IT AT ANY
POINT IN TIME.
IT IS JUST A SWEEPER AND
DISAPPEARS FOR THE RIGHT-HANDED
HITTER A LOT OF TIME.
SCOTT: HOW INCREDIBLE IS IT TO
IMPLEMENT A PITCH IN THE MIDDLE
OF YOUR CAREER, IN SPRING
TRAINING, AND SUDDENLY IT IS
YOUR BEST PITCH THAT VERY SAME
SEASON?
STATCAST POWERED BY GOOGLE CLOUD
IS HOOKING US UP WITH SOME ELITE
MEMBERS WITH THE SLIDER.
LOOK AT DOZIER GO.
ANOTHER HIT, SAME SPOT AS HE DID
IN THE SECOND.
JEREMY: GREAT PIECE OF HITTING
RIGHT THERE, NOT TRY TO DO TOO
MUCH WITH TWO STRIKES.
THAT IS WHAT THE ROYALS DO.
THEY WANT TO FORCE YOU TO MAKE A
PLAY.
THAT SLIDER LEFT OVER THE PLATE,
SO IT IS EASIER THAN THE SWEEPER
OFF THE PLATE FOR HIM.
YOU ARE RIGHT, THERE ARE SOME
GUYS THAT ARE REALLY GOOD AT
HELPING.
JAMES SHIELDS WAS ONE OF MY
FAVORITE TEAMMATES.
HE WAS A GUY THAT COULD HELP YOU
DEVELOP A PITCH.
IN 2014, HE HELPED ME THROUGH A
CUTTER, WHICH WAS HELPFUL FOR
ME DOWN THE STRETCH.
IT WAS A PITCH THAT I WENT FROM
NEVER THROWING TO THROWING ABOUT
15 TIMES AGAIN.
THESE PITCHERS, WE ARE ATHLETES.
YOU CAN LEARN THINGS MIDSEASON
OR OFF-SEASON AND DO BIG THINGS.
MCCULLERS HAS THE BUILD, HIS DAD
PLAYED IN THE BIG LEAGUES.
IT DOESN'T SURPRISE ME THAT HE
CAN LEARN IT BUT YOU ARE STILL
IMPRESSED BY THE FACT THAT IT
HAS BECOME SUCH A GOOD WEAPON
FOR HIM.
SCOTT: INITIALLY THE PITCHING
COACH BRENT STROM SAID IT'S A
NEW TOY, LET'S NOT GET CARRIED
AWAY.
YOU WATCH IT AFTER A FEW STARTS,
DO WHATEVER YOU WANT.
GEOFF: THAT IS I THINK HOW IT
PLAYED OUT.
IT WILL BE CUTE TO THROW IT OUT
THERE ONCE IN A WHILE.
YOU TAKE BRENT STROM AND AT HIS
WORD.
HE SAYS IT WAS A NEW TOY THAT HE
WAS TINKERING WITH, BUT ALL OF A
SUDDEN IT WAS WIPED OUT, GOT A
BETTER FEEL FOR IT.
IT WAS DEVASTATING.
.139 BATTING AVERAGE OVERALL
THIS DEEP INTO THE SEASON SAYS A
LOT ABOUT WHAT HE CAN DO WITH
THE PITCH.
JEREMY: IT WOULD BE NICE TO ADD
A PITCHING TO YOUR REPERTOIRE
THAT YOU ARE NOT GOING TO GIVE
UP HITS ON.
GEOFF: HE IS ALREADY AN
ALL-STAR.
ADDS ANOTHER PITCH FOR A HITTER?
WHEN YOU SEE LANCE --
SCOTT: RUNNERS GOING, AND HE IS
OUT!
MALDONADO DID IT AGAIN.
HE CATCHES HUNDRED DOZIER.
GEOFF: HIS NICKNAME IS THE
MACHETE.
CUTTING RUNNERS DOWN.
SCOTT: 12 TIMES THIS SEASON.
SALVI HAS DONE IT 11 TIMES THIS
SEASON.
WE ARE SEEING A TRUE BATTLE OF
CATCHERS BEHIND THE DISH.
THE ROYALS LIKE TO GO AFTER
BASES AS MUCH AS ANY TEAM IN
BASEBALL, BUT TODAY, MARTIN
MALDONADO AS THEIR NUMBER.
CORREA WITH THE CATCH AND TAG.
FIREBALL REVIEW IN THE
COMMENTARY SECTION SAID CATCHERS
SHOWING OFF TODAY.
>> ANYONE WHO MET SANDEEP DURING
HIS 10 YEARS WITH THE SHERIFFS
DEPARTMENT WILL TELL YOU HE WAS
ONE-OF-A-KIND.
HE WAS HOUSTON'S FIRST SIKH
DEPUTY, WORKED AROUND-THE-CLOCK
DURING HURRICANE HARVEY, AND
EVEN WENT TO CARLOS CORREA'S
NATIVE PUERTO RICO WHEN A
HURRICANE HIT THERE.
>> KNOWING THAT HE HELP PEOPLE
HERE IN HOUSTON AFTER HURRICANE
HARVEY AND THEN PUERTO RICO
AFTER MARIA, THAT WAS THE REASON
THAT I WANTED TO SHOW HIS FAMILY
MY RESPECT AND BE ABLE TO MEET
THEM.
>> IN LATE SEPTEMBER, THE
42-YEAR-OLD WAS MURDERED MAKING
A TRAFFIC STOP.
SOON AFTER, CORREA ASKED THE
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT IF YOU
COULD VISIT THE FAMILY.
>> THREE KIDS, I JUST WANTED TO
GO OVER AND SAY HIGH, MAKE SURE
THAT THEY KNEW THAT THEY HAD THE
CITIES SUPPORT.
>> IN RETURN, THEY GAVE HIM
PERSPECTIVE.
>> 0-4, I'M COMPLAINING ABOUT
IT, AND THERE ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE OUT THERE THAT HAVE IT
HARDER THAN ME.
IT MAKES YOU APPRECIATE WHAT YOU
HAVE, MAKES YOUR PERSPECTIVE A
LITTLE DIFFERENT.
SCOTT: ONE PER SIDE, BOTTOM
FAVOR IN HOUSTON, TEXAS.
MICHAEL A. TAYLOR AND THE KANSAS
CITY ROYALS BACK ON DEFENSE.
MIKE MINOR ON THE MOUND.
YULI, 0-1 WITH A STRIKEOUT.
IT IS THE TWO CATCHERS STRIKING
BIG.
MALDONADO AND PEREZ, SOLO HOME
RUNS.
THAT IS SMACKED AND TWISTING
FOUL.
ALSO THE ARMS SO FAR TODAY FROM
THE CATCHERS.
GEOFF: UNBELIEVABLE.
SCOTT: REALLY NICE.
POWER ARMS, ACCURATE ARMS BEHIND
THE PLATE.
SCOTT: GURRIEL UP THE MIDDLE.
THERE IS MERRIFIELD.
JEREMY: AFTER LAST SERIES IN
KANSAS CITY WHERE THEY RAN --
CASTRO HAD A COUPLE OF CAUGHT
STEALING'S.
THE ROYALS RAN SUCCESSFULLY LAST
WEEK.
CLEARLY, THEY ARE MUCH MORE
PREPARED, SAID WE HAVE TO SHUT
DOWN THE RUNNING GAME, WHICH FOR
THE ROYALS REALLY PUTS A CRAIG
IN THEIR OFFENSE.
THEY MADE SOME ADJUSTMENTS.
GEOFF: WHAT WAS INTERESTING
ABOUT THAT SERIES THEY HAD IN
KANSAS CITY, THOSE GAMES, MALTA
ONLY GOT TWO GAMES.
JASON CASTRO HAVE THE OTHER TWO.
THE ADJUSTMENT HERE AT HOME
AGAINST KANSAS CITY --
SCOTT: THERE, YORDAN ALVAREZ
MUSCLES UP!
2-1, ASTROS.
26 ON THE YEAR.
FLEX.
GEOFF: THAT IS THE SCARY PART OF
YORDAN ALVAREZ IN THIS BALLPARK.
EVEN THOUGH IT LOOKED LIKE HE
FOUGHT THAT PITCH OFF, IT STILL
JUMPED OFF THE BAT AT 107.3
MILES PER HOUR.
PRETTY MUCH A LASER BEAM OUT OF
THE LEFT.
IF THIS YOUNG MAN COULD FIGURE
OUT GOING TO LEFT IN THIS
BALLPARK, IT IS FRIGHTENING.
JEREMY: YOU START DOING THINGS
LIKE THAT WHEN YOU START
THINKING ABOUT THINGS LIKE BIG
PAPI.
HE COULD TAKE ANY PITCH HE
WANTED TO LEFT FIELD AT FENWAY.
BUT TO TRY TO BUST HIM HARD IN.
GEOFF: GREAT COMP.
JEREMY: IF HE CAN CONTINUE TO DO
THAT AND TRUST IN LEFT FIELD
HERE AT MINUTE MADE, YOU ARE
RIGHT, THE AMOUNT OF DAMAGE HE
WILL BE ABLE TO DO.
GEOFF: TRUST IS A GREAT WORD FOR
IT, LET THAT BALL GET DEEP.
I THINK DAVID ORTIZ MAY HAVE HAD
AN ISSUE WITH THAT ALSO, BUT
ONCE HE FIGURED THAT OUT, NEXT
LEVEL ALL-STAR D.H. FOR THE REST
OF HIS CAREER.
SCOTT: CORREA PULL BALL, GOBBLED
UP AT THE CORNER.
NICE JOB AT THE HOT CORNER.
GEOFF: LEFT ON LEFT, YOU HAVE TO
KEEP TOUCH FRONT SHOULDER CLOSE.
YORDAN ALVAREZ HAS BETTER
NUMBERS AS FAR AS BATTING
AVERAGE IS CONCERNED AGAINST
LEFT-HANDED PITCHING THE SEASON.
A LOT OF IT IS BECAUSE HE KEEPS
THAT FRONT SIDE CLOSED SO LONG
AND HIS HEAD STAYS SO STILL.
YOU CAN SEE HIM REENACTING, KEEP
THE HEAD STILL, WHAT THAT, AND
WHEN YOU RECOGNIZE IT, LET IT
GO.
JEREMY: IT IS NOT THAT HARD.
SCOTT: YOU JUST NEED BIG, BROAD
SHOULDERS.
GEOFF: NICE TO BE ABLE TO WALK
UP THERE WITH AN ADONIS-LIKE
FRAME AND BE ABLE TO DO THAT.
SCOTT: BREGMAN, HIS SECOND
AT-BAT OF THE DAY.
HE LIKED HIS FIRST PITCH IN THE
SECOND, POPPED UP IN FOUL
GROUND.
JEREMY: NOT SURE HOW OUR
YOUTUBERS ARE ON LISTENING TO
THIS GAME BUT I'M A BIG SHOE
FAN.
I'M NOTICING SOMETHING WITH
BREGMAN.
DID HE SWITCH COMPANIES?
I AM SEEING BLACK.
HE ALWAYS WORE WHITE.
GEOFF: HE HAD THE ADIDAS.
JEREMY: HE HAS NIKES ON.
GEOFF: THOSE LOOK LIKE OLD
FAITHFUL.
JEREMY: THOSE LOOK LIKE THEY GOT
THOSE OUT OF BAGWELL'S LOCKER
BACK IN THE DAY, WHICH TELLS ME
THAT HE IS SWITCHING OVER TO
NIKE, AND THEY HAD NOT MADE HIM
A BEAUTIFUL CUSTOM ONE YET.
I ALWAYS PAY ATTENTION TO
SNEAKERS.
GEOFF: IN THE GAME, THERE IS SO
MUCH PERSONALITY, THEY CAN GO
OUT AND HAVE DIFFERENT COLORS,
AS OPPOSED TO WHEN WE WERE
PLAYING.
JEREMY: BACK IN OUR DAY --
SCOTT: BREGMAN, HARD CONTACT,
RIGHT CENTER FIELD.
AND HE IS IN BUSINESS.
BASE HIT WITH TWO OUTS IN THE
FOURTH.
GEOFF: HAS TO FEEL GOOD FOR ALEX
GETTING BACK ON THE BOARD.
SCOTT: GOT TO BE THE SHOES.
JEREMY: ONE OF MY FAVORITES WAS
TO MAKE CUSTOMS.
THERE ARE CUSTOM CLEATS, THERE
ARE GUYS THAT PAINT THEM UP ALL
AROUND THE COUNTRY.
MY FAVORITE WAS TO SEND THEM TO
GET A SPIKE PUT ON A SHOE.
GEOFF: I WAS PLAYING IN
MONTRÉAL.
WEARING A NORMALSPIKE ON THE
TURF THEY HAD UP THERE WAS
MISERABLE.
I WOULD SEND IN A COUPLE OF
PAIR, BASKETBALL SHOES, AND THEY
WOULD ATTACH THEM.
JEREMY: HOW DID YOU FIGURE OUT
HOW TO DO THAT?
IT TOOK ME A COUPLE OF YEARS TO
FIGURE THAT OUT.
GEOFF: THERE WAS SOMEBODY IN OUR
EQUIPMENT ROOM, SOMEBODY KNEW
SOMEONE.
THE INFORMATION WAS MORE
AVAILABLE.
JEREMY: IT IS A LOT EASIER TO
CUSTOMIZE A SHOE, THAT IS TO
CUSTOMIZE A CLEAT.
YOU ALWAYS WANT YOUR PLAYER
ADDITION AND THERE ARE SO FEW OF
THEM.
I SEE THE BLACK SHOE AND IT
MAKES ME THINK THAT HE IS
PROBABLY WAITING FOR HIS PLAYER
ADDITION.
GEOFF: I'LL BE CURIOUS TO ASK
HIM.
EARLIER IN THE YEAR, HE HAD A
WHITE SHOE, MORE FLASH TO IT.
THESE SEEM LIKE A THROWBACK.
JEREMY: THE OTHER THING IS THAT
WE JUST HIT HIM WITH THE BUS.
HIGH, HIGH REWARD TODAY ON THE
BROADCAST.
SCOTT: THAT MISSES WIDE TO
TUCKER.
I AM SURE HIS AGENT IS TRYING TO
GET ONE OF OUR NUMBERS RIGHT NOW
AND TEXT US ALL OF THE JUICY
DETAILS.
JEREMY: MY NIKE REP IS PATTING
ME ON THE BACK.
WHAT DID YOU WEAR, BLUMMER?
GEOFF: EVERYTHING.
ANYBODY HE WAS GIVING, I WAS
TAKING.
JEREMY: I NEW GUYS THAT WOULD DO
THAT, BLACK EVERYTHING OUT.
A LOT OF GUYS WOULD DO THAT WITH
THE GLOVES.
GEOFF: SO MANY OPTIONS.
JEREMY: THEY WERE BLACK THEM AT
ONCE THEY MADE A CHANGE.
SORRY, ALEX, IF WE ARE GETTING
YOU IN TROUBLE.
WELCOME BACK, NICE PIECE OF
HITTING.
SCOTT: KYLE TUCKER IS BACK, FLEW
OUT TO CENTER FOR HIS FIRST
TRIP.
DUSTY SAID ABOUT BREGMAN, I
DON'T KNOW WHAT HE WILL LOOK
LIKE.
WE HAVE NOT SEEN HIM IN A COUPLE
OF MONTHS.
HE LOOKS PRETTY GOOD, LOOKS LIKE
HE IS BACK.
MINOR IS 2-1.2-2.
GEOFF: IF THE BASEBALL GODS ARE
WATCHING THIS GAME, THERE WILL
BE A GAP RIGHT HERE.
FIRST TO HOME, SEE IF HE CAN
TEST THAT.
IT WAS A BE THE QUESTIONS, CAN
HE SCORE FROM FIRST?
THEN IT WILL BE, HOW DOES HE
FEEL TOMORROW?
JEREMY: ALL GREAT QUESTIONS.
A QUESTION HE'S BEEN ASKING ON
SOCIAL MEDIA, DO YOU LIKE YOUR
SALSA SPICY?
HOT OR MILD?
GEOFF: BRADY BALM SALSA.
GEOFF: HE GOT TOGETHER WITH A
RESTAURANT IN HIS HOMETOWN AND
HE SAID I WANT TO BUT MY LABEL
ON THIS THING.
WHAT KIND OF ADJUSTMENTS CAN WE
MAKE?
I BELIEVE IT IS TEQUILA INFUSED
IF I'M REMEMBERING CORRECTLY.
JEREMY: DON'T ACT LIKE YOU
DIDN'T HOST A PARTY THIS PAST
WEEKEND.
GEOFF: I HAVE ENJOYED BREGY BOMB
SALSA.
SCOTT: HE IS MOVING BACK TO
FIRST.
JEREMY GUTHRIE IS NOT JUST HER
ANALYST TODAY, HE IS ALSO YOUR
MARKETING SPECIALIST.
GEOFF: I KNOW JEREMY HAS BEEN
IMPRESSED WITH WHAT ALEX HAS
DONE ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
JEREMY: I AM HERE BECAUSE JEREMY
AFFELDT CALLED AND SAID I CANNOT
MAKE THE GAME, THERE IS A
YOUTUBE GAME, CAN YOU DO IT?
GEOFF: THERE WAS NO OTHER JEREMY
AVAILABLE?
JEREMY: HE GAVE ME THREE WEEKS
HEADS UP, SO I'VE BEEN REACHING
OUT TO ALL THE COMPANIES SEEING
WHERE I CAN GET A CUT FOR THE
BROADCAST.
IF WE CAN FORCE A FEW MORE IN
HERE, WE WILL BE GOOD.
SCOTT: OFF GOES BREGMAN AND
TUCKER IS DOWN ON STRIKES TO AND
THE FOURTH.
HIGHLIGHTS FOR THE ASTROS THIS
INNING.
BREGMAN WITH THE BASE HIT, HIS
FIRST SINCE JUNE 10.
BEFORE THAT, YORDAN ALVAREZ
GOING DEEP, GIVING HOUSTON A 2-1
EDGE.
♪
>> SHUT YOUR EYES AND BE READY
TO BAIL OUT.
IF THAT CANNOT INTIMIDATE YOU,
NOTHING CAN.
>> I REMEMBER TALKING ABOUT
PLAYERS GETTING JR-ITIS.
>> SOMEBODY WOKE UP WITH A STIFF
NECK.
SOMEBODY ELSE HAD A FEVER OR
COUGH.
THEY DID NOT WANT TO BE OUT
THERE.
>> BIG GUYS, HALL OF FAME GUY
DIDN'T WANT TO PLAY.
THEY TOOK THE DAY OFF WHEN JR
WAS PITCHING.
>> AT 6'8" IN OVER TWO FOR 50
POUNDS, JR WAS AN IMPOSING
PRESENCE ON THE MOUND.
AND THERE WAS SOMETHING ELSE A
BIT SCARY ABOUT J.R. RICHARD.
>> HE IS SO STRONG, HAS THE MOST
ROACHES AND SHAKE THAT I HAVE
EVER ENCOUNTERED.
HE HAS GOT MAMMOTH HANDS.
>> I WAS A PR GUY AT THE TIME,
HAD HIM POSE FOR A PITCHER
HOLDING EIGHT OR NINE BOUGHT --
BALLS IN ONE HAND.
>> NINE BALLS IN ONE HAND.
>> WE TOOK THE PITCHER AND MADE
A POSTER OUT OF IT.
>> ONCE WE SAW IT COME EVERYBODY
TRY TO SEE HOW MANY THEY COULD
HOLD IN THEIR HAND.
MAYBE THREE OR FOUR.
I DON'T THINK I COULD HOLD SEVEN
GOLF BALLS IN MY HAND.
>> I HAD TWO PITCHES, FAST AND
FASTER.
MY BEST, I COULD THROW THROUGH A
CAR WASH AND IT WOULD NEVER GET
WET.
SCOTT: YOU TO WEEK WE ARE GIVING
LOVE TO OUR YOUTUBE CONTENT
CREATORS FEATURED IN OUR LIVE
GAME COMMENTARY SECTION.
TODAY, OUR CREATOR SPOTLIGHT
SHINES ON SPORTS GAMING
UNIVERSE.
SPECIALIZES IN SPORTS VIDEOGAME
SIMULATIONS.
YOU KNOW A GAME IS GOING ON, SHE
WILL TELL YOU HOW IT LOOKS
SIMULATED.
WE SAY HELLO TO HIM.
FIRST SPINACH -- PITCH SWINGING,
MICHAEL A. TAYLOR BOUNCES OUT.
ONE. QUICKLY.
THAT'S GO TO BRETT DOLAN.
BRETT: IT'S BEEN A TOUGH YEAR
FOR ASTROS LEGEND.
MOST RECENTLY BACK ON AUGUST THE
FOURTH, JAMES RODNEY, J.R.
RICHARD, PASSED AWAY.
DUSTY BAKER SAID I DIDN'T HAVE A
LOT OF PITCHERS WHO WERE FRIENDS
BUT JR WAS ONE OF THOSE.
HE ALSO CALLED HIM THE TOUGHEST
GUY HE HAS EVER FACED.
DUSTY HAD ONE HOME RUN AGAINST
THE J.R., BUT BASICALLY ONE OUT
OF EVERY THREE TIMES HE STRUCK
OUT AGAINST HIM.
HE FELT LIKE JR WAS THROWING
FROM 50 FEET WHEN EVERYONE ELSE
WAS THAWING FROM 60.
A QUICK ASIDE, I SAW JR IN APRIL
IN TOWN, WORKING WITH SOME YOUNG
KIDS WHO WERE EXCITED TO BE WITH
HIM.
IT TOOK EVERYTHING I HAD NOT TO
GO UP TO THESE YOUNG MEN AND
SAY, DO YOU REALIZE WHEN HE WAS
AT HIS BEST, THERE WAS NO ONE
BETTER?
AND THERE WERE CERTAINLY NO ONE
MORE INTIMIDATING THAN JR.
GEOFF: ONE OF THE ALL-TIME
GREATS.
HAVING HIM INDUCTED INTO THE
ASTROS HALL OF FAME, GETTING A
CHANCE TO TALK TO HIM,
EVERYTHING THAT BRETT SAID WAS
CORRECT.
LOVED IN THE GAME, LOVED BEING A
HOUSTON ASTRO, BUT THE STORIES
AROUND HIM ARE REALLY
IMPRESSIVE.
THESE OTHER GUYS ACROSS THE
ORGANIZATION COULD TELL GREAT
STORIES ABOUT J.R. RICHARD.
EVERY ONCE IN A WHILE WE SHOW
VIDEO AND WE SHOW GUYS LIKE
REGGIE JACKSON SWING INTO THE
GROUND TRYING TO CONNECT WITH
THE STUFF THAT JR HAD COME IT
WAS REMARKABLE.
SCOTT: ONE OF THE BEST PITCHERS
IN THE 1970'S.
LANCE MCCULLERS JR. PICKS UP
ANOTHER K, HIS FIFTH OF THE DAY.
JEREMY: LANCE HAS PEOPLE
SPENDING IN THE GROUND RIGHT
NOW.
SCOTT: YOU CAN MAKE THE CASE, HE
IS ONE OF THE BEST PITCHERS IN
THE LAST HALF DECADE.
MAYBE DOESN'T GET AS MUCH
ATTENTION BECAUSE OF THE INNINGS
PITCHED, WORKLOAD.
MISSED TIME WITH TOMMY JOHN'S
AFTER 2018, OUT ALL OF 2019, BUT
THE E.R.A. HAS BEEN SOUTH OF 4
AND FIVE OF HIS FIRST SIX
SEASONS IN THE BIGS.
JEREMY: WHAT I REMEMBER IS THAT
GREAT SERIES THE ROYALS PLAYED
AGAINST HOUSTON, ALDS IN 2015.
HE PITCHED GAME FOUR AND PITCHED
MASTERFULLY, TAKING A 7-3 LEAD
INTO THE EIGHTH.
TO DO IT IN THAT MOMENT TRYING
TO ADVANCE TO THE ALCS AS A
ROOKIE, YOU COULD TELL HE HAD
SWAG, CONFIDENCE, AND THE TOOLS
TO BACK IT UP.
SCOTT: FASTBALL IN THERE TO CAM
GALLAGHER AT 95.
I THINK THE LEGENDARY, HAVE TO
SEE YOU TO BELIEVE IT ON YOUTUBE
KIND OF MOMENT, 2017 ALCS, 27
CONSECUTIVE CURVEBALLS TO SEND
THE ASTROS TO THE WORLD SERIES.
THAT IS A ROLLER TO CORREA.
THREE UP, THREE DOWN.
IT IS A NON-PITCH INNING FOR
LANCE MCCULLERS JR. IN THE
FIFTH.
CRUISE CONTROL.
ASTROS UP BY A RUN.
♪
>> ZACK GREINKE ON THE MOUND
TONIGHT.
ROYALS IN CLEVELAND, NICE TO
HAVE YOU WITH US.
RIGHT IN THERE, STRIKE CALLED.
SWING AND A MISS, GOT HIM WITH A
FASTBALL.
THAT IS THREE STRIKEOUTS.
SWING AND A MISS, AND THAT IS
THE INNING.
SWING AND A MISS, HE STRUCK HIM
OUT.
SWING AND MISS BY SHIN-SOO CHOO.
RACK UP ANOTHER STRIKEOUT FOR
GREINKE.
SWING AND PERALTA.
GREINKE WITH 10 STRIKEOUTS IN
THE FIRST FIVE INNINGS.
LISTEN TO THE GROUND.
STRUCK HIM OUT!
A NEW SEASON, 11 STRIKEOUTS.
STRIKE THREE.
THAT IS NUMBER 12.
SWING AND HE GOT HIM.
NOW ZACK IS ONE AWAY FROM TYING
THE ROYALS RECORD.
CALLED STRIKE THREE AND THE
INNING IS OVER!
ZACH AND HIS NAME TO THE ROYALS
RECORD BOOK WITH 15 STRIKEOUTS.
SCOTT: LISTEN TO MLB'S PODCAST
TO HEAR THE LATEST ANALYSIS FROM
INSIDERS ACROSS THE LEAGUE AND
EXCLUSIVE IN-DEPTH INTERVIEWS
WITH BASEBALL'S BIGGEST STARS.
SUBSCRIBE NOW AT [INDISCERNIBLE]
/PODCASTS.
THE MLB BALLPARK AT WILL
COMPLETE YOUR NEXT TRIP TO THE
BALLPARK.
EXCLUSIVE CONTENT AND MUCH MORE.
DOWNLOAD THE BALLPARK APP TODAY.
WE ARE IN HOUSTON, TEXAS THIS
WEEK ON YOUTUBE.
MLB'S YOUTUBE CHANNEL, EASY TO
FIND US, FREE ALL DAY LONG.
ROYALS AND ASTROS, ANYWHERE YOU
ARE WATCHING.
HOUSTON, 2, KANSAS CITY 1.
ALL HOMERS, SOLO SHOTS.
WE BEGIN IN THE FIFTH WITH JAKE
MEYERS.
HERE IS A ROOKIE WHO WAS NOT
HIGHLY TOUTED, 13TH ROUND
SELECTION IN 2017.
THIS YEAR HE WAS NOT A TOP 30
PROSPECT IN THE ORGANIZATION,
ACCORDING TO MLB PIPELINE.
HE SAID I WILL SHOW THEM.
LOOK AT HIM GO SO FAR.
IN HIS FIRST MONTH HE HAS BEEN
GREAT.
JEREMY: SWUNG HIMSELF ONTO THE
ROSTER BY DOING SO WELL IN SUGAR
LAND.
SCOTT: HE PICKS UP A KNOCK.
LEADOFF MAN ABOARD FOR HOUSTON.
IT TOOK WORK, TOO, GEOFF,
LISTENING TO JULIE MORALES ON
THE BROADCAST THE OTHER DAY
SAYING HE WORKED ON STRENGTH,
ADDED 15 POUNDS OF MUSCLE,
TIMING, EXIT VELO, GETTING THE
BALL IN THE AIR MORE BECAUSE HE
IS A GUY WHO KNOWS HOW TO MAKE
CONTACT, AND IT IS ALL COMING
TOGETHER FOR HIM NOW.
GEOFF: TIME HE COULD NOT HAVE
BEEN BETTER.
THE REASON HE IS HERE, HE
BASICALLY FORCED THE TRADE OF
THEIR EVERYDAY CENTER FIELDER IN
MYLES STRAW.
THEY PICKED UP PHILIP MATON AND
PUT HIM IN THE BULLPEN.
WITH CHAS MCCORMICK GOING ON THE
INJURED LIST, ALLOWING THIS
YOUNG GUY TO GO OUT IN CENTER
FIELD AND PROVE HIS WORTH.
HE HAS DONE A VERY GOOD JOB LIKE
YOU ARE STAYING -- SAYING,
PUTTING UP SOME PRETTY GOOD
PRODUCTION NUMBERS.
SCOTT: I LIKE THE SWING, SHORT,
COMPACT.
GEOFF: I AGREE.
NICE AND QUIET, PLENTY OF THUMP
BEHIND IT.
SCOTT: 25 YEARS OLD, HE IS ON
FOR MALDONADO, WHO HOMERED IN
THE THIRD.
FROM OMAHA, NEBRASKA.
THE COLLEGE WORLD SERIES CITY
THERE IS A STRIKE TO MALDONADO.
GEOFF: WHAT IS GREAT ABOUT JAKE
MEYERS GOING TO UNIVERSITY OF
NEBRASKA, JAKE'S FATHER WAS THE
ASSISTANT COACH AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF NEBRASKA WHEN
DEREK ERSTAD WAS A FOOTBALL AND
BASEBALL PLAYER.
EVENTUALLY WHEN JAKE MEYERS WAS
ATTENDING THE UNIVERSITY OF
NEBRASKA, DEREK ERSTAD WAS THE
HEAD COACH OF NEBRASKA.
SOME STRONG TIES BETWEEN THEIR
ERSTAD AND MYERS FAMILY.
JUST SOME HISTORY.
SCOTT: FULL CIRCLE.
GEOFF: IT IS AMAZING.
SCOTT: MALDONADO IN THE AIR, GOT
UNDER THIS ONE.
AND INTEND THE RACING IN --
BENINTENDI RACING TO MAKE THE
CATCH.
LET'S FINISH UP OUR SECOND POLL.
ASTROS FANS SHOWING UP.
>> PULLING OUT TO A BIG LEAGUE
-- LEAD.
SCOTT: WHAT ELSE DO YOU HAVE FOR
US ON JAKE MEYERS, WHO IS ON
FIRST?
BRETT: I HAD A CHANCE TO TALK TO
HIM TODAY.
HE SAID HE WAS THE MOST INTENSE
PERSON HE HAS EVER BEEN AROUND.
JEREMY: THAT IS NOT SHOCK ME ONE
BIT.
I WAS HERE IN HOUSTON WITH HIM.
IT WAS TOWARD THE END OF HIS
CAREER.
HE AND MYSELF AND SOME OTHER
GUYS, WE ARE THE UTILITY GUYS,
THE BENCH GUYS.
HE TORE A SHOELACE TYING HIS
SHOELACES.
HE SNAPS.
I LOOK UP AND ASK IF HE IS OK.
HE SAYS HIS SHOELACE BROKE.
I SAID WHY ARE YOU BREAKING YOUR
SHOELACE?
YOU PROBABLY WILL NOT BE IN THE
GAME.
HE TURNED RED AND WIND AND GOT
ANOTHER PAIR OF SHOELACES.
VEINS WERE POPPING OUT OF HIS
HEAD.
IT WAS UNBELIEVABLE.
HE WAS A GREAT TEAMMATE.
SCOTT: 1-2 TO ALTUVE.
EDDIE HAVE A BAD MEMORY?
MAYBE HIS SHOE FELL OFF?
>> I WAS NOT ABOUT TO PEEL THAT
SCAB OFF.
I LET HIM DEAL WITH THAT
HIMSELF.
>> HE SAID HE DID NOT TALK TO
HIS WIFE FOR THREE DAYS OVER
GIMME PUTTS ON THE GOLF COURSE.
[LAUGHTER]
JEREMY: I HAVE SEEN HIM PUTT.
I CAN SEE WHY HE WANTED THE
GIMME.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: 1-2.
THIS IS MINOR MATCHING UP
AGAINST HOUSTON FOR A SECOND
CONSECUTIVE START.
HE LOST LAST WEEK.
HE WENT 94 PITCHES.
THAT WAS THE ONE LOSS FOR
KANSAS CITY AND THAT FOUR GAME
SET.
THE ASTROS HAVE AT TIMES SUNK
DOWN TO THEIR COMPETITION.
WE HAVE SEEN THAT WHEN FACING
THE AMERICAN LEAGUE CENTRAL THIS
SEASON.
THAT IS A FOUL BALL.
>> IT IS ONE OF THE TOUGH THINGS
TO EXPLAIN.
YOU SEE THINGS UNFOLDING.
THE NUMBERS ARE NOT THAT
DIFFERENT.
THE BULLPEN WAS NOT ABLE TO
SECURE SOME VICTORIES.
THEY HAVE NOT BEEN GOOD AGAINST
THOSE TEAMS.
I READ A STAT THE OTHER DAY
ABOUT THE ROYALS PLAYING 18-15
AGAINST FIRST PLACE TEAMS.
>> ON THE FLIPSIDE OF THAT
EQUATION, THE ROYALS HAVE PLAYED
WELL ALL YEAR LONG.
A LOT OF THAT HAS BEEN AGAINST
THE WHITE SOX.
IT SPEAKS TO THEIR RESILIENCE.
THIS IS A GREAT CLUB WITH GREAT
LEADERSHIP.
THEY UNDERSTAND THE GAME.
SCOTT: GOOD AT-BAT FROM ALTUVE.
KANSAS CITY, 18-14 AGAINST
CURRENT FIRST PLACE BALLCLUBS.
IT STANDS OUT AT THIS POINT.
>> THERE ARE SOME DIFFERENT
DYNAMICS AT PLAY.
SPEED AND AGGRESSIVENESS AND THE
PRESSURE THAT THE ROYALS PUT ON
YOU.
THE ASTROS DO IT A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENTLY.
>> I AM LOVING THIS AT-BAT.
THE ROYALS HAVE TURNED 123
DOUBLE PLAYS.
SCOTT: IN THE AIR.
>> DID YOU WATCH WHIT MERRIFIELD
BY ANY CHANCE?
HE WAS WATCHING ALTUVE.
IF HE IS NOT RUNNING TO FIRST
BASE, I BET HE DROPS IT AND
TRIES TO GO FOR THE DOUBLE PLAY.
SCOTT: GREAT NEWS, HE IS MIKED
UP TODAY.
>> I DID NOT GET THE PLEASURE TO
BE AROUND HIM A LOT.
HE IS FUN TO WATCH.
HE PLAYS THE GAME HARD EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
SOME FUN PLAYERS LIKE THAT.
ONE THING TO DO THE SMART PLAY.
SCOTT: NO RUNS FOR THE ASTROS.
THEY ARE CLINGING TO A ONE RUN
LEAD.
GREAT SEASON SERIES WRAPS UP
BETWEEN THESE TWO TODAY.
>> WE ARE READY FOR BASEBALL.
THE 2015 WORLD SERIES.
>> BACK AT THE WALL, THIS GAME
IS TIED!
THE ROYALS WIN GAME ONE.
HOW ABOUT CUETO?
ROYALS UP 2-0.
>> THE ROYALS HOPE TO GO UP 3-1
OVER THE METS.
>> ANOTHER RUN SCORES.
>> ONE MORE WIN!
>> THE KANSAS CITY ROYALS, A
CHANCE TO CLINCH THEIR FIRST
CHAMPIONSHIP IN 30 YEARS.
>> HOSMER SCORES TO TIE THE
GAME.
>> LINE DRIVE BASE HIT, LEFT
FIELD.
THE ROYALS LEAD 3-2.
STRIKE THREE CALLED!
IT IS OVER.
THEY HAVE DONE IT.
THE ROYALS ARE WORLD SERIES
CHAMPIONS.
>> I REALLY DID NOT GET THE BEST
JUMP.
BUT I HAVE GOTTEN WORST JUMPS.
SCOTT: WORDS FROM WHIT
MERRIFIELD, WHO LEADS OFF THE
SIXTH.
HE LOVES GOING AFTER THIRD BASE.
I ACTUALLY KNOW HIM PRETTY WELL.
HE IS A BASEBALL PLAYER.
HE DOES A LITTLE BIT OF
EVERYTHING.
WE ARE FORTUNATE TO HAVE HIM
MIKED UP.
HE IS 1-2 WITH A DOUBLE.
>> I THINK IT IS GREAT.
BEING ABLE TO DO THESE GAMES AND
EXPAND THE VARIETY AND THE
AUDIENCE.
IT IS SPECIAL.
HE GIVES FANS A LITTLE MORE
INSIGHT INTO WHAT HE WAS
THINKING.
SCOTT: HE HAS PLAYED IN 433
STRAIGHT, BY FAR THE LONGEST
CURRENT STREAK.
>> IT WAS INTERESTING WHAT MIKE
MATHENY SAID BEFORE THE GAME.
HE HAS NEVER ASKED FOR IT.
HE GRINDS.
HE IS WELL CONDITIONED.
SCOTT: DOWN ON STRIKES.
MCCULLERS WITH HIS SIXTH K OF
THE AFTERNOON.
6.5 IS YOUR NUMBER.
I AM ALSO LOOKING AT PITCH COUNT
, 71.
THAT MEANS HE HAS SOME FUEL
LEFT.
>> HE IS HIGHLY EFFICIENT.
HE GOT WHIT MERRIFIELD TO SWING
AND MISS.
HE DOES NOT THINK OUT A LOT.
>> BIG SWEEPING SLIDER.
IT IS HARD.
STILL IN THE UPPER 80'S.
>> WHEN YOU ARE PITCHING, DID
YOU THINK ANGLES?
AS A RIGHT-HANDED HITTER, HOW TO
ATTACK THAT SLIDER?
DO I TRY TO GET OUT IN FRONT OF
IT AND CLIP IT?
IN ORDER TO DO THAT, I HAVE TO
GET SO FAR FRONT OF HOME PLATE
THAT IT PUTS ME IN A TERRIBLE
POSITION.
>> YOU'RE PROBABLY GIVING US TOO
MUCH CREDIT.
WE ARE JUST TRYING TO HIT THE
STRIKE ZONE.
>> I WISH I HAD KNOWN THAT ROLE.
I SWITCH IT.
I DID NOT HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PASTE SOME OF THE SLIDERS.
>> HE IS STARTING IT ON THE --.
CLEARLY THAT HITTERS ARE SEEING
IT.
YOU ARE TRYING TO PUT IT
ANYPLACE THAT LOOKS TEMPTING.
THERE ARE CERTAIN TIMES WHEN YOU
ARE AHEAD IN THE COUNT.
MAYBE YOU ARE BEHIND IN THE
COUNT.
SCOTT: DRIBBLER FELL -- FOUL.
>> HE HAS SO MUCH MOVEMENT.
HE GOT A COUPLE OUTS ON THOSE.
NOT A LOT OF PITCHING COACHES.
WILL WORK WITH YOU ON THAT.
.
SCOTT: ALL SIX STRIKEOUTS TODAY
FROM BREAKING BALLS.
>> WE SAID THAT WOULD BE ONE OF
HIS KEYS.
SCOTT: IT HAS CHANGED HIS
PITCHING PROFILE.
THE SLIDER HAS BEEN THE
DIFFERENCE.
>> THAT WAS FASCINATING WHEN I
SAW THAT IT MAKES SENSE THAT HE
IS TOUGHER ON RIGHTIES NOW.
THAT IS A NICE REPERTOIRE.
TO ATTACK LEFTIES THAT WELL.
SCOTT: A BASE ON BALLS FOR
LOPEZ.
SALVADOR PEREZ IN THE THREE SPOT
.
>> IS WALKS UP HOMERS.
SOME KIND OF SPECIAL.
AT END IT FEELS LIKE.
I IMAGINE THEY ARE PRETTY HEAVY.
SCOTT: I BET YOUR MANAGER CAN
ANSWER THAT QUESTION.
>> HE IS TALKING TO THE PERFECT
GUY.
>> SALVY IS AS ADVERTISED.
REFUSES TO COME OUT.
THAT WAS ONE OF HIS CONCERNS.
HE KNOWS ABOUT GUYS WHO WANT TO
PLAY EVERY DAY.
THAT IS THE OPINION ME OF A
WINNER AND A TEAMMATE.
SCOTT: HE IS A LEADER, A GREAT
AMBASSADOR FOR THE SPORT.
LAYS OFF A TOUGH PITCH.
MIKE MATHENY CANNOT SAY ENOUGH
GOOD THINGS ABOUT HIM.
THEY DO NOT GET THE CREDIT THEY
DESERVE.
>> HE MAY NOT GO OUT AND GET THE
NATIONAL CREDIT THAT HE DESERVES
WHAT HE DOES.
YOU TALK TO GUYS INSIDE THE GAME
OF BASEBALL, HE IS SUCH A GREAT
PLAYER.
>> HE WAS A WORLD SERIES M.V.P.
SCOTT: SALLY TAKES -- SALVY
TAKES THAT ONE.
HOW AWESOME IS HE FOR KANSAS
CITY ON A DAILY BASIS?
BRETT: THEY LOVE HIM.
THE MOST SPECIAL THING TO WATCH
IS THE JOY HE PLAYS WITH.
IT IS A LESSON FOR YOUNG
PLAYERS.
THE GAME IS SUPPOSED TO BE FUN.
SCOTT: THE GUY WHO KEEPS THINGS
LIGHT.
OFTEN IT MIGHT BE YOUR BEST
PLAYER BECAUSE THINGS ARE EASIER
FOR THEM.
>> AND THEY ARE HAVING ANOTHER
GREAT YEAR.
SCOTT: SALVY STRIKES OUT.
SEVEN FOR MCCULLERS.
>> HE KNEW IT.
HE KNEW WHAT WAS COMING.
WAS SO BIG HE HAS NOT BEEN ABLE
TO REACH IT.
IDENTIFIED IT BUT COULD NOT LAY
OFF IT.
>> HE GOT HIS WITH THE HOME RUN.
LANCE GOT HIS WITH THE STRIKEOUT
ON THE SLIDER.
IT MOVES A TON.
IT LOOKS LIKE IT IS JUMPING OUT
OF HIS HAND LIKE A FASTBALL.
SCOTT: WHAT MAKES IT EXTRA
SPECIAL TO ME IS HE CAN MISS
WITH IT.
WE HAVE SEEN QUITE A FEW RIGHT
OVER THE PLATE.
>> SOME OF THE ONES YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT IT ALMOST LOOKS
LIKE HE IS THROWING IT AT THE
RIGHT-HANDED HITTER.
THEY CANNOT PULL THE TRIGGER.
SCOTT: FUN TO WATCH.
>> IT REALLY IS.
WHEN HE GETS IN A RHYTHM WITH
MARTIN MALDONADO BEHIND THE
PLATE, IT IS JUST A MATTER OF
HOW LONG BEFORE HE STRIKES A GUY
OUT.
>> INTERESTING BATTLE RIGHT
HERE.
LOPEZ IS PERFECT ON THE YEAR IN
STOLEN BASES.
SCOTT: POPPER.
CORREA HAS IT.
THAT WILL COMPLETE THE SIXTH.
LANCE MCCULLERS JR. IS STILL ON
A ROLL.
2-1, HOUSTON.
>> GORGEOUS EVENING FOR BASEBALL
HERE AT MINUTE MAID PARK.
THE ASTROS OPENING DAY.
>> THEY HAVE LOST SEVEN IN A
ROW.
>> LOWEST SCORING TEAM IN MAJOR
LEAGUE BASEBALL.
>> THE ASTROS WIN AGAIN.
>> THE ASTROS CLINCH THE
WILD-CARD.
>> BOTTOM OF THE 18TH INNING.
>> IT IS GONE!
>> HOLY TOLEDO! WHAT A WAY TO
FINISH.
>> THIS BALLPARK IS READY TO UP.
>> IN THE AIR DEEP TO LEFT, IT
IS GONE!
THE ASTROS LEAD 4-2.
>> PUJOLS HAS GIVEN ST. LOUIS
THE LEAD.
>> LET'S GET ONTO THE NEXT GAME.
>> FLY BALL INTO RIGHT FIELD.
>> THE HOUSTON ASTROS ARE GOING
TO THE WORLD SERIES FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN FRANCHISE HISTORY!
SCOTT: IT IS ALL ABOUT YOU.
WE GIVE YOU THE POWER TO VOTE
FOR A STANDOUT PERFORMER.
WE WILL HAVE POLLING OPTIONS
LATER.
AND OUT SOME HARDWARE IN THE
POSTGAME SHOW.
YOUR NAME GOES ON A DIGITAL
CLOCK.
BUT ACTUALLY THE TROPHY ITSELF.
PLAYERS LOVE IT.
IT IS REAL.
HE COMES IN THE MAIL.
IT IS COMING UP LATER.
I WOULD SAY LANCE MCCULLERS JR.
IS AN EARLY CANDIDATE.
MALDONADO ALSO WITH A LONG BALL.
HERE IS YULI GURRIEL.
I HAVE BEEN DYING TO ASK YOU
ABOUT THE TRANSFORMATION OF HIS
HITTING PROFILE.
HE IS ALWAYS A GUY WHO KNOWS HOW
TO MAKE CONTACT.
THAT ONE WILL DROP FAIR AND INTO
THE SEATS FOR A GROUND RULE
DOUBLE.
PERFECTLY PLACED.
>> I AM NOT SURE YOU COULD THROW
IT OUT THERE MUCH BETTER.
HE APPRECIATES IT JUMPING INTO
THE STANDS.
DOES NOT HAVE TO USE THOSE OLD
MAN WHEELS.
THIS IS A LITTLE EXTREME.
SNEAKING INSIDE.
SCOTT: RUNNER IN SCORING
POSITION FOR ALVAREZ.
THIS IS THE FIRST RUNNER IN
SCORING POSITION FOR HOUSTON
TODAY.
>> THIS WAS ONE OF THE KEYS AT
THE BEGINNING.
MINOR HAS REALLY BEEN CHALLENGED
THIS YEAR WITH RUNNERS IN
SCORING POSITION.
THE HOME RUNS HAVE BEEN THE ONLY
THINGS THAT HAVE HURT HIM.
LET'S SEE IF HE CAN KEEP MAKING
PITCHES.
DO SOMETHING TO GET OUT OF THIS
INNING.
SCOTT: WHAT IS THE DIFFERENCE
WITH YULI?
HOW IS HE SUDDENLY TAKING
PITCHES DEEP INTO HIS CAREER?
>> HE HAS GONE TO SCHOOL ON THE
PROGRAM.
COMING FROM CUBA, HE WAS PAID TO
BE A HITTER.
THE REASON HE WAS WITH THE
ASTROS WAS BECAUSE HE WAS SUCH A
GOOD HITTER.
HE HAD A LITTLE TOO AGGRESSIVE
WITH THE SWING.
HE WOULD CHASE OUT OF THE ZONE.
HE IS SEEING THE BALL BETTER.
PITCHERS HAD TO GET BACK IN THE
ZONE.
HE HAD TO BE A LITTLE BIT MORE
SELECTIVE.
HE HAS HAD SUCCESS EARLY ON.
SCOTT: YOU WILL PRODUCE MORE
WALKS WHEN YOU TAKE THOSE
PITCHES OUTSIDE OF THE ZONE.
YOU CAN DO DAMAGE WITH THOSE.
>> EVERY TIME HE WALKS, HE IS
SETTING A NEW PERSONAL RECORD.
SCOTT: I HEARD HE HAD SOME
HELPERS LIKE CARLOS CORREA.
TOLD HIM TO TAKE A PITCH HERE
AND THERE.
WE KNOW YOU CAN MAKE CONTACT
WITH ANYTHING.
>> THAT WAS ONLY THE SECOND HOME
RUN ALLOWED TO A LEFTY BY MINOR
ALL SEASON LONG.
HE HAS GIVEN UP 23 TWO
RIGHT-HANDERS.
ALVAREZ IS A TOUGH HITTER.
THEY WANT TO MAKE SURE THEY ARE
ON THE SAME PAGE.
SCOTT: BACK TO MINOR.
>> THAT IS A NICE RESULT RIGHT
THERE.
>> DOES NOT MOVE THE RUNNER.
>> GALLAGHER MUST BE PLEASED.
>>.
.
YOU GIVE CREDIT TO THOSE
CATCHERS THEY DO.
SEE SO MUCH I ALWAYS RESPECT THE
VETERAN PITCHERS WHO HAVE BEEN
AROUND SO MUCH.
>> BEING ABLE.
.
TO TRUST THEM KEEP THAT IN A
POSITION WHERE THAT IN A
POSITION WHERE THE HITTER WILL
GET TIED UP.
>> ONE GONE FOR CORREA.
TAYLOR WILL GLIDE OVER AND MAKE
THE CATCH.
TAGGING UP IS GURRIEL AND HE IS
IN THERE.
>> TAYLOR IS NOT AN EASY GUY TO
RUN ON.
THAT WAS A GUTSY PLAY.
>> HE HAD A COUPLE OF BIG THROWS
TO HOME PLATE IN THE SERIES BACK
IN KANSAS CITY.
SCOTT: HE HAD ONE IN THIS
SERIES.
I BELIEVE IT WAS MONDAY.
>> YOU TALK ABOUT VELOCITY.
MICHAEL A. TAYLOR CAN GET IN THE
LOW 90'S EVERY ONCE IN A WHILE.
SCOTT: THIRD AT-BAT WERE
BREGMAN.
>> A LOT OF ROYALS FANS WILL
REMEMBER LORENZO CAIN AND THE
KINDS OF PLAYS HE USED TO MAKE.
MIGHT NOT BE AS FLASHY.
>> THAT IS A HUGE COMPLIMENT.
SCOTT: NINE OUTFIELD ASSISTS.
THE MOST MONTH CENTER FIELDERS.
YOU TALK TO HIM IN PERSON, HE IS
QUIET.
A MAN OF FEW WORDS, BUT HE IS
TALENTED.
IT'S THE KANSAS CITY STYLE.
>> HE HAS BEEN WORKING TO FIND
HIS SWING.
SCOTT: I CAN ONLY IMAGINE WHAT
THE COMMUNICATION HAS BEEN LIKE
OVER THE LAST COUPLE MONTHS
BETWEEN ALEX BREGMAN AND THE
ASTROS FRONT OFFICE AND COACHING
STAFF.
HIS ANXIOUSNESS TO RETURN TO THE
LINEUP.
DOES HE LIKE BASEBALL?
GEOFF: HE ABSOLUTELY LOVES
BASEBALL.
HE IS A GUY THAT IF THERE IS
OPTIONAL BATTING PRACTICE, HE IS
TAKING IT.
DUSTY BAKER SAID THIS GUY'S ME
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
KIND OF SURPRISED ME A LITTLE
BIT.
SCOTT: TODAY IS THE DAY.
LAYS OFF, IT IS A STRIKE.
>> THERE HAVE NOT BEEN TO MANY
PITCHES UP IN THE ZONE CALLED.
>> MINOR CONTINUES TO TRY TO GO
INSIDE.
HE HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL WITH
THAT.
SCOTT: HE HAS SHOWN ALL OF HIS
PITCHES.
>> GOOD LIFE ON THE FASTBALL.
>> THAT MYSTERY ZONE.
YOU HAVE TO FIGHT THAT PITCH
OFF.
YOU ARE HOPING TO VALID OFF --
FOUL IT OFF.
.
>> WE HAVE SEEN TRY THAT A
COUPLE OF TIMES.
>> HE HAS THE BASE OPEN WITH A
LEFT-HANDED HITTER ON DECK.
I THINK HE IS PRETTY CONFIDENT
WITH HIS STUFF.
>> IN ON THE HANDS AND BEHIND
THE NETTING.
WE WILL DO IT AGAIN.
>> HAVE YOU TALKED TO BREGMAN AT
ALL ABOUT THE WAY HE CHOKES OUT?
-- UP?
>> HE ENJOYS BAT CONTROL.
HE IS ALSO A GUY WHO COMMANDS
THE ZONE.
ONE OF THE ADJUSTMENTS HE HAS
MADE IS GETTING ON THE PLANE AND
THINKING ABOUT ELEVATING TO THE
PULL SIDE.
ALLOWS HIM TO USE THE BARREL
MORE EFFECTIVELY.
SCOTT: SMACKED TO LEFT FIELD AND
IT IS OFF THE TOP OF THE WALL.
ALEX BREGMAN IS BACK IN A BIG
WAY WITH AN R.B.I. DOUBLE TO
EXTEND THE ADVANTAGE.
IT IS 3-1.
>> MIKE MINOR KNOWS ABOUT THAT
BARREL.
HE WAS TRYING TO STAY OFF OF IT.
THAT ONE JUST DIDN'T GET TO
WHERE HE WAS HOPING.
CREDIT TO BREGMAN FOR MAKING THE
ADJUSTMENT IN THE AT-BAT.
>> HE TOOK ADVANTAGE THAT PITCH
THAT, A LOT MORE OF THE PLATE
THEN HE WANTED TO.
HE FIGURED OUT THE ADJUSTMENT HE
NEEDED TO MAKE ON THAT SWING.
>> I LIKE YOUR POINT.
HE SAW IT ENOUGH TIMES THAT HE
HAD A BETTER CHANCE TO CATCH UP
TO THE LAST ONE.
A BIG RUN FOR THE ASTROS.
SCOTT: FIRST R.B.I. SINCE JUNE
13.
SCORES GURRIEL.
FIRST PITCH SWINGING, KYLE
TUCKER GOING FOR CENTER FIELD,
TAYLOR BACK AT THE WARNING TRACK
TO HAUL IT IN.
SOME LOUD CONTACT FROM THE
ASTROS IN THE LAST OF THE SIXTH.
ONE RUN TO SHOW FOR IT.
3-1, HOUSTON.
>> HANG ONTO THE ROOF.
>> THIS ONE IS OUT OF HERE!
>> THERE WE GO.
DEEP LEFT CENTER FIELD.
SPLASH!
IT IS OVER.
>> RIGHT OVER THE MIDDLE.
HE KNEW IT WAY BEFORE ANYONE
ELSE DID.
IT ENDED UP GETTING WET.
>> THERE GOES WIT.
SWUNG ON AND BELTED, DEEP CENTER
FIELD, GONE.
10 YEARS TO THE DAY THAT HE MADE
HIS BIG-LEAGUE DEBUT.
>> THERE YOU GO.
ENJOY.
SALVY HAS TWO HOME RUNS
TONIGHT.
HE ADDS TO HIS CAREER-HIGH.
THE ROYALS HAVE TIED THE GAME,
4-4.
SCOTT: SEVENTH INNING ACTION ON
YOUTUBE IN HOUSTON.
OUR THIRD POLL QUESTION OF THE
DAY, EASY TO PARTICIPATE ON YOUR
MOBILE DEVICE OR COMPUTER.
WHICH ROYALS PROSPECT WITH YOU
MOST LIKE TO SEE GET THE CALL
THIS YEAR?
SOME OF THE TOP PROSPECTS IN
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL.
KANSAS CITY HAS SOMETHING
SPECIAL BREWING IN THE MINOR
LEAGUES.
HUNTER DOZIER TO CARLOS CORREA,
THERE IS YOUR FIRST OUT IN THE
SEVENTH.
KANSAS CITY DOES NOT HAVE THE
RECORD TO SHOW FOR WHAT THEY
HAVE DONE THIS YEAR.
THEY MADE SOME REALLY TOUGH
GAMES.
BRETT: BASEBALL AMERICA HAS MIKE
MATHENY'S SYSTEM AS NUMBER
THREE.
IN ARKANSAS, I SAW THEM PLAY
ABOUT 20 TIMES.
EVERYBODY KNOWS ABOUT BOBBY WITT
JR..
MELENDEZ'S FATHER COACHES.
THEIR SONS ARE COMPETING FOR THE
MINOR LEAGUE HOME RUN CROWN.
SCOTT: RYAN O'HEARN ROLLS OVER
ONE.
>> DON'T ASK THE ROYALS FRONT
OFFICE ABOUT WHO IS COMING UP
NEXT.
I KNOW THE FANS ARE SCREAMING
FOR BOBBY WITT JR. TO COME UP.
A VERY MATURE HITTER WHO HITS
FOR POWER.
YOU SEE THE INFIELD.
IT IS A GOOD PROBLEM TO HAVE.
THEY HAVE SOME GUYS PITCHING A
LOT OF INNINGS FOR THEM RIGHT
NOW.
THE FUTURE IS VERY EXCITING IF
YOU ARE A ROYALS FAN.
WHAT IS COMING UP FOR THEM TO
BUILD ON TOP OF WHAT IS ON THE
BASEBALL FIELD RIGHT NOW.
EVERYONE IS EXCITED.
SCOTT: A SINGLE FOR MICHAEL A.
TAYLOR.
>> I AM FINE IF THEY HANG OUT
FOR A LITTLE BIT.
>> YOU THINK ABOUT THE
PROJECTIONS FOR THE ASTROS.
THE ROYALS CAME THROUGH.
>> A LOT OF THESE GUYS BEING
DRAFTED WITHIN THE ORGANIZATION,
ONE THING THAT HAS STEPPED UP IN
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS IS
GOING OUT AND DRAFTING WELL.
THE ASTROS DID SUCH A GOOD JOB
OF DRAFTING.
THOSE GUYS YOU HAVE NURTURED
ALTOGETHER.
YOU HAVE A CONTENDING TEAM.
>> IT IS SO EASY TO DRAFT AFTER
THE FACT.
WHY DIDN'T WE TAKE THIS GUY OR
THAT GUY?
THE AMOUNT OF PRESSURE ON THESE
ORGANIZATIONS.
HERE IS AN EXAMPLE.
THEY ARE CONTRIBUTING.
WE ARE STARTING TO SEE THEM TURN
THE CORNER.
THEY HAVE PITCHED PHENOMENALLY.
>> I HAVE A CHANCE TO WATCH SOME
OF THEM.
I WAS SOLD.
>> NOT A BAD SITUATION.
MANY CALL IT A LOST SEASON.
BUT THEY ARE GAINING THE
EXPERIENCE.
SCOTT: THEY HAD THE LEAGUE
LOOKING OUT FOR THEM.
BUT THEN THEY DROPPED 11 IN A
ROW.
THEY HAVE BOUNCED UP AND DOWN
THIS YEAR.
>> YOU CAN GO AHEAD AND LET THE
WHITE SOX RUN WITH IT FOR A
SEASON.
THEN YOU START MAKING
ADJUSTMENTS.
SOME EXPERIENCE TO MOVE ON AND
BUILD ON GOING FORWARD.
SCOTT: MCCULLERS AT 97 PITCHES.
HERE IS THE A.L. CENTRAL.
THE WHITE SOX HAVE THE COMFY IS
LEAD AMONG FIRST-PLACE
BALLCLUBS.
THIS COULD BE THE LAST PITCH
FROM THE ASTROS STARTER.
CRISTIAN JAVIER IS GETTING WARM.
PAYOFF.
WE WILL DO IT AGAIN.
>> RIVERA IS GOING TO MAKE THEM
WORK FOR IT.
>> A COUPLE OF SLIDERS BACK TO
BACK.
HE HAS HIM IN SWING MOVING HERE.
SCOTT: ALMOST EXCLUSIVELY SINKER
AND SLIDER.
THAT IS NOT MAKE IT EASY.
>> DUSTY PROBABLY DOES NOT WANT
TO GO OUT TO THE MOUND.
LANCE MCCULLERS IS ACCUSTOMED TO
THROWING MORE THAN 100 PITCHES.
HE WANTS TO FINISH THIS INNING.
>> MINDS ME OF MIKE MUSSINA.
HE APOLOGIZED.
>> CLEARLY THE ARM GETS A LITTLE
BIT TIRED.
SCOTT: MCCULLERS IS AT 100
PITCHES.
THE SEASON HIGH FOR HIM IS 111.
>> THAT IS A GOOD SLIDER.
IT IS HARD BECAUSE HIS SINKER
SINKS SO MUCH.
SCOTT: WE THINK THE SAME.
>> HOW DOES HE LOOK UP THERE?
>> GOT ONE RIGHT THERE.
>> YOU NEED THOSE SOMETIMES.
SCOTT: GALLAGHER TAKES ANOTHER
PITCH.
.
>> HE EXECUTED.
SCOTT: HE HAS USED ALL OF HIS
PITCHES AGAINST RIGHT-HANDERS.
GALLAGHER LOST ONE FOUL.
WHAT IS THE OPTION?
DO YOU GO BACK TO THE CLASSIC
SLIDER?
>> THIS IS A BIG PITCH.
2-2 COUNT.
>> HE HAS NOT BEEN HEARD ON THE
FASTBALL.
THE SLIDERS HAVE NOT BEEN SHARP.
'S FASTBALL STILL HAS GREAT LIFE
AND GREAT LOCATION.
WHICH ONE DO YOU WANT TO GIVE
THE GUY OUT ON?
>> GALLAGHER STAYS ALIVE.
>> I REMEMBER CERTAIN AT-BATS.
I DO NOT WANT TO GO BACK TO THE
DUGOUT HAVING THROWN A PITCH
THAT I WAS NOT SO SOLD ON AND
MADE A MISTAKE.
>> YOU WANT TO GET BEAT BY YOUR
BEST.
>> HE HAS TO THROW SLIDERS UNTIL
THIS AT-BAT IS OVER.
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE, HE CAN
CHOOSE EITHER ONE.
>> DID NOT GET THE CHASE ON THAT
ONE.
SCOTT: DID YOU SEE MALDONADO?
HE WENT RIGHT BACK TO THE NEXT
PITCH.
WILL DO ANOTHER.
>> HE IS GETTING THE HEATER AND
THE SLIDER.
>> THAT WAS A REALLY GOOD PITCH.
>> A GREAT PIECE OF FIGHTING BY
GALLAGHER.
HE WILL NEED TO GET SOMETHING UP
IN THE ZONE HE CAN DRIVE.
SHOCKED THE WORLD WITH A
CHANGEUP HERE.
SCOTT: HERE WE GO.
BALL FOUR.
HE YANKED ONE.
THAT LOADS UP THE BAGS.
THAT WILL DO IT.
>> MIND TAKING HIS CHANCES
AGAINST SOMEONE ELSE.
SCOTT: HE WILL FACE A NEW
PITCHER.
MCCULLERS LEAVES WITH THE BAGS
FULL OF ROYALS.
>> I REMEMBER THE NINTH INNING,
SOMEBODY SAID WHOEVER CATCHES
THE LAST FALL, SOMEONE PAYS HIM
$25.
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS $100.
[LAUGHTER]
>> IT IS WILSON.
ONE OUT TO GO.
>> EVERYONE ASKS ME, WHAT DID HE
SAY TO YOU?
HE SAID, WHEN YOU GET THIS GUY
OUT, I WANT TO BE THE FIRST GUY
TO GRAB YOU.
>> VAN SLYKE HITS IT AND IT IS
COMING TO ME.
IS THIS REALLY HAPPENING?
>> I WAS READY TO JUMP IN HIS
ARMS RIGHT THEN.
HE SAID IT HAD NOT COME DOWN
YET.
>> A LOT OF PRESSURE CATCHING
THAT LAST OUT.
>> THE KANSAS CITY ROYALS ARE
THE 1985 WORLD CHAMPIONS.
SCOTT: GOOGLE CLOUD IS HELPING
TO POWER STATCAST.
REVEALING NEW INSIGHTS, TAKING
YOU DEEPER INTO THE GAME THAN
EVER BEFORE.
GOOGLE CLOUD IS THE OFFICIAL
CLOUD TECHNOLOGY OF MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL.
THE PRESSURE IS ON FOR CRISTIAN
JAVIER.
REPLACING LANCE MCCULLERS JR.,
WHO HELD KANSAS CITY TO ONLY ONE
RUN, BUT DO NOT CLOSE THE BOOK
YET.
HE IS RESPONSIBLE FOR ALL THREE
BASE RUNNERS.
YOU ARE OUT THERE WATCHING AND
SAYING, PLEASE, GIVE THEM THE
GOOD STUFF.
JEREMY: I KNOW BOTH ENDS OF IT.
GIVE ME ANYTHING.
I WANT TO THE FIRST GUY TO SWING
AT THE FIRST PITCH.
IT WAS USUALLY AN OUT.
JAVIER STARTED THE YEAR AS A
STARTER.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY RUNNERS HE
HAS INHERITED THROUGHOUT THE
SEASON.
I CAN'T IMAGINE THIS IS THE MOST
FAMILIAR SPOT FOR HIM TO JUMP
INTO.
GEOFF: THIS IS A UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY.
SCOTT: WHIT MERRIFIELD GOES
AFTER THE FIRST PITCH, IT IS
HEADED TOWARD THE WALL AND THE
OFFER BOXES, FORGET ABOUT IT!
FIRST PITCH GRAND SLAM.
THE ROYALS JUMP IN FRONT, 5-3.
>> HE GUESSED RIGHT.
JEREMY: IF I AM THE PITCHER, I
DON'T WANT HIM TO SWING AT THE
FIRST PITCH ANYMORE.
WHAT A GUTSY SWING.
BECAUSE BACK TO THE PREVIOUS
AT-BATS.
THOSE GUYS WORKING IN.
AGAINST A TOUGH SLIDER.
GEOFF: THAT IS A TYPICAL ASTRO
INNING.
THEY PUT RUNNERS ON AND CREATE
TRAFFIC AND WE STRESS FOR THE
PITCHER.
THAT WAS A GREAT AT-BAT FOR WHIT
MERRIFIELD.
HE DOES NOT HAVE A HIGH STRIKE
PERCENTAGE.
HE GUESSED FASTBALL OVER THE
PLATE AND HE GOT IT.
THE BIGGEST THING IS DO NOT MISS
IT.
JEREMY: HE TURNED ON IT.
ANOTHER GUY WHO CHOKES UP.
GENERATES A LOT OF POWER.
SCOTT: HOME RUN NUMBER NINE ON
THE SEASON.
WOW, WHAT A SHOT.
GEOFF: I THINK THE ASTROS MIGHT
BE CALLING TO GET A POLICE
ESCORT TO MAKE SURE THEY GET OUT
OF HERE AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
SCOTT: THEY HAVE ALREADY WON THE
SEASON SERIES.
THIS IS THE LAST MATCHUP OF THE
SEASON BETWEEN THESE TEAMS.
TAKE A DEEP BREATH.
YOU ARE RIGHT.
COLD-BLOODED.
THAT IS HOW THEY HAVE BEEN
AGAINST HOUSTON.
DUSTY SAID THEY DO NOT FEEL LIKE
THE SOFTER PART OF THE SCHEDULE.
[LAUGHTER]
STRIKE THREE ON LOPEZ.
HE SHOULD BE PUMPED FOR HIS
TEAMMATE, WHIT MERRIFIELD, WITH
THE BASES LOADED.
TAKES ADVANTAGE.
FIRST PITCH FROM CRISTIAN JAVIER
TO THE CRAWFORD BOXES.
THE ROYALS SNATCH THE LEAD.
>> HANG ON TO THE ROOF.
>> THIS ONE IS OUT OF HERE!
>> MIDDLE OF THE INFIELD IS
BACK, HOPING TO TURN A DOUBLE
PLAY.
ALTUVE DRIVES ONE DEEP TO LEFT
FIELD.
THAT IS GONE.
JOSE ALTUVE!
>> ARE YOU SERIOUS?
>> A WALKOFF GRAND SLAM FOR JOSE
ALTUVE.
DRIVES ONE DEEP TO LEFT FIELD.
YOU HAVE TO BE KIDDING ME!
SIX RUN BOTTOM HALF OF THE
NINTH.
ALTUVE HAS DONE IT AGAIN.
FOR THE SECOND TIME THIS YEAR
AGAINST CHAD GREEN.
MAYBE THE MOST IMPROBABLE
COMEBACK IN THE MAJOR LEAGUES
THIS YEAR.
>> UNBELIEVABLE.
SCOTT: MLB ORIGINALS SEASON TWO
IS LIVE ON YOUTUBE WITH NEW
EPISODES EVERY WEEK.
LEARN MORE ABOUT THE GAME YOU
LOVE.
COMPETE FOR CASH EVERY GAME WITH
QUICK PICK.
MAKE SEVEN PREGAME PICKS AND
COMPETE TO WIN.
THE PENDULUM HAS SWUNG.
TWO OUTS,  BASES LOADED,KC WITH
AN EXCELLENT SEQUENCE.
WILL TAKE OVER FOR MIKE
MINOR.
HE KEPT HIS TEAM IN THE GAME.
JEREMY: HE GOT HURT ON A COUPLE
OF LONG BALLS.
THE HITTING PICKED HIM UP.
WHIT'S FIRST HOME RUN IN 47
GAMES.
SCOTT: WELCOME BACK TO THE GUN
SHOW.
GEOFF: THE ASTROS GAVE UP THE
HOME RUN TO LOPEZ TO BREAK A
LONG HOMERLESS STRAIGHT.
NOW WHIT MERRIFIELD IS ON THAT
LIST.
SCOTT: THAT WAS THE FIRST OF THE
SEASON FOR LOPEZ LAST WEEK ON
THURSDAY.
THAT IS NOT PART OF HIS GAME.
2-0 FROM TAPIA.
THIS MAN CAN BRING THE HEAT.
AVERAGES FAST FOR OUR ON THE
FOUR-SEAMER.
THAT IS WELL DONE.
LET'S TAKE YOU BACK, AUGUST 19,
DO YOU REMEMBER THIS?
GEOFF: IT WAS A BREAKING BALL.
HE TOOK IT AND LAUNCHED IT.
THAT WAS PRETTY IMPRESSIVE.
AT KAUFFMAN STADIUM.
MAYBE AT SOME OF THESE SHORT
PORCHES IN RIGHT FIELD.
BUT HE GOT BIG AND A BIG
BALLPARK.
SCOTT: IT IS ACTUALLY WHAT THREW
OFF HIS GAME.
MIKE MATHENY HAS TALKED ABOUT
THIS.
THE COMEBACK DIFFERENT FROM
LOPEZ AFTER A VERY DOWN 2020 AND
SOME STRUGGLES IN 2019.
HE WAS LOOKING AT LAUNCH ANGLE
AND VELOCITY IN ALL OF THAT.
HE SAID THAT IS NOT YOUR GAME.
YOU CAN BE A CLASSIC THROWBACK
PLAYER.
IT IS A BREATH OF FRESH AIR IN
OUR GAME.
HE DOES PUT THE BASEBALL ON THE
GROUND A LOT.
SAC BUNTS, STOLEN BASES, ELITE
DEFENSE.
LET'S SEE IF THAT IS PLAYABLE
FOR GALLAGHER.
SIXTH ROW.
GEOFF: I HAD NOT SEEN LOPEZ PLAY
BEFORE LAST WEEK.
I HAVE BEEN IMPRESSED.
WHAT I HAVE HEARD FROM GUYS IN
THE CLUBHOUSE.
HE WORKS HARD.
A REAL LIKABLE YOUNG PLAYER.
HE KNOWS HOW TO HANDLE HIMSELF
IN THE CLUBHOUSE.
SCOTT: THIS IS THE TIME TO BRING
UP THAT HE HAS BEEN ALL OVER THE
PLACE.
A WELL-TRAVELED INDIVIDUAL TO
US.
GEOFF: ONE OF THE FEW STOPS
ALONG MANY.
JEREMY: THAT WAS MY DREAM WAS TO
GO TO AFRICA.
WE SPENT THREE YEARS HERE IN
HOUSTON WORKING AS MISSIONARIES
FOR MY CHURCH.
I DID NOT LEAVE HOUSTON AT ALL
FOR THREE YEARS.
I SAID WE ARE GOING TO AFRICA
AND WE ARE TAKING THE KIDS.
WE WENT TO KENYA FOR EIGHT DAYS.
I FOUND A NEW FAVORITE ANIMAL,
THE WARTHOG.
GEOFF: SOUNDS NASTY.
JEREMY: IT IS AMAZING.
YOU LEARN SO MUCH ABOUT THEM.
WHO KNEW THAT PUUMBA MEANS
STUPID IN SWAHILI?
GEOFF: THAT MEANS A LOT.
YOU HAVE BEEN CALLING ME THAT.
[LAUGHTER]
JEREMY: IF YOU SAW THE BODIES ON
THEN, THESE CHISELED LEGS, BUT
QUICK.
GEOFF: WHAT TODAY HOT -- DO THEY
HUNT?
JEREMY: LEFTOVERS.
SCOTT: I DO THAT AS WELL.
I DON'T WASTE A MORSEL.
MALDONADO LIFTS ONE TO DEEP
LEFT, DOES IT HAVE ENOUGH?
IT DOES NOT.
BENINTENDI MAKES THE CATCH.
A LONG FLY BALL OUT, THE FIRST
TIER IN THE SEVENTH -- HERE N
THE SEVENTH.
GEOFF: HE GOT A LITTLE BIT ALL.
-- OFF.
LOOKED LIKE A OFF-SPEED PITCH.
ALMOST LAUNCHED IT TO THE RIGHT
SPOT.
TRYING TO CREEP INTO THE
CRAWFORD BOXES.
SCOTT: HE TOOK THE FOUL BALL OFF
HIS ARM IN THE LAST HALF INNING.
A TRUE CATCHER.
HOMER NUMBER 10 BACK ANOTHER
DAY.
TOP OF THE LINEUP CARD FOR DUSTY
BAKER, ALTUVE FOLLOWED BY DIAZ.
JOSE IS 0-3.
JEREMY: TAPIA HAS BEEN ONE OF
THEIR MORE RELIABLE RELIEVERS
THIS YEAR.
I WATCHED HIM PITCH TO THE OTHER
NIGHT.
BOWLING BALLS, HEAVY WITH
MOVEMENT.
ONE OF THOSE THINGS THAT
DESTROYS YOUR BAT.
THAT FASTBALL WAS HEAVY AND
HARD.
GEOFF: THAT IS WHY IT'S
INTERESTING FOR ME TO SEE HIS
STRIKEOUT NUMBER.
STILL A GUY TRYING TO FIGURE IT
OUT.
WITH THAT HIGH VELOCITY, TOUGH
TO COMPETE WITH THAT.
JEREMY: HE WILL FIGURE IT OUT.
WHEN HE DOES, MAYBE WORK HIMSELF
TOWARDS THE BACK.
GEOFF: YOU ARE RIGHT.
SCOTT: 97.
GEOFF: JUST DOESN'T LOOK LIKE
FUN.
JEREMY: NO, HEAVY RUN.
WHEN IT IS DOWN, IT SINKS A BU
NCH.
HE HAS BEEN GREAT FOR THEM.
PITCHING THE SEVENTH INNING OF A
TWO RU GAME, SOMEONE THAT MIKE
TRUSTS VERY MUCH.
SCOTT: HE REACHES FOR ONE RIGHT
SIDE.
MERRIFIELD GETS THE OUT AT
FIRST.
TWO GONE IN THE SEVENTH.
POLL QUESTION ON THE ROYALS
PROSPECTS.
POLL ANSWER, OBVIOUS, BOBBY WITT
JR. IS WHO EVERYONE WANTS TO SEE
IN SEPTEMBER.
TOP THREE PROSPECT ACCORDING TO
MLB PIPELINE.
HE PASSES THE EYE TEST TOO.
I HAVE SEEN HIM IN PERSON A
COUPLE TIMES.
HE IS SPECIAL.
EVERYONE GETS EXPOSED AT SOME
POINT IN THE BIG LEAGUES, BUT SO
FAR IN THE MINOR LEAGUES HE
LOOKS LIKE THE IDEAL SHORTSTOP.
JEREMY: GOOD DRAFTING BY THE
ROYALS.
IT WILL START TO PAY DIVIDENDS,
AS IS ALREADY IS WITH THE EVER
THEY GIVE ON THEIR SCOUTING.
REMINDS ME A BIT OF MATT WIETERS
IN TERMS OF THE EXCITEMENT.
WHEN HE CAME UP, THEY ANNOUNCED
HIM A WEEK IN ADVANCE SO THAT
PEOPLE CAN BUY TICKETS.
THERE WERE TWO DEBUTS FROM A
COUPLE OF ARE STARTING PITCHERS
THE WEEK BETWEEN THE
ANNOUNCEMENT AND HIS DEBUT.
THEY WERE JUST AFTERTHOUGHTS.
YOUNG STARTERS MADE STARTS AND
IT WAS ALL ABOUT MATT.
I THINK THEY MIGHT HAVE DONE A
BOBBLEHEAD HIS FIRST DAY.
[LAUGHTER]
GEOFF: DANG.
SCOTT: THAT IS A LOT OF
PRESSURE.
THAT WILL FALL AND SCORE A RUN
FOR HOUSTON.
HERE COMES MYERS.
HE'S IN ON THE R.B.I. KNOCK FOR
LEAD MISS DIAZ TO MAKE IT 5-4.
GEOFF: YOU CAN NEVER
UNDERESTIMATE THE VALUE OF A GUY
LIKE A LEAD MISS DIAZ -- ALEDMYS
DIAZ.
DIAZ DID A GOOD JOB OF FIGHTING
THAT OFF.
JEREMY: A LOT OF THE PITCHES WE
HAVE SEEN THIS INNING HAVE BEEN
LEFT ON THE INNER THIRD.
MAYBE THAT IS ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT RIGHT NOW A CHALLENGE FOR
HIM IS GETTING IT TO THE GLOVE
SIDE.
YOU THROW ENOUGH PITCHES INSIDE,
THAT WILL GET TO IT EVENTUALLY.
HE HIT IT HARD ENOUGH.
SCOTT: HE ACTUALLY PLAYED FOR
THE CARDINALS, CAME UP WITH ST.
LOUIS.
HE WAS MANAGED BY MIKE MATHENY.
HE KNOWS WHAT HE CAN DO.
DIAZ RIDING A SIX GAME
HITTING STREAK.
PROBABLY WILL SEE HIS PLAYING
TIME DECREASE AS BRIGHTMAN IS
BACK, BUT HE'S PLAYING WITH FULL
OF CONFIDENCE.
GEOFF: THEY LIKE THE IDEA OF
GETTING GUYS DAYS OFF.
WITH ALEX BREGMAN BACK, IT GIVES
AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO USE A GUY
LIKE ALEDMYS DIAZ TO GIVE CARLOS
CORREA A GUY OFF, GIVE JOSE
ALTUVE AND YULI GURRIEL A DAY
OFF.
JEREMY: THAT IS A NICE LUXURY TO
HAVE.
GEOFF: CLEARLY.
JEREMY: HAVE A GUY BATTING OVER
.300, YOU CAN MOVE HIM AROUND.
GOOD PLACE TO BE.
ARM SIDE.
IF HE CAN GET IT DOWN, HE HAS A
CHANCE TO GET THE LAST OUT.
HE HAS TO BE MORE PATIENT AND
FINISH IT DOWN IN THE ZONE, EVEN
WORK IT GLOVE SIDE IF POSSIBLE.
SCOTT: CAN THE ASTROS BATTLE
BACK?
INSIDE TO YULI.
THE FUMBLE SAYS, HERE THEY COME.
GEOFF: LATE INNINGS HERE AT HOME
FOR THE ASTROS CAN BE EXCITING.
SCOTT: HOW GOOD HAS THIS SEASON
SERIES BEEN?
GEOFF: IF YOU ARE A FAN OF
BASEBALL AND CAN PULL UP SEVEN
GAMES TO WATCH, THESE SEVEN
WOULD BE INCREDIBLE.
SCOTT: 3-0 TO YULI.
NOT LANDING THE SINKER RIGHT
NOW.
JEREMY: I FELT THAT EARLY IN MY
CAREER.
IT WAS TOUGH FOR ME TO GET GLOVE
SIDE.
YOU WOULD ALWAYS HAVE THE
CATCHER SAY HEY, DON'T TRY TO
THROW IT TOO EARLY.
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES I HAD WAS
TRYING TO THROW IT EARLY.
I COULD NOT GET THAT HAND OUT IN
FRONT.
SOME ADJUSTMENT, HOPEFULLY HE
CAN GET THOSE PITCHES WHERE HE
WANTS, LOW AND AWAY.
RIGHT THERE IS A GOOD
ADJUSTMENT.
NOT A STRIKE, BUT THAT IS A GOOD
PITCH.
3-0 COUNT, HE'S NOT GOING TO GET
A CHANCE TO WORK ON IT TODAY,
BUT GOOD TO SEE THE ADJUSTMENT
FROM A YOUNG RELIEVER.
SCOTT: MIKE WILL MAKE A SWITCH
AFTER THE ROYALS PUT UP FOUR
THANKS TO THE WHIT MERRIFIELD
GRAND SLAM IN THE TOP OF THE
INNING.
ONE RUN BACK FROM HOUSTON.
NO TWO -- NOW TWO ON.
RICHARD LOVELADY IS COMING IN.
SEVENTH INNING ACTION.
WHAT A SERIES BETWEEN THESE TWO
THIS SEASON.
THE DRAMA CONTINUES IN A MOMENT.
♪
>> THERE ARE FEW MOMENTS LIKE
IT.
MOMENTS THAT COMPARE TO ARRIVING
HERE.
AND DESPITE ALL OF A GOING TO
THE SAME PLACE, WE ALL COME FOR
DIFFERENT REASONS.
SOME COME FOR THE SIGHTS.
SOME FOR THE SOUNDS.
SOME COME FOR THE BOMBS.
SOME FOR THE BONDS.
SOME COME FOR PASSION.
SOME COME FOR THE PLAYS.
WE ALL COME TO BE PART OF
SOMETHING BIGGER THAN OURSELVES.
AND REGARDLESS OF WHAT YOU COME
FOR, THERE IS A TICKET FOR YOU.
ASTROS SEASON TICKETS.
FOR THE H.
♪
SCOTT: THIS COPYRIGHTED TELECAST
IS PRESENTED WITH AUTHORITY BY
THE OFFICE OF COMMISSIONER OF
BASEBALL AND MAY NOT BE
RETRANSMITTED IN ANY FORM.
THE ACCOUNTS AND DISRUPTIONS MAY
NOT BE DISSEMINATED WITHOUT
EXPRESS WRITTEN CONSENT.
IT'S GETTING LOUD INSIDE MINUTE
MAID PARK.
ASTROS HAD THE LEAD FOR A
MAJORITY OF THIS CONTEST.
WHIT MERRIFIELD CHANGED THAT
WITH HIS GRAND SLAM SWING.
NOW BOTTOM SEVEN, ONE RUN IN.
HUGE SPOT FOR RICHARD LOVELADY
TO ENTER.
THE ONLY LEFTY OUT OF THE BULB
AND FOR MIKE MATHENY.
DIAZ AND GURRIEL ABOARD.
YORDAN ALVAREZ, 1-3 WITH A HOME
RUN TODAY.
FIRST PITCH FOULED OFF.
JEREMY: A GREAT OPPORTUNITY FOR
RICHARD HERE.
THEY HAD JAKE BRENTZ DOING A LOT
OF THE LATE INNING RELIEF
APPEARANCES.
SO LOVELADY HAS PITCHED GREAT
THIS YEAR.
A CHANCE IN A BIG MOMENT TO PICK
UP HIS TEAMMATE HERE.
SCOTT: HE PITCHED ON MONDAY
AGAINST HOUSTON, A HIT, A
STRIKEOUT, NO RUNS AGAINST.
A 12 PITCH APPEARANCE.
SAME SPOT, ALVAREZ FOULS IT OFF.
JEREMY: THAT STRIKEOUT WAS
ALVAREZ THAT HE GOT IN HIS LAST
OUTING.
SCOTT: THERE ARE YOUR SPLITS.
THAT IS A VERY HEALTHY LINE FOR
YORDAN.
GEOFF: THAT IS WHAT IS AMAZING
ABOUT YORDAN.
HE IS A GUY THAT GOES OUT AND
TAKES A LOT OF PRIDE IN KEEPING
THE AVERAGE AROUND .280 PLUS.
BUT FOR A YOUNG HITTER TO HIT
LEFT-HANDERS AS WELL AS HE HAS
SO FAR IN HIS CAREER IS REALLY
IMPRESSIVE.
SCOTT: HE HOMERED OFF MIKE MINOR
EARLIER, WHO IS A SOUTHPAW.
GEOFF: GOOD TAKE BY YORDAN.
JEREMY: 0-2, SOMETHING HE COULD
SWING AT.
NO CHANCE HE'S GOING TO HIT IT
HERE.
GEOFF: SOMETIMES HE CAN FIGHT
THE PITCH OFF, BUT IT A GOOD JOB
HOLDING HIS GROUND.
-- DID A GOOD JOB HOLDING HIS
GROUND.
JEREMY: HE'S GOT A LOT OF
SWEEPING ACTION ON HIS SLIDER.
THAT PITCH WAS MORE MENTAL.
HE GOT JAMMED BECAUSE OF THE WAY
THAT SWEPT.
A LOT OF MOVEMENT.
SCOTT: HE USES IT 48% OF THE
TIME.
1-2.
OPEN SPACE, LEFT FIELD.
NOPE, IT IS TRACKED DOWN BY
BENINTENDI.
NICE JUMP ON THAT BASEBALL FROM
THE ROYALS LEFT FIELDER, ONE OF
THE BEST IN THE BIZ AT THE
POSITION.
LOVELADY DOES HIS JOB.
ROYALS PLAY GOOD DEFENSE.
THEY HOLD A ONE RUN LEAD THROUGH
SEVEN.
♪
>> HE IS A THROWBACK,
BLUE-COLLAR TYPE PLAYER.
HE ALWAYS SEEMS TO HAVE DIRTY
PANTS AND RIPPED KNEES, HAD PINE
TAR ALL OVER HIS BAT.
HE LOOKED LIKE HE SHOULD BE
FILMED IN BLACK-AND-WHITE.
THE NUMBERS ARE PHENOMENAL.
50 DOUBLES.
20 HOMERS.
HE WAS ON BASE 40% OF THE TIME.
HE WAS A SPECTACULAR PLAYER.
>> THE CROWD IS UP.
ONE AWAY FROM THE 3000 HIT CLUB.
>> HE JUST WANTED A DOUBLE.
I DON'T THINK THERE IS ANY
SECRET.
>> TO MAKE IT A DOUBLE.
>> HE DID NOT QUITE MAKE IT.
>> HE'S GOING TO BE OUT.
>> BAD MOVE BY HIM, BY THE WAY.
YOU CAN TELL HIM I SAID THAT.
>> 3000 CAREER HITS, AND ALL AS
AN ASTRO.
>> 3000 HITS AT HOME.
THIS IS WHAT IT WAS SUPPOSED TO
BE LIKE.
THE FANS HAVE BEEN UNBELIEVABLY
GREAT TO ME.
THANK YOU.
>> HE IS A BASE VALAIKA.
HE-- HE IS A BASEBALL ICON.
>> HE SPENT ALL HIS TIME IN AN
ASTROS UNIFORM.
♪
>> COME ON, BABY!
J.P.!
>> LET'S GO.
PUT IT BACK.
>> BIG BODY.
>> DID YOU CALL IT?
LET'S GO.
LET'S GO, BABY.
SCOTT: DID SOMEONE CALL THAT IN
THE K.C. DUGOUT?
GEOFF: THERE HAS NEVER BEEN AN
AT-BAT WITH THE BASES LOADED
THAT SOMEBODY DID NOT CALL.
KUDOS TO THE ONE THAT DID DO IT.
SCOTT: SALVADOR PEREZ ON THE
FIRST PITCH FROM JAVIER IN THE
EIGHTH.
DRIVES ONE TO DIAZ.
THERE IS YOUR FIRST OUT OF THE
INNING.
I LIKE WHIT PUMPING UP HIS
TEAMMATES WHEN THEY CROSS ON.
GOOD A.B., YOU HELPED ME OUT,
THANK YOU.
JEREMY: EXACTLY RIGHT.
THAT IS THE BRAND THEY PLAY,
RECOGNIZE EVERY CONTRIBUTION
MATTERS.
WHEN YOUR TEAM LIVES OR DIES
WITH THE HOME RUN, IT IS JUST
ABOUT WHO HITS THE HOME RUN, BUT
THOSE AT-BATS DON'T EVEN
HAPPENED WITHOUT THOSE TWO
AT-BATS.
GREAT RECOGNITION FROM ONE OF
THEIR LEADERS.
SCOTT: ANDREW BENINTENDI MADE
THE LAST OUT IN THE LAST INNING.
RICHARD LOVELADY COMES IN AND
GET YORDAN ALVAREZ TO FLIED OUT
-- TO  FLY OUT.
ROYALS WON ON MONDAY 7-1.
DOESN'T THIS TEAM LOOK BETTER
THAN 56-69?
IS IT JUST ME?
GEOFF: FOR THE SEVEN GAMES I
HAVE SEEN.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: WE WATCHED A LOT OF K.C.
VERSUS HOUSTON OVER THE PAST
WEEK.
PART OF THAT HAS BEEN THE YOUNG
PITCHING TRYING TO BLOSSOM.
THROUGH THEIR SLUMS, THEY WENT
THROUGH GROWING PAINS.
JEREMY: THOSE ARE GOING TO
HAPPEN.
THAT IS WHY THEY GET A GUY LIKE
MIKE MINOR.
EXACTLY WHAT HE DID TODAY IS ALL
THEY ASK OF HIM.
GIVE US A CHANCE TO WIN, SIX
INNINGS, THREE RUNS.
THEY HAVE TO SEE SOMEONE TAKE
THE EVERY DAY, EVEN IF
THE RESULTS ARE NOT WHERE THEY
HAVE BEEN.
THAT IS THE IMPORTANCE OF A GUY
LIKE MIKE.
SCOTT: WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
QUALITY START EARLY THIS
MORNING.
ARE THEY STILL COOL?
JEREMY: I'VE GOT THEM BEING
REALLY COOL.
GEOFF: JEREMY BRINGS UP A GOOD
POINT.
WHAT IS A QUALITY START?
STATISTICALLY IT IS SIX INNINGS,
THREE EARNED RUNS OR LESS.
THREE EARNED RUNS OVER NINE
INNINGS IS A 4.50 E.R.A.
MAYBE THAT IS NOT SOMETHING YOU
WANT TO CARRY TO THE ARBITRATION
TABLE.
BUT IF YOU ONLY GIVE UP THREE
RUNS, SIX STRONG, YOU ARE ONE
SWING AWAY FROM OPENING THIS UP
AND WINNING.
I THINK THAT IS WHERE THE
QUALITY MEANS MORE, IN THAT IT
GIVES YOUR TEAM A CHANCE TO
CREATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO WIN.
JEREMY: I THINK THAT IS PROBABLY
WHERE IT COMES FROM.
IF YOU ARE DOWN BY THREE, TWO,
OR ONE RUNS, YOU HAVE A CHANCE.
GEOFF: A WALK AND A HOME RUN
AWAY IS WHERE YOU WANT TO BE.
JEREMY: I NEVER HEARD OF A PITCH
ER ROLLING OUT THREE QUALITY
STARTS AND FINISHING WITH A 4.50
E.R.A., AND WHAT WITH THE CLUB
SAY ABOUT A GUY THAT THROWS 29
QUALITY STARTS AND A 4.40.
WITH A APPRECIATE THAT IS MUCH
AS THE NAME QUALITY START --
WOULD THEY APPRECIATE THAT AS
MUCH AS THE NAME QUALITY START
INDICATES?
I KNOW MIKE MATHENY WOULD.
EVERY TEAMMATE WOULD TAKE ON
THAT AND BANK ON IT.
GEOFF: IN THIS DAY AND AGE, WHEN
YOU ARE SO CONCERNED ABOUT PITCH
COUNT'S, HOW MANY TIMES I FACED
A LINEUP, WHEN YOU SAY QUALITY
START, I LIKE IT BECAUSE IT'S IT
IS YOU GOT TO THAT SIX INNING
THRESHOLD OR FURTHER.
IT BACKS UP SO MANY BULLPENS.
IT ALLOWS YOU TO USE YOUR
BULLPEN IN SO MANY WAYS TO KEEP
THEM RESTED AND USEFUL.
SCOTT: CRISTIAN JAVIER FREEZES
HUNTER DOZIER.
NICE INNING FROM THAT RELIEVER.
LAST OF THE EIGHTH COMING UP.
♪
>> THANKS FOR HANGING OUT WITH
ME TODAY.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> IF YOU DID NOT PLAY BASEBALL,
WHAT SPORT WOULD YOU PLAY?
>> BASKETBALL.
>> SOMETIMES?
>> SOCCER TOO.
>> WHAT IS YOUR FAVORITE AWAY
STADIUM TO PLAY IN?
>> IT IS INTO THE UPPER DECK.
>> TARGET FIELD.
>> ANY FIELD I HAVE 19 HOMERS,
I'M GOING TO LIKE THAT ONE TOO.
[LAUGHTER]
DO YOU HAVE ANY PREGAME RITUALS
OR SUPERSTITIONS?
>> I DON'T THINK PEOPLE WANT TO
KNOW THAT.
[LAUGHTER]
I GOT TO BE HONEST WITH YOU.
>> WHO IS THE MOST COMPETITIVE
GUY ON THE TEAM?
>> I AM.
>> YOU?
I KNEW IT.
>> I LIKE TO PLAY HARD AND GIVE
IT EVERYTHING I HAVE.
♪
SCOTT: THE MLB GAME OF THE WEEK
LIVE ON YOUTUBE IS PRESENTED BY
YOUTUBE TV.
WATCH LIVE TV WITH UNLIMITED
DVR, NO CABLE BOX REQUIRED.
YOUTUBE TV.
I LOVE IT.
I'VE GOT IT.
THIS IS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
RECOGNIZE THE GREAT MIMKE BRADY.
TODAY'S THIRD BASE CAMERA
OPERATOR.
HE'S WORKING HIS LAST GAME THIS
AFTERNOON.
WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK HIM FOR
EVERYTHING HE CONTRIBUTED TO THE
ASTROS AND HIS 31 YEARS.
HE WILL STILL BE COMMANDING THAT
THING FOR FOOTBALL AND RODEO,
BUT MIKE, CHEERS TO YOU.
GEOFF: GREAT HAVING HIM AROUND.
DOES A PHENOMENAL JOB.
SCOTT: NICE VIEW TO WATCH A
BALLGAME.
GEOFF: PRETTY STRONG.
JEREMY: RICHARD LOVELADY DID A
PHENOMENAL JOB IN A TOUGH SPOT
FOR THE ROYALS.
WE TURN IT OVER TO JOSH.
ONE OF THE RELIEVERS I HAVE
WANTED TO SEE IN PERSON WITH
THAT ELECTRIC HARM HE HAS.
SCOTT: HE'S GOT THE FLOW IN THE
BACK TOO.
HE BRINGS FIRE.
HE WILL NEED IT.
CORREA, BRADEN, TUCKER --
BREGMAN, TUCKER DUE UP FOR
HOUSTON.
FIVE, SIX, AND SEVEN.
GEOFF: WORKING THEIR WAY BACK TO
FULL STRENGTH DOES CREATE A
DYNAMIC FOR THESE PITCHERS TO
GET TO THESE LINEUPS.
IT HAS BEEN A LOT OF FUN OVER
THE YEARS TO WATCH THESE GUYS
PLATE AND UNDERSTAND HOW MUCH
POSTSEASON EXPERIENCE THESE GUYS
HAVE ACCRUED SINCE THE 2015
SEASON.
THEY HAVE REACHED THEIR WAY ONTO
THE LEADERBOARD POSTSEASON I
THINK IT HELPED THEM PLAY EVEN
DURING THE REGULAR SEASON.
SCOTT: 2-1 TO CORREA.
HOW CAN IT NOT?
YOU LOOK AT A SPOT LIKE THIS AND
YOU CAN LOOK BACK ON EXPERIENCES
THAT WERE A LITTLE MORE PRESSURE
PACKED.
[LAUGHTER]
GEOFF: 45,000 OF THEIR FAVORITE
FANS HERE, COMING UP IN BIG
SITUATIONS.
WHAT I LOVE ABOUT THESE GUYS IS
EACH GUY WANTS TO BE IN THAT
POSITION TO GET THAT BIG HIT.
SCOTT: MANY OF THEM HAVE DONE
IT.
GEOFF: THAT IS TRUE.
SCOTT: AND THEN WHEN THEY REACH
FREE AGENCY, IF THEY ARE NOT
KEPT, THEY ARE HIGHLY COVETED.
EXAMPLE A, GEORGE SPRINGER NOW
WITH THE BLUE JAYS.
GEOFF: THAT WAS A TOUGH PILL TO
SWALLOW FOR ASTRO FANS LOSING A
GUY LIKE GEORGE SPRINGER.
JOSE ALTUVE TIPTON AND THE
LINEUP -- STEPPED IN IN THE
LINEUP.
NOW IT'S GUYS LIKE MEYERS AND
CHAS MCCORMICK.
AND YOU ARE NOT ABLE TO SEE A
GUY LIKE JAKE MEYERS IN THIS
LINEUP START AT CENTER FIELD ON
A PENNANT CHASING TEAM UNLESS
YOU HAVE THE MAGNIFICENT SEVEN
WE TALKED ABOUT, WHERE YOU DON'T
HAVE TO LEAN ON A GUY LIKE JAKE
MEYERS.
SCOTT: NICE A.B. FROM CORREA.
THEY WILL MAKE STAUMONT WORK.
THERE IS MEYERS.
IF YOU ARE SOMEONE LIKE HIM AND
YOU COME UP TO THIS TEAM, I'M
SURE YOU ARE PICKING EVERYONE'S
BRAIN ALL DAY LONG.
TELL ME WHAT I NEED TO DO TO BE
LIKE YOU.
YOU CAN SAY THAT TO ALMOST
ANYONE IN THE LINEUP.
IT WOULD BE A GREAT COMBO.
GEOFF: THIS CLUBHOUSE ARE MORE
THAN WELCOMING.
THERE IS NO HIERARCHY.
THEY WANT YOU TO HELP PRODUCE.
THEY WILL HELP JAKE MEYERS
ACCLIMATE ANYWAY THEY CAN.
SCOTT: CORREA SETS THE TABLE.
SECOND FREE PASS FOR HIM THIS
AFTERNOON.
ON-BASE PERCENTAGE LEADERS TO
LEAD OFF INNINGS.
HOUSTON DOES A BETTER THAN
ANYONE IN THE AMERICAN LEAGUE.
K.C. NUMBER THREE ON THAT BOARD.
THAT IS WHY DUSTY BAKER ALMOST
ALWAYS HAS A SMILE ON HIS FACE.
HE'S A HAPPY GUY IN GENERAL, BUT
HE TAKES OVER A TEAM THAT CAN
SWING THE BAT, AND NOT SWING THE
BAT WHEN NECESSARY.
GEOFF: IN 2020, WHEN HE GOT A
HOLD OF THIS BALLCLUB, WE HAD A
CHANCE TO INTERVIEW HIM ON THE
RADIO, HE SAID I'VE GOT THE KEYS
TO THE FERRERI.
SCOTT: BREGMAN GOES.
TAYLOR TRACKING BACK.
GOT IT.
CORREA WILL STAY AT FIRST.
SOME NICE SWINGS TODAY FROM ALEX
BREGMAN.
FIRST CAME BACK IN A COUPLE
MONTHS.
GEOFF: I COMPLETELY AGREE.
EVEN THOUGH THAT ENDS UP BEING A
FLY OUT TO CENTER FIELD, HE'S
DONE A GOOD JOB DRIVING THE BALL
TO CENTER FIELD.
GOT THAT BASE HIT EARLIER GOING
THE OTHER WAY.
HE KNEW HE HIT IT TO THE OTHER
PART OF THE BALLPARK.
HE MAY HAVE EVEN SAID, WHY DID I
GO THERE?
[LAUGHTER]
JEREMY: I AM SURE THE AMERICAN
LEAGUE WEST PITCHERS ARE TAKING
NOTE.
THEY WILL HAVE THEIR WORK CUT
OUT FOR THEM WITH ANOTHER
ELECTRIC BAT IN THE LINEUP.
SCOTT: THIS MAN CAN SWING IT
TOO.
ACTIVATED YESTERDAY.
HE GOES AFTER THE FIRST PITCH.
WALKS CORREA, THEN BREGMAN
HUNGRY EARLY.
JEREMY: YOU SEE STAUMONT USING A
LOT OF THE CURVEBALL.
IN TALKING WITH SOME OF THE
ROYALS, I THINK FOR A LOT OF
THEIR YOUNG PITCHERS, LAST YEAR,
WHAT HAPPENED WITH THE OFF SITE
WHERE THEY WOULD GO AND WORK, IT
GAVE PITCHERS A CHANCE TO WORK
ON OTHER PITCHES.
STAUMONT THROWS UPPER 90'S, OVER
100.
HE HAD NUMEROUS PITCHES OVER 100
A COUPLE SEASONS AGO, BUT LAST
YEAR HE HAD COVID, SO WE HAD TO
WORK HIS WAY BACK INTO IT.
SPENT HIS TIME THROWING A LOT OF
THOSE PRACTICE GAMES WHILE
GETTING BACK INTO SHAPE.
HE DEVELOPED A LOT OF TRUST IN
THIS CURVEBALL, WHICH MAKES THIS
FASTBALL MORE
IMPORTANT.
HE'S REACHING THE UPPER 90'S
AGAIN, ALTHOUGH EARLIER IN THE
YEAR HE WAS IN THE MID-90'S.
SOUNDS LIKE A NICE LUXURY TO BE
DOWN AND ONLY IN THE MID-90'S,
BUT YOU ARE USED TO PITCHING
WITH 100, IT DOES MAKE AN IMPACT
ON YOUR APPROACH.
SCOTT: ONE OUT, ONE ON FOR
TUCKER.
JEREMY: THAT IS A SHARP
CURVEBALL.
DID NOT GET THE CALL THERE.
GEOFF: GOOD TAKE.
THAT IS ONE OF THOSE ONES AS A
HITTER THAT BUCKLES YOU.
CALL IT A BALL, YES.
JEREMY: I WOULD LIKE THE THIRD
BASEMAN CHECK THE HOME PLATE
UMPIRE ON THE WIDTH OF THAT
PITCH.
WAS THAT WIDE?
CHECK THE HOME PLATE UMPIRE ON
THAT PITCH.
SCOTT: THAT IS A NICE SWING
GOING THE OTHER WAY.
KYLE TUCKER KEEPS THE TRAIN
ROLLING.
CORREA TO SECOND.
GEOFF: PRETTY GOOD SWING ON 97.
BUT IT'S ALSO A FASTBALL.
A LITTLE BIT OF A TWO-SEAMER AT
97.
KYLE DOES A GOOD JOB SHOOTING IN
THE OTHER WAY AND CONTINUING
THIS INNING.
SCOTT: NICE LITTLE WEAPON OFF
THE BENCH THIS AFTERNOON.
MICHAEL BRENLY WILL -- MICHAEL
BRANTLEY WILL CLIMB IN.
SEE IF JAKE MEYERS CAN CREATE
SOME ACTION FOR HOUSTON.
MEYERS IS 2-3 TODAY.
TAKES ONE DOWN BROADWAY.
THERE HE IS.
I THINK ABOUT ANOTHER ONE-LINER
FROM DUSTY THIS SEASON.
HE SAYS WE ARE NOT THE BIG RED
MACHINE, BUT MAYBE WE ARE THE
ORANGE WAGON OR SOMETHING?
[LAUGHTER]
I THINK YOU NEED A MORE FIERCE
NAME FOR THIS OFFENSE WHEN
BRANDLEY IS COMING OFF YOUR
BENCH.
GEOFF: I WOULD AGREE, MAYBE
SOMETHING MORE DANGEROUS.
SCOTT: ORANGE FERRARI SOUNDS
BETTER.
THAT IS IN THERE.
A LITTLE INCONSISTENT ON THE
ZONE, BUT THAT LOOKS LIKE IT WAS
A STRIKE.
IT IS JUST WE SAW A PITCHER
EARLIER IN THE SAME SPOT.
GEOFF: I WOULD HAVE CHANGED THE
AT-BAT A LITTLE BIT FOR KYLE
TUCKER IF HE HAD THAT CALLED ON
HIM.
SCOTT: CORREA AND TUCKER ON FOR
JAKE MEYERS.
0-2 TO THE ROOKIE.
JEREMY: WE SAW THAT GRAPHIC
EARLIER, THIRD AMONGST RELIEVERS
WITH THE STRIKEOUT AND
CURVEBALL.
CLEARLY A PITCH HE LIKES TO GO
WITH.
IF HE CAN EXECUTE THE FESTIVAL,
PROBABLY WILL NOT PUT A GREAT
SWING ON IT.
HE'S REALLY GOT HIM SET UP FOR
THESE PITCHES.
SCOTT: SCOTT BARLOW, WHO IS THE
K.C. CLOSER DU JOUR.
UNEXPECTED.
HE HAS BEEN REALLY EFFECTIVE IN
HIGH LEVERAGE SPOTS.
THE ROYALS ORGANIZATION LOVES
THIS ARM, JOSH STAUMONT.
GEOFF: THERE IS A FASTBALL TO
SPEED THINGS UP.
SOMETIMES YOU HEAR HITTERS TO
SAY I WILL TRY AND HIT OFF THE
FASTBALL.
MENTALLY YOUR MIND IS GETTING
READY FOR 97.
IF HE COMES AT YOU WITH A
BREAKING OR SOMETHING OFFSPEED,
HOPEFULLY YOUR HANDS ARE IN GOOD
ENOUGH POSITION READY TO FIRE.
SOMETIMES YOU CAN LOSE THAT
LOWER HALF.
THE HANDS ARE BACK AND YOU GET
UP THE ZONE, YOU STILL HAVE THE
ABILITY TO TRY AND FIND SOME
OPEN SPACE OUT THERE.
SCOTT: MEYERS SEARCHING FOR HIS
THIRD HIT OF THE DAY.
HE STRIKES OUT.
JEREMY: BIG STRIKEOUT FOR HIM.
CURVEBALL BACKED UP ON THE INNER
THIRD.
NOTHING TOUGHER TO HIT THAN THE
BACKED UP BREAKING BALL.
GEOFF: NOT SOMETHING YOU TEACH,
BUT WHEN YOU GET IT, IT'S MORE
EFFECTIVE THAN IT IS NOT.
SCOTT: MATCHUP OF THE DAY.
LOOKS LIKE IT WILL BELONG TO
BARLOW.
MIKE MATHENY COMING TO THE
MOUND.
MICHAEL BRANTLEY WILL PINCH-HIT
FOR HOUSTON.
HERE COMES BARLOW.
MOST LIKELY GOING FOR A FOUR OUT
SAVE THIS AFTERNOON.
BIG TIME BIG-LEAGUE MATCHUP IN A
TIGHT SERIES BETWEEN THE ASTROS
AND THE ROYALS.
♪
>> MAKE FUN OF ME AND MY
BALLCLUB.
>> HEART IS PALPITATING.
>> YES.
♪
>> THIS ONE LINED INTO LEFT
FIELD.
SAFE.
>> MAKES THE CATCH.
[LAUGHTER]
ADDS A LITTLE BIT TO THE END.
THE JUDGES WILL NOT GIVE THEM A
HIGH SCORE FOR THAT THIS ROUND.
>> CIMBER WAS WARMING UP WHEN HE
CAME INTO THE GAME.
WATCH THE LEFT OF YOUR SCREEN.
[LAUGHTER]
IF ONLY THESE GUYS COULD LOOSEN
UP AND HAVE A LITTLE FUN.
>> THEY LIKE TO HAVE FUN.
♪
>> OUT OF PLAY.
.
FALLS DOWN AT HOME PLATE.
SLIPPED TO THE GROUND AFTER THE
BIG CUT.
>> YOU DON'T SEE THAT VERY
OFTEN.
>> UH OH, WHAT IS THAT?
>> A MANTIS PRAYING FORA RALLY.
>> HE'S GOT HIS BUDDY ON HIM.
I'VE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THAT BEFORE.
♪
SCOTT: THE HEAT IS ON FOR SCOTT
BARLOW.
SCOTT BRAUN, JEREMY GUTHRIE
WATCHING THE ACTION WITH YOU
TODAY.
WORLDWIDE ON YOUTUBE.
BARLOW HAS BEEN THE MAN IN THE
LATE STAGES FOR K.C.
8-13 IN SAVE CHANGES.
74 STRIKEOUTS ON THE YEAR IN HIS
60 INNINGS.
OH, WELCOME TO THE GAME TO FACE
MICHAEL BRANTLEY.
PINCH HITTER IN THE NINE SPOT
THIS AFTERNOON FOR DUSTY BAKER'S
HOUSTON CREW.
BRANTLEY IS IN A RARE CHILLY
SPOT IN THE SEASON.
THREE FOR HIS LAST 30.
NO EXTRA-BASE HITS.
I DON'T KNOW.
THERE IS CORREA, WHO WALKED OFF
TO START THE EIGHTH.
TWO BATTERS LATER, TUCKER WITH
THE BASE HIT.
GEOFF: THIS IS AN EXTREMELY NICE
WEAPON FOR DUSTY BAKER TO HAVE
COMING OFF THE BENCH.
FOUR YEARS -- THREE YEARS WITH
THE ASTROS, HIT .300 EVERY
SINGLE YEAR.
COMING INTO THIS GAME, TOP TWO
HITTERS IN THE AMERICAN LEAGUE
ARE YULI GURRIEL AND MICHAEL
BRANTLEY.
BRANTLEY WAS WELL IN THE LEAD AS
FAR AS BATTING AVERAGE WAS
CONCERNED AND THE AMERICAN
LEAGUE.
UPTAKE SPOT FOR HIM AGAINST
BARLOW.
SCOTT: LOOKS LIKE HE HAS HANDLED
PINCHHITTING PRETTY WELL IN HIS
LIFE TOO.
JEREMY: BARLOW WILL MIX IN THAT
SLIDER, THAT CURVEBALL WITH A
GOOD FASTBALL.
THE ROYALS HAVE HANDLED MICHAEL
BRANTLEY WELL THIS YEAR.
ONE HIT AGAINST HIM IN SIX
GAMES.
THIS IS A MUCH-DESERVED OFF DAY
FOR HIM.
BARLOW WILL MIX AND MATCH CURVE
AND SLIDER.
SEE IF HE CAN GET SOMETHING DONE
WITH SOFT CONTACT.
SCOTT: OVER THE WEEKEND THE
ROYALS SWEPT THE CUBS.
BRANTLEY CENTER FIELD.
HE'S IN BUSINESS.
CORREA ROUNDING THIRD.
AND WE WILL TIE THIS GAME UP AT
5-5 WITH THE BRANTLEY R.B.I.
KNOCK.
WHAT A BACK-AND-FORTH AFFAIR
WITH THESE TWO.
WE SEE MICHAEL BRANTLEY COME
THROUGH OFF THE BENCH TODAY FOR
HOUSTON.
GEOFF: WHEN YOU OPEN UP
WEBSTER'S DICTIONARY AND YOU SAY
PROFESSIONAL BETTER, IT WILL
SHOW YOU -- BATTER, IT WILL SHOW
YOU MICHAEL BRANTLEY.
HE'S SO CONTROLLED AND QUIET AT
THE PLATE THAT IT DOES NOT
MATTER THE VELOCITY, JUST WHERE
YOU ARE GOING TO PUT THAT PITCH.
HE IS LIKE -- NOT TOO MANY
HITTERS IN THE BIG LEAGUES CAN
ROLL OUT OF BED AND GET THE
BARREL TO THE BASEBALL.
HE HAS BEEN SUCH A LUXURY FOR
THEM TO HAVE.
HE IS THAT STEADFAST FREE AGENT
THAT HAS SOLIDIFIED THIS LINEUP
FOR THE ASTROS.
HE HAS BEEN A BLAST TO WATCH IN
THIS UNIFORM.
GOING THROUGH CLEVELAND, THEY
ARE GOING OH MAN, HERE COMES
MICHAEL BRANTLEY AGAIN.
JEREMY: A PROFESSIONAL HITTER.
I CAN ONLY IMAGINE WHAT IT MEANT
TO THOSE PITCHERS TO SEE HIM
LEAVE.
NEVER TRIES TO DO TOO MUCH.
HE LETS THE HANDS WORK.
HE CAN TAKE IT DEEP INTO THE
STANDS.
USES THE WHOLE FIELD.
A.
LUXURY.
WHAT A GREAT JOB BY DUSTY TO
GIVE HIM AN OFF DAY.
GEOFF: CHANGES THE RHYTHM OF
WHERE HE HAS BEEN EVERY AT-BAT.
BREAK THE RHYTHM.
THAT IS ACTUALLY A REALLY GOOD
CALL.
I THINK IT IS A GREAT CALL.
SCOTT: ON THE CORNERS FOR
ALTUVE.
SKIES ONE.
BENINTENDI SEARCHING.
THERE IT IS.
SIDE RETIRED.
WE ARE TIED AT 5-5 THANKS TO
MICHAEL BRANTLEY OFF THE BENCH.
CLUTCH.
♪
>> WELCOME TO THIS LITTLE
INTERSTATE SQUABBLE, OTHERWISE
KNOWN AS THE 1985 WORLD SERIES.
>> JOHN TUDOR DELIVERS.
HE SWINGS AND MISSES.
♪
>> AND IT'S HIT DOWN THE LINE IN
LEFT FIELD.
THE CARDINALS WIN 4-2.
>> THIS IS A CY YOUNG
PERFORMANCE TONIGHT.
2-2.
THE KANSAS CITY ROYALS BEAT THE
CARDINALS.
♪
>> CARDINALS LEAD THE WORLD
SERIES 3-1.
>> JACKSON HAS BEEN BRILLIANT.
HERE WE COME AGAIN.
>> RACES OVER TO COVER.
THE THROW DOES NOT GET HIM.
>> I DON'T THINK THERE IS ANY
DOUBT.
>> HE SCORES.
WE GO TO A SEVENTH.
>> FOR THE TITLE.
>> THE KANSAS CITY ROYALS ARE
THE 1985 WORLD CHAMPIONS.
♪
SCOTT: KNOTTED UP AT 5-5.
WE ARE IN THE NINTH IN HOUSTON,
TEXAS.
THERE IS ONLY ONE PLACE YOU CAN
TAKE A BOAT RIDE WITH SALVADOR
PEREZ, THE ROYALS YOUTUBE
CHANNEL.
SUBSCRIBE TODAY AND WATCH
EXCLUSIVE CONTENT ON THE ASTROS
YOUTUBE CHANNEL.
YOUTUBE.COM/ASTROS AND FOLLOW
THE ASTROS TODAY.
WE ARE FOLLOWING BOTH.
THEY ARE PUTTING ON A SHOW.
RYAN PRESSLY IS THE MAN OF THE
NIGHT FOR HOUSTON.
PLEASED TO BE WITH YOU ON A
WEDNESDAY AFTERNOON TO A
WORLDWIDE AUDIENCE.
JASON CASTRO WILL TAKE OVER
BEHIND THE PLATE.
DUSTY BAKER PRESSING THE RIGHT
BUTTON IN THE EIGHTH.
CONCERNING MICHAEL BRANTLEY IN
THE NINE SPOT.
HERE IS JARROD DYSON, FORMER
JEREMY GUTHRIE TEAMMATE.
BOUNCES THAT OUT.
JEREMY: FUN TO SEER OD OUT -- TO
SEE ROD OUT THERE.
ONE OF THOSE GUYS THAT EASILY
COULD HAVE BEEN TAKEN BY SOMEONE
ELSE.
NOW A 10 YEAR CAREER, A PART OF
SOME BIG WINS.
GOOD TO SEE HIM YESTERDAY.
SCOTT: HOW OFTEN DID HE LET
EVERYONE KNOW HE WAS SELECTED IN
ROUND NUMBER 50?
HOW MANY PEOPLE PAST -- PASSED
ME BY?
JEREMY: I HEARD A GREAT STORY,
THERE WERE TWO PLAYERS AND THE
ROYALS PLANNED TO DRAFT ANOTHER
GUY, LOOKED THROUGH IT.
A FOLDER, AND IT ENDED UP BEING
DYSON.
LOOKED UP THROUGH THE LEAGUES.
A GREAT BASEBALL STORY ABOUT
GUYS WORKING HARD, PERSEVERING
AND MAKING IT THROUGH.
SCOTT: WHAT IS THE GAME WITH THE
BRIEFCASES?
DEAL OR NO DEAL.
TAKE THAT ONE.
THAT ONE IS LIGHTNING FAST.
SO IS MICHAEL A. TAYLOR, WHO
TURNS AWAY FROM A FASTBALL.
ALMOST HIT HIM.
GEOFF: I LOVE TEARING STORIES
ABOUT GUYS GETTING THAT 10 YEAR
PLATEAU.
IT MEANS SO MUCH TO THE PLAYER
THEMSELVES IN SO MANY DIFFERENT
WAYS.
IT HELPS OUT THE FAMILY BECAUSE
THEIR PENSION KICKS IN.
BUT TO PLAY FOR 10 YEARS AT THIS
LEVEL SAYS A LOT ABOUT THE
PERSEVERANCE OF A HUMAN BEING.
THERE ARE GUYS THAT ARE ELITE
AND HAVE ALL THE TALENT IN THE
WORLD, BUT THEN YOU HAVE THE
JARROD DYSONS WHO SCRATCH FOR 10
YEARS.
THEY SHOULD BE RECOGNIZED AND
HONORED IN WHAT THEY DO.
WHEN YOU GO THROUGH THE DUGOUT
AT THE CLUBHOUSES AND IF
JARROD DYSON MEETS SOMEONE IN
FIVE YEARS, DID YOU PLAY THE BIG
LEAGUES?
FOR FIVE YEARS.
JEREMY: THIS WILL GO AWAY.
YOU HAVE PLAYED 10 CONSECUTIVE
YEARS IN THE MAJOR LEAGUES, BID
TO THE PLAYOFFS NUMEROUS TIMES,
THIS WILL GO AWAY EVERY TIME YOU
HAVE A CHANCE TO TOUCH SOMEONE'S
LIFE.
HE HAS NOT PLAYED A TON THIS
YEAR, SO I CAN IMAGINE WHAT THAT
IS LIKE FOR A VETERAN.
EVERY DAY YOU HAVE A CHANCE TO
IMPACT SOMEONE'S LIFE.
IT WILL GO AWAY.
WHO KNOWS HOW MANY MORE GAMES,
HOW MANY YEARS HE HAS IN THIS
LEAGUE.
BE GRATEFUL FOR EVERY ONE OF
THEM.
GO MAKE AN IMPACT.
SCOTT: HE'S ALWAYS BEEN ABLE TO
RUNDOWN A BASEBALL WITH THE BEST
OF THEM.
JEREMY: THAT IS WHAT SPEED DO.
THAT WAS HIS FAMOUS QUOTE YEARS
AGO.
THAT IS WHAT SPEED DO.
SCOTT: HE IS FUN TO BE AROUND.
2-2 ON TAYLOR.
DID HE GO?
NO.
MICHAEL A. TAYLOR TRIED TO STEAL
HOME YESTERDAY.
I WANTED TO SNEAK THAT IN.
LUIS GARCIA DOES NOT HAVE THE
QUICKEST DELIVERY ON THE PLANET.
THAT WAS PUT TO THE TEST, BUT HE
RUSHED IT AND TAYLOR WAS TOAST.
I THINK THAT HELPS TO TELL THE
STORY OF WHY THE ROYALS ARE SO
FUN TO WATCH.
TAYLOR UP THE MIDDLE.
IT WILL BE A TOUGH PLAY FOR
ALTUVE.
TAYLOR WILL REACH.
BASE HIT FOR MICHAEL A. TAYLOR.
JEREMY: I THINK JOSE WAS WELL
AWARE OF THAT SPEED AS WELL,
TRYING TO FIELD THAT BALL.
GEOFF: HE'S AWAY FROM THE BAG
HE'S TRYING TO THROW TO.
WHEN YOU KNOW A GUY HAS SPEED AT
HOME PLATE, YOU KNOW THERE IS SO
MUCH PRESSURE ON THE EXCHANGE
FROM THE GLOVE TO THE BAREHAND
THAT IF YOU DON'T MAKE THE
EXCHANGE THERE IS NO CHANCE.
SCOTT: THAT IS A VETERAN TOO
THAT KNOWS IF I MAKE A BAD THROW
AND TAYLOR IS IN SCORING
POSITION, WE ARE IN TROUBLE.
5-5 GAME IN THE NINTH.
GEOFF: THAT IS A GOOD POINT.
SCOTT: NUMBER EIGHT HITTER
EMMANUEL RIVERA.
RIVER IS NEW TO THE PARTY.
FIRST CAREER HOME RUN ON FRIDAY
WAS AT WRIGLEY FIELD.
HIS FIRST CAREER HIT WAS IN
BOSTON AT FENWAY.
HE'S JUST RACKING UP THE CLASSIC
BALLPARKS WITH MILESTONES.
HERE IN HOUSTON ON MONDAY, WE
SAW HIM DELIVER HIS FIRST THREE
HIT GAME IN HIS CAREER.
JEREMY: I KNOW HE'S A FEW
HOMERUNS AWAY, BUT DOES HE HAVE
A LOOK LIKE NELSON CRUZ OR AM I
SEEING SOMETHING WRONG?
SCOTT: YOU ARE SAYING WITH SWING
OR FACE?
JEREMY: THE FACE.
THE SWING LOOKS LIKE A GOOD
PLACE TO BE TOO.
GEOFF: AND IF YOU ARE DOING
UNTIL YOU ARE 40 YEARS OLD WITH
DAMAGE.
SCOTT: THEY START CALLING HIM
BABY NELLY, I THINK HE WILL TAKE
IT.
HERE IS TAYLOR ON FIRST.
0-1 FROM PRESLEY.
CALLED JUST OFF THE PLATE, BUT
NO, IT IS A SWING.
GEOFF: RYAN PRESSLY CAME OVER
FROM MINNESOTA.
THE REASON THEY TRADED FOR HIM
WAS BECAUSE OF THE SPIN RATE.
EVERYTHING WAS A SPIN RATE.
SINCE HE HAS COME OVER TO
HOUSTON, HE HAS BEEN IN THAT SET
UP ROLE AND MOVED INTO THE
CLOSING ROLE, WHERE HE HAS TAKEN
OFF.
THE SLIDER HE THROWS IS
ABSOLUTELY DEVASTATING.
HE SNAPS IT OFF THE OUTSIDE
CORNER.
YOU CAN SEE THE SWINGS THAT YOU
JUST SAW FROM RIVERA.
YOU GET THE IDEA IT IS A
FASTBALL, AND THEY CAN HOLD UP
BECAUSE THERE IS SO MUCH SHARP
RIGHT ON THAT SLIDER.
-- SHARP BREAK ON THAT SLIDER.
JEREMY: HE HAS BEEN SO AMAZING
FOR THIS CLUB.
INTERESTING TO HEAR THE
PERSPECTIVE, THIS IS SOMEONE WE
CAN WORK WITH.
CLEARLY HE HAS BEEN ABLE TO HELP
HIMSELF AND THEY HAVE HELPED
HIM.
SCOTT: JUST THE POWER IS SO
GOOD.
GEOFF: EVERYTHING ABOUT HIM IS
POWER.
HE THROWS THAT POWER CURVEBALL.
EVERYTHING IS MAX EFFORT.
IT'S AMAZING TO SEE THE
MOVEMENT.
THEY WERE SEARCHING FOR THAT
CLOSUER. -- CLOSER.
THEY WERE NOT SURE IF RYAN
PRESSLY WOULD TAKE CONTROL OF
THE END OF THE BALLGAME, BUT HE
HAS DONE A GREAT JOB.
SCOTT: A BRILLIANT PICKUP A FEW
YEARS AGO.
A FEW YEARS BEFORE THAT, THE
ASTROS SIGNED CHARLIE MORTON
THANKS TO SOME SPIN RATE'S THEY
ENJOYED.
THAT WORKED OUT.
A STRIKE TO GALLAGHER.
STRIKEOUTS FROM THE BREAKING
BALL SINCE 2018, RYAN PRESSLY
LEADS THE PACK.
I'M GOING TO GIVE CAM GALLAGHER
THE MOST UNDERRATED A.B. OF THE
DAY.
THERE IS NOT NECESSARILY A
YOUTUBE TROPHY FOR THAT
POSTGAME.
BUT BACK IN THE SEVENTH, TWO ON,
TWO OUTS, WORKS A WALK AGAINST
MCCULLERS, KNOCKS HIM OUT OF THE
GAME.
JAVIER COMES IN.
MERRIFIELD ON ONE PAGE BLASTS
THE ROYALS TO A GRAND SLAM AND
5-3 LEAD AT THE TIME.
THE ASTROS HAVE BATTLED BACK.
NOW GALLAGHER WILL PULL THAT
FOUL LEFT SIDE.
GEOFF: WHIT MERRIFIELD, IF YOU
DON'T GET THE GUY ON BASE,
REMEMBER THE PREVIOUS AT-BAT
WHERE WE HAD WHIT MERRIFIELD
MIC'ED UP AND HE SAID THAT IS A
GOOD SLIDER?
WE KNOW THERE WAS FATIGUE WITH
LANCE, BUT MERRIFIELD DID NOT
HAVE TO HAVE THAT SLIDER
REPERTOIRE.
HE GOT A HOLD OF HIM.
JEREMY: ONE OF THOSE THINGS.
ALL BECAUSE OF GREAT AT-BATS.
GEOFF: EXACTLY.
SCOTT: LOOK AT RYAN PRESSLY.
STRAIGHTENED UP CAM GALLAGHER
WITH A FASTBALL.
THAT IS IN THERE.
THEY WILL LOOK BACK ON YOUTUBE
AND SAY OKAY, GOOD CALL.
RYAN PRESSLY STRANDS MICHAEL
TAYLOR AT FIRST.
SHOWING OFF THE FULL DISPLAY
THIS AFTERNOON IN THE NINTH AND
GIVING HIS TEAM A CHANCE TO WALK
IT OFF.
♪
>> WHEN I CAME UP IN 1976, IT
WAS A BIG POWERHOUSE.
>> THE ROYALS GO TO THE WORLD
SERIES.
>> OUR THING WAS WE NEVER
BRUSHED OURSELVES OFF.
YOU KNOCK ME DOWN, I WILL GET
BACK UP, ALL DIRT, EVERYTHING,
BECAUSE YOU ARE NOT INTIMIDATING
ME.
>> YOU DID NOT HAVE GUYS TRYING
TO AVOID THE TAG.
WE JUST RAN OVER THE TAG TO
PREVENT THE DOUBLE PLAY.
>> FROM 1976 TO 1985, THE ROYALS
WON TWO PENNANTS, CULMINATING IN
THE UNFORGETTABLE 1985 WORLD
SERIES TITLE.
THEY WERE LED BY A FUTURE HALL
OF FAMER AT THIRD BASE.
>> WE DRAFTED GEORGE IN 1971.
WHEN I SAW HIM AS AN 18-YEAR-OLD
KID FOR THE FIRST TIME, I
REALIZED WE HAVE SOMEONE
SPECIAL.
>> HE'S ONE OF THE GREATEST
PLAYERS OF ALL TIME.
>> GREAT HUSTLE, GREAT HEART,
GREAT GRIT, AND THE SEEMING
ABILITY TO COME THROUGH IN THE
CLUTCH EVERY TIME.
>>V THREE RUN HOME RUN.
-- THREE RUN HOME RUN.
>> IF YOU CHALLENGED HIM, HE
ALWAYS CAME THROUGH.
♪
SCOTT: BACK-AND-FORTH BATTLE
WITH THE ROYALS AND ASTROS
TODAY.
THE ASTROS HAVE 35 GAMES LEFT.
THEY ARE OFF TOMORROW.
THEIR TRIP IS NIGHT GAMES.
THREE IN ARLINGTON, THREE IN
SEATTLE, THREE AGAINST THE SAN
DIEGO TEAM.
LET MISS DIAZ WILL START OFF
--ALEDMYS DIAZ WILL START OFF
THE NINTH.
SCOTT BARLOW IS BACK IN THERE.
DIAZ, MURIEL, ALVAREZ.
THE NEXT THREE ARE NO FUN FOR
RELIEVERS EITHER.
GEOFF: YOU BETTER BE ON POINT
EARLY.
SCOTT: IF YOU ARE MIKE MATHENY,
YOU ARE THINKING NO LEADOFF
WALKS, PLEASE.
WE DID THE NATIONALS LAST WEEK
WITH DAVE MARTINEZ TALKING ABOUT
A YOUNG GROUP THAT IS TURNING
THINGS OVER, AND THAT WAS THE
NUMBER ONE RULE FOR YOUNG
RELIEVERS, NO LEADOFF WALKS.
PUMP THOSE PITCHES IN THE ZONE.
GEOFF: EVERY POSTGAME INTERVIEW
YOU HEAR WHERE THE GUY DID NOT
DO WELL, I DID NOT GET THE FIRST
PITCH STRIKE.
IT CREATES SO MANY OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THE HITTERS TO TAKE CONTROL.
SCOTT: DIAZ TWISTED ONE FOUL.
JEREMY: TO GET AHEAD IS THE MOST
UNDERRATED THING A PITCHER CAN
DO.
I TALKED TO ANOTHER FRIEN -- TO
A FRIEND THE OTHER DAY, I WISH I
KNEW THE POWER OF STRIKE ONE.
YOU DON'T REALLY NEED THE
PERFECT PITCH, JUST THROW A
STRIKE.
THEY DO YOU A FAVOR ANYWAYS IF
IT IS FIRST PITCH IN PLAY.
SCOTT: STRIKE THREE.
THEY COULD PUNCH OUT FOR BARLOW
TO START THE NINTH AGAINST DIAZ.
JEREMY: BIG OUT.
THIS GAME HAS SHAPED UP TO BE
LIKE MIKE MARNER'S LAST -- MIKE
MINOR'S LAST START IN KANSAS
CITY.
BARLOW HERE TRYING TO EXTEND
THIS ONE.
HE'S BEEN GOOD FOR THEM.
I THINK HE'S GIVEN THEM A CHANCE
TO WORK MULTIPLE INNINGS, WHICH
IS A NICE LUXURY TO HAVE.
THAT IS SOMETHING THEY TRIED TO
WORK WITH IN THE EIGHTH INNING.
YOU GO BACK WITH HIM AND GET A
GOOD START.
SCOTT: ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU DON'T
GET A BREAK.
GEOFF: THAT IS A TOUGH ROADIE.
GO FROM ARLINGTON TO HOUSTON,
THEN HOP ON THAT CHARGER FOR A
GOOD 4.5 HOURS TO THE GREAT
NORTHWEST.
THAT IS A SERIOUS TRIP FOR
KANSAS CITY.
SCOTT: ASTROS WANT THEM TO BE
WELL RESTED.
SEATTLE IS AS MUCH OF A
CONTENDER IN THE DIVISION AS
OAKLAND.
THEY ARE ONLY A GAME BEHIND THE
A'S.
JEREMY: ISN'T THAT SOMETHING?
I THINK THEY ARE SNEAKING UP ON
A LOT OF PEOPLE THIS YEAR.
CLEARLY FOR REAL AT THIS POINT
IN THE SEASON.
GEOFF: IT'S UNFAIR FOR ASTRO
FANS TO WATCH THE SEATTLE
MARINER MATCHUP AND WATCH THEM
AWAY FROM THE ASTROS, BECAUSE
THE ASTROS OBLITERATE THEM,
ESPECIALLY AT MINUTE MAID PARK.
IT HAS BEEN REMARKABLE WATCHING
THEM GO OUT AND BEAT OTHER TEAMS
AND ONLY BE ONE GAME BEHIND
OAKLAND AFTER PLAYING A GOOD
SERIES.
JEREMY: I LOVE THE PARITY
THIS YEAR.
SCOTT: THERE IS THE SEASON
SERIES WITH THE TOP TWO TEAMS
FOR NOW AND THE A.L. WEST.
ASTROS LEADING 9-4 OVER OAKLAND.
THEY HAVE PLAYED WELL AGAINST
THE OTHER TWO IN CONTENTION AT
THE MOMENT IN THE DIVISION.
GEOFF: IT HAS BEEN AMAZING JUST
TO SEE THAT DISCREPANCY AS FAR
AS RUNS PER GAME.
IT HAS BEEN TESTY AT TIMES.
IT HAS BEEN FUN OVER THE YEARS
TO WATCH THE ASTROS PLAY WELL IN
THE DIVISION.
THAT IS WHERE THEY EARNED THE
RIGHT OVER THE YEARS, EXCEPT
LAST YEAR WHERE THEY LOST TO THE
OAKLAND A'S.
PLAYING 19 TIMES WITHIN YOUR
DIVISION AND PLAY AS WELL AS
THEY DO IS WHERE YOU GET IT
DONE.
SCOTT: UNDERWATER SWING FROM
GURRIEL.
GEOFF: THAT WAS THAT SLIDER AND
SWEEPING.
LOOKS LIKE IT SURPRISED YULI A
LITTLE BIT.
JEREMY: YOU KNOW GALLAGHER WANTS
THAT CALL, HAVING PUNCHED OUT ON
THE SAME LOCATION.
HE DOES A NICE JOB TO GIVE THE
UMPIRE A CHANCE TO LEVEL OUT THE
SCORE.
SCOTT: YORDAN ALVAREZ
DOWNSTAIRS.
I LOVE THE POINT YOU MADE 2.5
HOURS AGO.
THIS IS HIS SECOND SEASON.
LAST YEAR WITH A SHORTENED YEAR
FOR EVERYONE.
GEOFF: HAD ISSUES WITH BOTH OF
HIS KNEES.
WHEN ON THE INJURED LIST.
IN THE OFF-SEASON, HAD SURGERY
ON BOTH OF THOSE KNEES.
HAVING THAT LOWER HALF, YOU
ASSUME A LOT OF UPPER BODY
STRENGTH GOES INTO HITTING, BUT
IF YOU DON'T HAVE THAT LOWER
HALF IT WILL BE MUCH HARDER.
IT'S GREAT TO HAVE HIM BACK IN
THE LINEUP.
SCOTT: 24 YEARS OLD.
THIS IS WHAT HE DID.
GEOFF: A LEISURELY SWING.
SCOTT: EASY PUMP IN THE FOURTH.
SCOTT: THAT IS WELL STRUCK.
ASTROS HAVE A TWO BASE OUT IN
THE NINTH.
GEOFF: DOESN'T THAT LOOK LIKE A
HANDSY SWING?
JEREMY: THEY ARE WORKING HIM
AWAY THE WHOLE AT-BAT.
HE GOES OUT AND WRAPS ALL THE
WAY AROUND, BARRELS IT THROUGH.
TO YOUR POINT, NOT A PANICKY
SWING.
GETTING AHEAD AND PULLING IT.
GEOFF: KNOWING THAT IN ONE SWING
HE CAN END THIS BALLGAME.
JEREMY: WHENEVER YOU SEE THE
HITTER BALANCED, THAT MAKES A
PITCHER NERVOUS.
WHEN YOU START THROWING PITCHES
BENDING FROM THE BACK DOOR,
TAKING EASY SWING'S AND THROWING
IT HARD, BALANCE IS LIKE AN EYE
TEST FOR A PITCHER.
SCOTT: PASS THE BATON TO CARLOS
CORREA.
JEREMY: WHICH IS WHY HE MAY BE
DID NOT WANT TO SEE ANY GOOD
BALANCE.
[LAUGHTER]
LOOKS LIKE HE IS FALLING ALL
OVER THE PLACE.
SCOTT: ALVAREZ WAS JUST IN A
LITTLE 0-8 SKID ENJOYING THE
DAY.
JEFF BAGWELL SAID HE IS A LITTLE
LATE.
THAT IS WHY HE IS A BATTING
AVERAGE GUY IN ADDITION TO THE
POWER.
THE SLUMPS DON'T LAST LONG WITH
HIM.
YOU SEE BIG POWER HITTER, YOU
FIGURE HE IS HIT OR MISS, NO.
THIS IS A CONSISTENT MAN IN THE
LINEUP FOR HOUSTON.
3-1 TO CORREA.
GEOFF: PRETTY GOOD TAKE.
JEREMY: THAT MAKES YOU
UNCOMFORTABLE.
JUST WATCHING MAKES ME
UNCOMFORTABLE TO SEE THAT.
BARLOW IS MIXING IT UP WELL.
GOOD FASTBALL.
MAKES A GOOD PITCH HERE, HITTING
IN THE COUNT.
GEOFF: DON'T MAKE THAT MISTAKE.
HITTING .347 IN HIS LAST 13
GAMES.
SCOTT: TAKE YOUR BASE.
JEREMY: IT WAS CLEAR THEY DID
NOT WANT TOO MUCH OF HIM IN THAT
AT-BAT.
GEOFF: YOU CAN PITCH AROUND GUYS
UNINTENTIONALLY.
JEREMY: A GUY YOU RECOGNIZE IS
SWINGING THE BAT WELL, IF IT'S
CLOSE ENOUGH, HE CAN DO DAMAGE
-- CAN'T DO DAMAGE, WE WILL LET
HIM DO THAT.
THE PROBLEM IS YOU NOW FACE
BREGMAN, WHO IS TAKING SWINGS
ALL DAY LONG.
THE REWARD FOR THIS IS IN
QUESTION.
GEOFF: ALEX BREGMAN RIGHT NOW IS
LICKING HIS CHOPS.
FIRST CAME BACK AND YOU HAVE A
CHANCE TO WIN IT, THIS IS HIS
KILL ZONE.
SCOTT: THIS IS THE GOOD STUFF.
GEOFF: THAT IS HOW THE SERIES
SHOULD END.
IT HAS BEEN AMAZING.
JEREMY: EARNED A VISIT FROM THE
PITCHING COACH.
THEY WILL GO WITH A NEW PLAN
HERE.
SCOTT: SWUNG AT FIRST PITCH.
IF ANYONE IS ANXIOUS TO BE BACK
WITH THE BIG-LEAGUE CLUB, IT'S
THE MAN THAT LOVES BASEBALL MORE
THAN ANY OTHER HUMAN ON THE
PLANET.
BREGMAN GOES AFTER THE FIRST
PITCH POPPED UP.
DOZIER CAN'T GET TO IT.
GEOFF: I THINK BRETT ALMOST MADE
A PLAY ON THAT.
BRETT: TRYING NOT TO FACE PLANT,
GUYS.
THAT ONE TOOK A BOUNCE OFF THE
CONCRETE.
YOU CAN SEE ME JUMPING UP ABOUT
SIX SECONDS LATE.
PROPER ETIQUETTE IS TO HOLD THE
PLAYERS SO THEY DON'T TUMBLE
INTO THE CAMERA WELL.
GEOFF: SELF-PRESERVATION.
SCOTT: HE'S DOING HIS JOB.
JEREMY: I DID NOT SEE HIM
PROTECTING ALEXA.
I DON'T KNOW IF BRETT CHECKED
OUT ON US.
BRETT: I WAS TRYING.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: ALEXA RAMOS DOWN WITH
BRETT DOLAN.
EVERYONE IS SAFE.
FIRST GAME BACK, BREGMAN MISSED
59.
TWO STRIKES ON HIM.
1-2.
GEOFF: GOOD PICK BY GALLAGHER,
KEEP THE RUNNERS WHERE THEY'RE
AT.
JEREMY: GOT TO TRUST THE
CATCHER.
GALLAGHER DID A NICE JOB ON THAT
ONE.
SCOTT: ALVAREZ AND CORREA ON FOR
THE HAIL RUNNER-UP -- A.L.
RUNNER-UP M.V.P., ALEX BREGMAN.
GEOFF: A COUPLE GOOD TAKES AFTER
HE CHASED THAT 0-1 SLIDER.
SCOTT: I WOULD LOVE TO BE INSIDE
HIS BRAIN RIGHT NOW.
HE DOES DISPLAY EXCELLENT PLATE
DISCIPLINE, BUT IT'S HIS FIRST
GAME BACK.
GEOFF: YOU WANT TO HAVE A HEART
RATE MONITOR ON HIM RIGHT NOW?
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: ALSO KEEP IN MIND, 30
PITCHES FROM BARLOW TODAY.
THAT IS NOT NOTHING.
GEOFF: THAT IS A PRETTY HEAVY
WORKLOAD FOR A RELIEVER.
SCOTT: DUSTY TOLD ALEX HE WILL
BE IN THE SIX HOLE TODAY.
PUTS IT ON THE GROUND.
INNING OVER.
JEREMY: GREAT JOB BY BARLOW
GETTING OUT OF THAT ONE.
SCOTT: A COUPLE STRIKES OUT.
CORREA WALK, BREGMAN BOUNCES
OUT.
LET'S PLAY A LITTLE BONUS
BASEBALL ON YOUTUBE IN HOUSTON,
TEXAS, SHALL WE?
♪
>> IT'S JULY8, 1980.
THE ASTROS BIG RIGHT-HANDER IS
THE STARTER FOR THE NATIONAL
LEAGUE.
AFTER FOUR STRAIGHT YEARS OF 18
PLUS WINS AND BACK-TO-BACK 300
STRIKEOUT SEASONS, J.R. IS
HAVING A GREAT FIRST HALF IN
1980.
>> I THOUGHT HE WAS ON HIS WAY
TO BEING THE BEST PITCHER HE HAD
EVER SEEN.
>> HE WAS THROWING 99, 100 MILES
PER HOUR AS THE SUN WAS SETTING.
>> RICHARD PITCHED TWO SCORELESS
INNINGS THAT NIGHT AND HAD THREE
STRIKEOUTS.
THE MEMORABLE CAME AGAINST
REGGIE JACKSON.
>> POWER AGAINST POWER.
>> 3-2.
>> I THREW REGGIE JACKSON A
SLIDER ON 3-1.
HE HAD NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THAT BEFORE.
>> 3-2 COMING.
PITCH CHASES HIM.
HE'S OUT.
♪
SCOTT: WE HAVE HIT THE 10TH,
TIED AT 5-5.
CAM GALLAGHER WILL BE AT SECOND.
BRETT: I WOULD STARE THERE IS A
BIT OF NEWS IN ASTROS SOCIAL
MEDIA LAND.
CARLOS CORREA IS ON THE LAST
YEAR OF HIS CONTRACT.
THERE WAS AN ARTICLE THAT
BOASTED AT THE ATHLETIC.
MY LAST YEAR WITH THE ASTROS
HOPEFULLY WE CAN WIN ANOTHER
CHAMPIONSHIP AND I CAN LEAVE
THIS ORGANIZATION WITH TWO OF
THEM.
WHILE THE TWO CHAMPIONSHIPS
SOUNDS GOOD TO ASTROS FANS, I AM
SURE THEY ARE NOT THRILLED TO
HEAR CARLOS MENTION THAT TODAY.
SCOTT: THAT HAS BEEN A LITTLE
BACK-AND-FORTH WITH CARLOS
CORREA AND THE MEDIA DISCUSSING
THE CONTRACT OFFER THAT HE
CONFIRMED FOR US.
YOU LOOK AT THE OTHER DOUGH HAND
ED OUT TO FRANCISCO LINDOR OR
TATIS JR., IT IS TRIPLE THAT
NUMBER.
HANSER ALBERTO WILL RUN FOR
GALLAGHER.
THE ASTROS ARE LIKE, THIS GUY
AGAIN?
WHIT MERRIFIELD.
GEOFF: TIMING IS EVERYTHING.
SCOTT: THIS IS KENDALL GRAVEMAN,
THE 30-YEAR-OLD.
HAVING A DYNAMITE SEASON.
GEOFF: I REMEMBER HIM AS A
STARTER.
HE HAS ADAPTED WELL TO THIS
ROLE.
ASTROS PLUG HIM FROM ONE OF THE
CONTENDERS IN THE DIVISION, PLUG
HIM IN FOR A SECOND CONSECUTIVE
DAY.
IT'S ALWAYS INTERESTING TO SEE
THAT TRANSITION BETWEEN PITCHING
AND TO SEE THE GUYS THAT STEP IN
LIKE WADE DAVIS AND TAKE THE
RELIEF ROLE.
LOOKS LIKE HE HAS DONE WELL WITH
THAT.
SCOTT: 2015, I REMEMBER KENDALL
GRAVEMAN WAS A SOFT TOSS OR IN
THE ROTATION -- SOFT TOSSER IN
THE ROTATION.
THAT IS BETTER, 97.
THAT WILL PLAY.
WHIT MERRIFIELD WITH THE BIG
SHOT TODAY FOR KANSAS CITY.
STATCAST POWERED BY GOOGLE
CLOUD.
GOOD LIFT ON THIS ONE.
CRAWFORD BOXES, FOURTH ROW.
GRAND SLAM.
ACCOUNTING FOR 4-5 RUNS FOR K.C.
TODAY.
GEOFF: I LIKE TO SEE KENDALL
GRAVEMAN WORK BACK INTO THIS
COUNT WITH WHIT MERRIFIELD.
NICKY LOPEZ IS NOT AFRAID TO HIT
DOWN A BUNT.
HANDLES THE BAT WELL.
COULD CREATE ISSUES WITH RUNNERS
AT FIRST AND SECOND.
JEREMY: THE ROYALS ARE NOT
AFRAID TO SAC BUNT.
MANY ORGANIZATIONS BAN IT.
WE ARE NOT GIVING AN OUT AWAY.
HE HAS ENOUGH SPEED THAT IF HE
BUNTS WELL, HE CAN STRETCH INTO
A HIT.
THE LEADOFF HITTER ALWAYS
IMPORTANT, BUT ESPECIALLY WITH
NICKY LOPEZ COMING UP.
GEOFF: THE LEADOFF MAN ALREADY
ON SECOND.
SCOTT: STRIKE THREE, GRAVEMAN.
BIG PUNCH OUT TO START THE 10TH.
GEOFF: ANOTHER GOOD SLIDER.
THAT MIGHT END UP BEING THE BOOK
ON WITT.
A COUPLE SLIDERS AGAINST TWO
TOUGH PITCHERS.
JEREMY: YOU TAKE ANYTHING YOU
CAN GET.
THAT IS THE WAY THEY HAVE
ATTACKED HIM SUCCESSFULLY.
SCOTT: FIRST A.B. IN THE 10TH
FOR THE VISITING TEAM IS SO
PIVOTAL BECAUSE NOW THE PRESSURE
IS ON.
NIKKI LOPEZ WATCHING IT
DOWNSTAIRS.
-- NICKY LOPEZ WATCHING IT
JEREMY: IS IT NORMAL TO YOU AT
THIS POINT?
SCOTT: ME, YES, BECAUSE I CALLED
THE WORLD BASEBALL CLASSIC AND I
SAID I LIKE TO THE ACTION.
GEOFF: I AM USED TO IT.
I DO NOT.
[LAUGHTER]
NOT YET.
I UNDERSTAND THE PURPOSE,
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE 10TH
OR 11TH INNING WITH NOBODY ON
BASE AND SEE HOW IT GOES.
THEN THE GUY AT SECOND BASE.
JEREMY: THE CASUAL BASEBALL FAN
COME EVERY TIME THEY RUN SCORES
COMMAND BELONGS TO A PITCHER,
MEANING THEY ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
IT.
DOES KENDALL GRAVEMAN HAVE
RESPONSIBILITY?
AN UNEARNED RUNS.
SO HE'S NOT IMPACTED BY THE
RULE.
SCOTT: NICKY LOPEZ TO THIRD.
TAG APPLIED.
THEY GET THE LEAD RUNNER.
WHAT DO THEY CALL IT IN SPRING
TRAINING?
JEREMY: PFP'S.
PITCHER FIELDING PRACTICE.
GOOD EASY RUNDOWN FOR GRAVEMAN.
HE DID NOT LET THE RUNNER
ADVANCE TO SECOND.
THE GOOD RUNDOWN DID NOT ALLOW
FOR THAT.
GEOFF: YOU KNOW WHAT ELSE THEY
PRACTICE IN SPRING TRAINING?
SEE THE BALL THROUGH.
THAT WAS A GREAT JOB TO
RECOGNIZE THE BASE RUNNER WAS
CAUGHT IN NO MAN'S LAND.
SCOTT: A CHECK OVER TO FIRST.
IF YOU ARE LOPEZ, YOU MIGHT GET
CAUGHT TRYING TO SWIPE SECOND.
SALVY CAN CHANGE THIS GAME WITH
ONE SWING.
GEOFF: ESPECIALLY IN THIS
BALLPARK.
SCOTT: 1-0.
BRETT: HAVE THE ROYALS RUN
THEMSELVES INTO OUTS FOR THE
CYCLE?
LOSING WHIT MERRIFIELD AT THIRD
BASE AND DOZIER AT SECOND, NOW A
RUNNER BETWEEN SECOND AND THIRD,
THE CYCLE?
GEOFF: YOU COULD ARGUE THAT.
SCOTT: THEY ARE AGGRESSIVE.
SOMETIMES IT COSTS THEM.
JEREMY: I LOVE WHAT YOU SAID
ABOUT BREGMAN LAST HALF INNING.
SCOTT: A QUICK LOOK AT MICHAEL
A. TAYLOR.
THINKING BIG.
LUIS GARCIA WAS ON.
WHAT GAVE IT AWAY WAS TWO PITCH
ES BEFORE THAT, TAILOR-MADE THE
PITCH -- TAYLOR MADE THE PITCHER
AWARE.
DID HE WAKE UP A SNOOZING PITCH
ER WITH A LONG DELIVERY A COUPLE
PITCHES BEFORE THAT?
OR DID HE HAVE AN EITHER WAY?
JEREMY: I THINK EITHER WAY.
HE'S GOT BALANCE.
TO BREAK THAT EARLY, HE HAS
PLENTY OF TIME TO ADJUST.
THE KEY IS IF YOU HAVE A SHIFT
THAT ALLOWS MICHAEL TAYLOR TO
TAKE A LARGER LEAD AND GET WAY
DOWN THE LINE, MAYBE HE HAS A
CHANCE.
HE DID NOT HAVE A GENEROUSLY.
THE PITCHER SAW HIM.
CREDIT TO HIM FOR NOT STOPPING
AND MOCKING.
GEOFF: I THINK LUIS, IT TIPPED
HIM OFF A BIT.
HE HAS ALMOST A DANCE STEP HE
DOES BEFORE HIS WINDUP.
THAT IS WHY THE MANAGER FOR THE
ROYALS POPPED OUT OF THE DUGOUT,
TO ARGUE HE ALTERED HIS DELIVERY
TO GET THAT OUT.
IT WAS NOT THAT STANDARD MOVE
THAT LUIS GARCIA HAS.
I THINK HE KEYED ON THAT TAYLOR
WAS DOING.
A NICE FLIP TO HOME PLATE.
IT WAS PERFECTLY LOCATED TO MAKE
THE TAG.
SCOTT: I THINK TAYLOR WAS ASKING
AT SOME POINT ABOUT THE DELIVERY
AND IF HE ALTERS IT.
MOST CHALLENGING THE RULE ON
THAT PLAY.
IT DIDN'T WORK OUT.
JEREMY: A GUY THAT LOVES
BASEBALL, HAS A CHANCE TO MAKE A
COMEBACK.
ONE OF THE UNDERSTATED IMPACTS
OF HIM HAVING TOMMY JOHN SURGERY
IS FOR A GUY THAT GETS AS BEAT
UP AS HE DOES, SALVY, IT ALMOST
GAVE HIM REJUVENATION TO COME
BACK AND HAVE THE SEASON HE IS
HAVING THIS YEAR.
SCOTT: THE ROYALS COME UP EMPTY
IN THE 10TH, LEAVING A LOT OF
ROOM FOR A WALKOFF CHANCE FOR
HOUSTON TO FINISH OFF THE SEASON
SERIES.
STAY TUNED.
♪
>> HERE'S HUNTER DOZIER.
>> THERE'S A DRIVE DEEP TO LEFT
FIELD.
HUNTER DOZIER.
>> OH, BABY, NICKY LOPEZ.
>> THAT LOOKED LIKE IT WAS
DROPPING.
>> A LINE DRIVE TO CENTER FIELD
THAT WILL KNOCK IN AT LEAST
ONNE.
-- AT LEAST ONE.
THEY GOT HIM.
>> HIT SHARPLY.
LOPEZ.
GOT HIM!
WHAT A PLAY.
>> THAT BALL IS STRUCK WELL.
DEEP TO RIGHT.
NICKY LOPEZ, HIS FIRST HOME RUN
OF THE YEAR.
>> JOSE ALTUVE.
BASE HIT LEFT FIELD.
MCCORMICK COMING AROUND.
THE THROW TO THE PLATE.
GOT HIM.
>> BENINTENDI UNLOADED.
♪
SCOTT: THIS IS THE MLB GAME OF
THE WEEK ON YOUTUBE.
WATCH LIVE TV WITH A LIMITED DVR
-- WITH UNLIMITED DVR.
WE ARE AT MINUTE MAID PARK IN
HOUSTON, TEXAS.
WHAT A DAY.
IT'S A PERFECT WAY TO WRAP UP
THE SEASON SERIES BETWEEN THESE
TWO.
WE ARE IN THE LAST OF THE 10TH.
HOUSTON DOES A NICE JOB IN THE
TOP OF THE INNING KEEPING THE
ROYALS OFF THE BOARD.
SALVADOR PEREZ WILL TAKE OVER
BEHIND THE PLATE.
ALBERTO WAS ULTIMATELY CAUGHT
BETWEEN SECOND AND THIRD.
A COSTLY OUT FOR K.C.
JOEL PAYAMPS IN THE GAME.
IT'S TUCKER, MEYERS.
TUCKER WITH BREGMAN AT SECOND IN
THE BOTTOM OF THE 10TH.
WE MIGHT GET A SNIPPET OF THAT
CONVO IN GOOP SHOW -- IN THE
POSTGAME SHOW.
WHIT MERRIFIELD IS MIC'ED UP.
ONE HIT CAN END THIS GAME.
GEOFF: AND YOU WILL TEST THE
LEGS OF ALEX BREGMAN HIS FIRST
GAME BACK.
THE ASTROS ARE ON THE OTHER END
OF THE SACRIFICE BUNT SITUATION
WHERE THEY DO NOT BUNT.
SCOTT: I DON'T THINK KYLE TUCKER
HAS PUNTED MUCH IN HIS LIFE.
-- BUNTED MUCH IN HIS LIFE.
JUST ACTIVATED YESTERDAY.
THIS IS HIS FIRST START IN ABOUT
A WEEK AND A HALF.
HE WAS ON THE COVID I.L.
1-4 TODAY.
LAST HIT CAME IN THE EIGHT.
HIGH FROM PAYAMPS.
I THINK ASTROS FANS SHOULD BE
PLEASED TO SEE NOT ONLY THE
PRODUCTION FROM ALEX BREGMAN,
BUT THAT HE'S PLAYING THE ENTIRE
GAME.
NO PINCH RUNNER HERE IN THE 10TH
INNING.
HE'S BACK.
GEOFF: HE'S PROBABLY GOT SOME
FRONT OFFICE PEOPLE SWEATING A
LITTLE BIT, CONCERNED ABOUT HOW
THOSE LEGS ARE DOING OF ALEX
BREGMAN.
IT'S ONE THING TO PLAY SEVEN OR
EIGHT INNINGS IN A MINOR LEAGUE
GAME.
IN A BIG-LEAGUE GAME, A LOT OF
THE MOVEMENT IS FAST IMMEDIATE
REACTIONS.
HE WILL GET TESTED RIGHT HERE.
TAYLOR JONES IS THE ONLY GUY TO
HAVE LEFT ON THEIR BENCH.
IF YOU HAVE THE OPTION TO PINCH
RUN FOR ALEX BREGMAN, IT WOULD
BRING ALEDMYS DIAZ IN.
I'M SURE IT IS AN ONGOING
CONVERSATION BETWEEN TRAINERS
AND ALEX BREGMAN, CAN WE KEEP
YOU IN THE GAME KIND OF THING.
SCOTT: HE STRIKES ME AS ONE OF
THOSE GUYS GOING, I AM PLAYING.
GEOFF: THAT WOULD BE A VERY
POLITE VERSION OF ALEX BREGMAN.
SCOTT: STATCAST SETTING UP ARM
STRENGTH.
BENINTENDI AND LEFT.
TAYLOR AT SECOND.
TUCKER GOING TO WRITE AND
TESTING -- RIGHT AND TESTING
DYSON.
BERGMAN WILL STAY PUT AT THIRD.
--  BREGMAN WILL STAY PUT AT
THIRD.
HERE COMES YOUNG JAKE MEYERS,
THE ROOKIE.
GEOFF: THAT IS A PITCH INSIDE
THE KYLE TUCKER, WHERE YOU THINK
YOU COULD BEAT HIM, BUT HE
DOES A GOOD JOB BRINGING THE
HANDS IN.
MOVES THAT RUNNER TO THIRD BASE.
JEREMY: YOU CAN UNDERSTAND THEY
ARE HAVING FUN ON THE BACKDOOR
BREAKING BALL, THINKING I CAN
GET A SWING UP AND IN IF I
LOCATE IT.
THAT IS A PRODUCT OF NOT TRYING
TO DO TOO MUCH.
IT'S EASIER TO FACE A HEADER
TRYING TO DO TOO MUCH -- A
HITTER TRYING TO DO TOO MUCH.
GEOFF: THAT IS WHERE I THINK
THESE OTHER GUYS THAT ARE NOT
TRYING TO DROP AND DRIVE PROVED
TO BE TOUGH AT-BATS, BECAUSE
THEY WORK WITHIN THEIR OWN
LIMITS AND HAVE TOUGH AT-BATS.
KYLE TUCKER DID A GREAT JOB.
SCOTT: RUNNER ON THE MOVE.
FREEBASE FOR KYLE TUCKER.
ONLY BREGMAN MATTERS IN A 5-5
GAME HERE IN THE TENT.
-- IN THE TENTH.
GEOFF: IF YOU HAVE A RUNNER AT
THIRD BASE AND LESS THAN TWO
OUTS, YOU ARE LOOKING FOR
SOMETHING YOU CAN DRIVE TO THE
OUTFIELD.
JEREMY: THE ROYALS PITCHERS HAVE
BEEN WORKING RIGHTIES INSIDE ALL
GAME LONG, SO THEY WILL SEE
WHICH PLAN WINS OUT.
SCOTT: DEFENSIVE INDIFFERENCE
GETS TUCKER TO SECOND.
CASTRO ON DECK.
ARE YOU SOMEWHAT PITCHING AROUND
JAKE MEYERS?
JEREMY: I THINK YOU ARE TRYING
TO GET A JAM.
A ONE HOPPER TO THE INFIELDER,
THEN YOU CAN TRY AND GO FOR THE
DOUBLE PLAY, BUT YOU HAVE TO GET
THE FIRST GUY AND GET HIM TO
SWING OUT OF THE ZONE.
IF YOU LOAD THEM UP RIGHT AWAY,
YOU ELIMINATE THE FREEDOM TO GET
SOME BAD CONTACT AND GET HIM
OUT.
SCOTT: TWO HITS FOR JAKE MEYERS.
HE'S HITTING .321 THIS YEAR.
THAT IS OFF PAYAMPS.
THIS ONE IS OVER.
R.B.I. GROUND OUT.
JAKE MEYERS, YOU DID IT.
HIS FIRST CAREER WALKOFF R.B.I..
ASTROS TAKE IT IN 10, 6-5.
SCOTT: PRETTY GOOD AT-BAT BY
JAKE MEYERS.
WAS NOT ABLE TO ELEVATE, BUT WAS
ABLE TO HIT IT HARD BACK UP THE
MIDDLE.
JEREMY: YOU GOT THE ONE HOP.
YOU HOPE PAYAMPS IS OKAY WITH
THE COMING OFF THE LEG.
FIRST CAREER WALKOFF.
GEOFF: KID HAS ONLY BEEN HERE
THREE WEEKS?
SCOTT: IT HAS BEEN A FUN THREE
WEEKS.
.300 PLUS HEADER, FIRST WALKOFF
R.B.I..
IT'S THE BIG LEAGUES.
MAKES CONTACT ON A PITCH DOWN.
GEOFF: HE PITCHED HIM WELL.
JUST DID NOT WORK OUT.
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN A TOUGH
PLAY FOR PAYAMPS.
SCOTT: THERE IS BREGMAN.
FIRST DAY BACK, SCORES THE
WINNING RUN FOR HOUSTON.
ALL AROUND GREAT DAY FOR THE
ASTROS.
AND AN EXCELLENT SERIES BETWEEN
THESE TWO TEAMS.
PLAYED SEVEN GAMES IN A WEEK AND
A HALF SPAN.
JEREMY: I THINK BOTH SETS OF
FANS HAVE TO BE HAPPY.
THE ROYALS CONTINUED SUCCESS.
THEY BOTH CAN BUILD OFF THIS
CLEARLY.
SCOTT: READY FOR THE POSTGAME
SHOW?
30 MINUTES ALL ABOUT THE ROYALS
AND THE ASTROS.
THIS GAME A WALKOFF WIN FOR
HOUSTON.
LET'S HIT IT.
♪
THE MLB GAME OF THE WEEK LIVE ON
YOUTUBE POSTGAME SHOW IS
PRESENTED BY YOUTUBE TV.
WHAT A DAY FOR HOUSTON ASTROS
FANS.
YOU ARE EXCITED TO SEE ALEX
BREGMAN BACK IN THE LINEUP.
HOUSTON LET US KNOW LAST NIGHT
HE IS BACK.
FANS GO, I'M IN.
SKIP WHATEVER YOU'VE GOT GOING
ON AND HEAD TO MINUTE MAID PARK.
THAT SETS UP OUR FINAL POLL
QUESTION FOR THE YOUTUBE GAME OF
THE WEEK.
THE YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME,
WHO IS GETTING THE TROPHY?
MR. WALKOFF, WHO JOINS US RIGHT
NOW ON THE POSTGAME SHOW, THE
ROOKIE WITH HIS FIRST CAREER
R.B.I. IN EXTRA.
JAKE, CONGRATULATIONS ON THE W.
WHAT WAS IT LIKE?
JAKE: AWESOME.
I WAS HAPPY TO BE IN THAT
SITUATION AND TRYING TO HELP THE
TEAM WIN.
OUR TEAM FOUGHT HARD BALLGAME.
GLAD WE CAME OUT ON TOP.
GEOFF: TALK US THROUGH THAT
AT-BAT.
A SECOND AND THIRD SITUATION
WITH NOBODY OUT.
GIVE US AN IDEA WHAT YOU ARE
LOOKING FOR.
JAKE: I WAS JUST TRYING TO GET
A PITCH OVER THE PLATE TO THE
OUTFIELD.
I GOT THE RUN IN.
THAT IS ALL THAT MATTERS.
JEREMY: FIRST WALKOFF FOR YOU,
WHAT WAS YOUR HEART RATE LIKE?
HOW DID YOU FEEL THAT LAST
AT-BAT?
JAKE: I'M NOT GOING TO LIE, MY
HEART WAS RACING A LITTLE BIT.
I GOT MORE COMFORTABLE WHEN I
STEPPED IN THE BOX.
IT WAS FUN.
JEREMY: GOOD PIECE OF HITTING.
CONGRATULATIONS.
SCOTT: HOW FOOTING HAS IT BEEN
TO BE PART OF THIS BALLCLUB --
HOW FUN HAS IT BEEN TO BE PART
OF THIS BALLCLUB?
THE ASTROS HAVE PLAYED IN HUGE
GAMES YEAR AFTER YEAR.
ARE YOU ASKING EVERYONE, HEY,
WHAT IS THIS SITUATION LIKE?
JAKE: ABSOLUTELY.
EVERY DAY I AM LEARNING
SOMETHING FROM SOMEBODY.
AN AWESOME TEAMMATE.
I ASK A BUNCH OF QUESTIONS.
I OWE A LOT OF MY SUCCESS TO
THEM.
THEY HELPED ME ACCLIMATE TO THE
BIG LEAGUES COMFORTABLY.
IT HAS BEEN FUN TO WORK WITH
THEM.
SCOTT: THIS IS YOUR FIRST GAME
PLAYING WITH ALEX BREGMAN FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN 59 GAMES.
WHAT WAS IT LIKE BEING WITH ALEX
TODAY?
I'M SURE HE WAS EXCITED TO BE
BACK ON THE BIG-LEAGUE CLUB.
JAKE: HE IS A GREAT BASEBALL
PLAYER.
MADE A NICE PLAY A THIRD.
HAD A BUNCH OF GOOD AT-BATS.
I'M GLAD HE'S ON OUR TEAM.
SCOTT: YOU WON YOUTUBE PLAYER OF
THE GAME.
THE TROPHY IS YOURS.
WATCH OUT, IT IS A LITTLE SNEAKY
HEAVY.
[LAUGHTER]
THERE IS SOME WEIGHT TO IT.
YOUR NAME WILL BE ENGRAVED ON
IT.
NICE FIRST FEW WEEKS IN THE BIG
LEAGUES, HUH?
JAKE: THANK YOU.
SCOTT: YOU GUYS KEEP TRUCKING
ALONG.
WHAT HAS IT BEEN LIKE IN THIS
DIVISION RACE?
IT'S NOT ONLY OAKLAND, BUT THE
MARINERS ARE PLAYING INSPIRING
BASEBALL AS WELL.
JAKE: EVERY GAME MATTERS, EVERY
PITCH MATTERS.
I THINK WE DO A GOOD JOB MAKING
SURE WE BRING IT EVERY DAY AND
FOCUSED.
GEOFF: YOU HAD A BIG WEEK WHEN
YOU WENT OPPOSITE FIELD FOR THE
GRAND SLAM.
I BELIEVE YOU ARE ONE OF THE
QUICKEST ROOKIES IN ASTROS
HISTORY TO DO THAT.
TELL US HOW GOOD IT FELT TO GET
THE FIRST GRAND SLAM OUT OF THE
WAY.
JAKE: A MOMENT I WILL REMEMBER
FOR THE REST OF MY LIFE.
A LOT OF FUN.
SOMETHING TO BUILD OFF OF.
SCOTT: DARREN WAS HIS COACH IN
COLLEGE.
WHAT WAS HE LIKE?
JAKE: ONE OF THE MOST, IF NOT
THE MOST COMPETITIVE GUY I HAVE
BEEN AROUND.
AN INCREDIBLE PERSON.
TAUGHT ME HOW TO BE A BETTER
PERSON AND BASEBALL PLAYER.
IT WAS FUN TO BE AROUND HIM AND
LEARN A BUNCH OF INVALUABLE
THINGS.
SCOTT: MANY KIDS WATCHING
WORLDWIDE ON YOUTUBE, SOME
THINKING ABOUT BEING IN A SPOT
LIKE YOU WHEN THEY ARE OLDER,
CAN YOU WALK ME THROUGH THE
PROCESS AS A MINOR LEAGUE
BALLPLAYER?
WHAT WERE SOME OF THE
DEVELOPMENTS YOU HAVE GONE
THROUGH THAT MADE YOU WHO YOU
ARE?
JAKE: GREAT QUESTION.
IT TAKES YEARS OF A BUNCH OF
DIFFERENT THINGS, LEARNING HOW
YOU CAN GET BETTER.
THAT IS THE KEY, JUST KEEP
GETTING BETTER EVERY DAY.
JUST TRUST YOURSELF.
YOU CAN DEFINITELY GET HERE.
YOU HAVE TO BELIEVE IT.
SCOTT: YOU FINISH OFF THE GAME
TODAY FOR THE ASTROS.
CONGRATULATIONS AGAIN.
LET'S CHECK OUT THE TROPHY ONE
MORE TIME.
GOOD LUCK THE REST OF THE
SEASON.
WE WILL GET YOU ONE WITH YOUR
NAME ON IT.
JAKE MEYERS JOINING US.
48% OF THE PIE, HE GETS THE
YOUTUBE TROPHY.
HE BRINGS HOME ALEX BREGMAN AND
YORDAN ALVAREZ.
WE WILL GIVE YOU A FULL RECAP,
HIGHLIGHTS, ALL COMING UP ON THE
POSTGAME SHOW.
♪
>> RUNNER ON THE GO.
A THROW IN TIME.
HIS FIRST CAUGHT STEALING OF THE
YEAR.
ANOTHER GUY THROW DOWN.
JARROD DYSON CAUGHT STEALING.
>> THE ASTROS TAKE THEIR FIRST
LEAD OF THE GAME.
4-3.
>> THROWS IT ON THE FASTBALL.
>> THE 1-2.
SWING AND A MISS.
SEAGER DOWN ON STRIKES.
EIGHT PUNCH OUTS FROM MCCULLERS.
>> FOUR HIT GAME FOR ALTUVE.
R.B.I. SINGLE.
AN EVEN DOZEN FOR THE SECOND
STRAIGHT GAME, 12-0 ASTROS.
♪
GEOFF: GORGEOUS DAY IN HOUSTON.
IT WENT TO EXTRAS.
WE'VE GOT SOME HIGHLIGHTS FOR
YOU RIGHT NOW ON THE GAME.
>> LANCE MCCULLERS HAS BEEN
AROUND IT FEELS LIKE FOREVER.
HE CAN BE THE ACE.
IF HE PITCHES LIKE THAT, HE WILL
GET HIS CAREER IN INNINGS.
>> LOPEZ MAKES CONTACT.
DIVING STOP BY BRIGHTMAN. -- BY
BRIGHTMAN.
-- BY BREGMAN.
HE'S BACK.
>> NICKY LOPEZ IS TESTING HIM.
AS MUCH AS WE TALK ABOUT WHAT
ALEX BREGMAN BRINGS TO THE
OFFENSE, YOU SEE WHAT HE CAN DO
DEFENSIVELY ALSO.
>> THEY BROUGHT HIM IN FOR A TWO
YEAR DEAL.
HE IS THEIR LEADER.
SCOTT: A FLARE, AND CAUGHT.
GRABBED BY NICKY LOPEZ FOR THE
FIRST OUT.
>> THAT IS WHAT NICKY LOPEZ
DOES.
NOW HE IS IN CONTENTION FOR A
GOLD GLOVE THIS YEAR.
SCOTT: HAVING A HUGE HOME STAND.
A LITTLE CHASE.
MINOR SITS DOWN THE SIDE IN
ORDER.
EIGHT STRIKEOUTS IN A 12-3 WIN
LAST WEEK.
HE PICKS UP A STRIKEOUT, HIS
FIRST OF THE DAY.
1-2 TO TAYLOR.
SAID THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
SLIDER HAS BEEN HUGE, ADDING TO
OUR CONVERSATION.
THAT IS A PITCH THAT SUDDENLY
BECOMES MAY BE HIS BEST WEAPON.
RIGHT BACK TO A GREAT ATHLETE ON
THE MOUND AS WELL, MCCULLERS JR.
IMPRESSIVE SECOND INNING AFTER
THE DOZIER BASE HIT.
STRIKEOUT, STRIKEOUT.
LANCE MCCULLERS JR. TO FINISH
OFF THE ROYALS IN THE SECOND.
>> ALEX BREGMAN IS BACK.
DO YOU THINK THEY LIKE ALEX
BREGMAN/
>> JUST A LITTLE BIT.
>> FOR BREGMAN, FIRST GAME SINCE
JUNE 16.
SAID HE FEELS BETTER THAN HE HAS
THE LAST COUPLE YEARS.
GOES AFTER THE FIRST PITCH.
RIVERA, CALLED OFF BY LOPEZ.
DOMESTIC WITH THE SHORTSTOP.
HE JUST GOT ENGAGED TOO.
>> THE CHANGEUP IS PROBABLY MY
BREAD-AND-BUTTER.
SCOTT: NICE THROW FROM MARTIN
MALDONADO.
THIS TEAM CAN REALLY RUN.
TOOK OUT WHIT MERRIFIELD.
HE HAD THE ONE OUT DOUBLE.
CAUGHT STEALING FOR THE THIRD
TIME THIS YEAR.
SECOND BEST IN BASEBALL.
MALDONADO SMASHES ONE TO THE
CRAWFORD BOXES AND BEYOND.
HOUSTON IS ON THE BOARD THANKS
TO MALDY.
JEREMY: HAD HIS COUNT
MIDDLE-MIDDLE.
DID NOT MISS IT.
SCOTT: SALVADOR PEREZ UNLOADS.
ALMOST THE SAME SPOT AS
MALDONADO.
BOTH CATCHERS ON EITHER SIDE
WITH HOME RUNS.
THAT IS NUMBER 34 ON THE SEASON
FOR SALVY.
JEREMY: HE IS ON PACE TO BECOME
THE SIXTH CATCHER TO HIT 40 HOME
RUNS IN THE HISTORY OF THIS
GAME.
SCOTT: RUNNERS GOING.
HE IS OUT.
MALDONADO DID IT AGAIN.
HE CATCHES HUNTER DOZIER.
>> HIS NICKNAME IS THE MACHETE.
CUTTING RUNNERS DOWN.
SCOTT: THERE IT GOES.
YORDAN ALVAREZ MUSCLES UP.
2-1 ASTROS.
26 ON THE YEAR.
♪
SCOTT: BREGMAN, HARD CONTACT.
HE'S IN BUSINESS.
A BASE HIT WITH TWO OUTS IN THE
FOURTH.
THIRD A.B. FOR BREGMAN TODAY.
SMACKED TO LEFT FIELD.
OFF THE TOP OF THE WALL.
ALEX BREGMAN IS BACK WITH AN
R.B.I. DOUBLE TO EXTEND THE
ADVANTAGE.
3-1.
>> THAT ONE DID NOT GET QUITE TO
WHERE HE WAS HOPING.
AN AMAZING ADJUSTMENT.
SCOTT: ASTROS IN CONTROL, RIGHT?
SEVENTH INNING, MCCULLERS TAKES
AN OUT.
WHIT MERRIFIELD.
ONE PITCH FROM KRISHAN JAVIER
AND 5-1 K.C.
GRAND SLAM.
IN THE BOTTOM OF THE SEVENTH,
ALEDMYS DIAZ HELPS HOUSTON COME
BACK WITH AN R.B.I. KNOCK.
THERE IS JAKE MEYERS.
DIAZ HAS BEEN SO SOLID THIS
YEAR.
GEOFF: FILLING SOME HOLES.
THEY DID NOT MISS A BEAT HAVING
ALEDMYS DIAZ PUT TOGETHER GOOD
AT-BATS.
IT ALLOWS MORE MOBILITY AND
VERSATILITY OUT OF ALEDMYS DIAZ.
SCOTT: MICHAEL BRANTLEY WITH AN
R.B.I. KNOCK.
WE ARE IN THE 10TH WHEN KYLE
TUCKER TURNS IT INTO A BASE HIT.
THE MISS FOR THE ROYALS WAS NOT
COMING THROUGH WITH ANY RUNS IN
THE TOP OF THE 10TH.
IT PUTS A TON OF PRESSURE ON
YOUR RELIEVER.
IT'S OFF PAYAMPS.
JAKE MEYERS, CONGRATULATIONS TO
THE ROOKIE AND A WALKOFF R.B.I.
6-5 IN FAVOR OF THE ASTROS.
THEY IMPROVE TO 6-7 IN EXTRA
INNINGS.
THE ROYALS DROP TO 2-4.
KANSAS CITY WITH A RECORD ON THE
SEASON OF 56-70.
THE ASTROS WITH THEIR 75TH WIN.
THEY ARE IN FIRST PLACE IN THE
AMERICAN LEAGUE WEST.
ONE BASEBALL THAT WAS PRETTY
CLOSE FOR YOU, BRETT.
YOU WERE READY JUST IN CASE TO
PROTECT A FLYING HUNTER DOZIER.
HE IS A BIG DUDE.
BRETT: A LOT OF SPIN ON THOSE
HIGH POP-UPS.
IT FEELS LIKE WE ARE ON THE SIDE
OF THE SUN IN THE CAMERA WELL.
QUITE A SEASON SERIES BETWEEN
THESE TEAMS COVERING SEVEN
GAMES.
SOME BACK-AND-FORTH, SOME ONE
RUN CONTEST.
WE STARTED THIS 4.5 HOURS AGO
TALKING ABOUT HOW THIS ASTROS
LINEUP WAS HAPPY TO HAVE ALEX
BREGMAN BACK.
MISSED 59 GAMES WITH THE QUAD
ISSUE.
NOT ONLY DID HE PLAY THE ENTIRE
GAME AND SCORED THE GAME-WINNING
RUN.
I HAD A CHANCE TO CATCH UP WITH
HIM MOMENTS AGO.
IS THERE AN EXTRA SHOT OF
ADRENALINE WHEN YOU HAVE NOT
PLAYED A COUPLE MONTHS?
ALEX: DEFINITELY EXCITED.
IT WAS FUN TO COME BACK AT
HOME.
BRETT: FELT LIKE YOU MISSED ONE
EARLY ON TO CENTER FIELD.
ALEX: MISSED THE FIRST ONE TOO.
WE WILL GET IT GOING.
BRETT: HOW GOOD CAN THIS OFFENSE
BE DOWN THE STRETCH?
ALEX: THIS OFFENSE CAN BE NASTY.
HOPEFULLY WE KEEP IT ROLLING.
BRETT: DOESN'T MATTER WHERE YOU
BAT?
-- DOES IT MATTER WHERE YOU BAT?
ALEX: I DON'T KNOW.
I AM JUST TRYING TO PUT GOOD
SWINGS ON IT.
BRETT: ANY PLAN FOR HOW MUCH YOU
WANT TO PLAY AS WE GET TOWARDS
THE POSTSEASON?
ALEX: NO, OF COURSE I WANT TO
PLAY EVERY DAY.
WE WILL SEE WHAT THE PLAN IS AND
TRUST IN WHAT THEY HAVE PLANNED,
GET AFTER IT WITH GREAT
TEAMMATES.
BRETT: CONGRATULATIONS ON THE
WIN.
THAT'S ALEX BREGMAN.
HE'S HEALTHY AND DRIVEN INTO AN
ASTROS WIN.
THE ROYALS AND ASTROS FINISHED
OFF SEVEN GAMES IN 10 DAYS.
HAVE A FEELING THEY MIGHT BE
TIRED OF SEEING EACH OTHER.
SOMETIMES YOU WONDER ABOUT A
TEAM LIKE HOUSTON THAT HAS BEEN
IN FOUR STRAIGHT AMERICAN LEAGUE
CHAMPIONSHIP SERIES.
MAYBE YOU ARE ANXIOUS TO GET
BACK TO THE POSTSEASON, SEE IF
YOU CAN REACH THE WORLD SERIES
AGAIN.
IT FEELS LIKE WHEN THIS ASTROS
TEAM IS DOWN TO SOME TEAMS THEY
SHOULD DEFEAT, THAT
COMPETITIVENESS KICKS IN.
SCOTT: WHEN WE TALKED ABOUT THE
ASTROS AT TIMES STRUGGLED TOWARD
THE BOTTOM OF THEIR DIVISION,
BUT EVENTUALLY YOU SEE THE
ROYALS ENOUGH.
DUSTY BAKER'S LINE WAS WE HAVE
BEEN PUNCHED QUITE A BIT BY THIS
TEAM AND NOT PUNCHED BACK.
BREGMAN IS BACK IN THE LINEUP.
WHEN BRETT ASKED HIM ABOUT THE
PLAN OVER THE NEXT FIVE WEEKS, I
COULD SENSE INSIDE ALEX
BREGMAN'S BRAIN, I WILL DO WHAT
THEY WANT.
BUT HE'S PROBABLY GOING I BETTER
BE IN THE LINEUP AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE BECAUSE I MISS THIS
GAME.
GEOFF: HE WASN'T GIVING THE FULL
STORY, I AGREE.
IF YOU ASK HIM OFF-CAMERA, HE
WILL SAY I BETTER BE IN THERE
TOMORROW.
I AGREE IN THE SENSE THAT THEY
ARE SICK AND TIRED OF THE KANSAS
CITY ROYALS.
I THINK THEY ARE IMPRESSED WITH
WHAT THEY WERE ABLE TO DO.
THEY PLAY THE GAME WELL.
THEY CONTINUE TO FIGHT.
IT FORCED THEM WHERE THEY HAD TO
STEP UP AND PLAY BETTER.
THE MOST OVERUSED TERM IN
AUGUST MIGHT BE THE DOG DAYS OF
SUMMER.
WITH THE POSTSEASON EXPERIENCE
AND ISSUES OF ADJUSTING BACK TO
A LONG SEASON AGAIN, MAYBE THESE
WERE THE SEVEN GAMES THAT FORCES
THESE GUYS TO PLAY GOOD BASEBALL
DOWN THE STRETCH.
JEREMY: THEY ARE CHARACTER
BUILDING WINS.
YOU CAN TAKE A LOT OUT OF THE
LOSSES IF YOU SO CHOOSE.
YOU NEED SOMETHING TO TEST YOU.
YOU NEED TO BE CHALLENGED IN A
WAY THAT CAUSES YOU TO SELF
REFLECT.
THEIR GOAL IS THE WORLD SERIES.
BRETT: FOR THIS ASTROS TEAM, THE
BULLPEN SEEMED TO BE THE MISSING
OR WEAK LINK.
THEY ADDRESSED THAT.
NOW THE HEALTH.
ANY THING YOU NEED TO SEE THIS
TEAM DO OR DO YOU FEEL THEY ARE
IN A GOOD POSITION DOWN THE
STRETCH?
GEOFF: THE 4.5 GAME LEAD OVER
THE A'S, IF THEY CHOOSE TO PUT
ALEX ON THE BENCH, IT WILL NOT
UPFRONT MAKE A BIG IMPACT
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A CUSHION.
YOU DON'T WANT TO SIT BACK, BUT
THE TIMING IS GREAT.
THEY HAVE THE WHOLE MONTH OF
SEPTEMBER TO GET IT GOING.
GEOFF: YULI GURRIEL HAD SOME
TIME OFF AND WILL GET HIS LEGS
BACK UNDER HIM.
THEY WILL RELY ON ALEX BREGMAN
DOWN THE STRETCH.
IT IS GIVING THESE GUYS THE
APPROPRIATE MOMENTS OFF.
THE BACK END OF THE BULLPEN
EARLY ON WAS THE WEAK LINK.
STARTING PITCHERS WOULD COME OUT
AND SUDDENLY THINGS WOULD BLOW
UP WITH WALKS.
YIMI GARCIA HAS BEEN GOOD.
IT IS GOING TO BE FUN TO SEE HOW
DUSTY FIGURES OUT WHERE THESE
GUYS MIX IN.
THE TIGHTER GAMES ARE WHERE THE
ASTROS REALLY EXCEL.
SCOTT: DUSTY BAKER SET UP BY THE
FRONT OFFICE NICELY DOWN THE
STRETCH.
I'VE GOT FOUR NEW RELIEVERS.
A 6-5 WALKOFF WIN IN DOWNTOWN
HOUSTON.
MUCH MORE TO COVER ON THE
POSTGAME SHOW IN JUST A MOMENT.
♪
>> HE JUST SMOKES IT.
>> FORGET ABOUT IT.
>> MY GOODNESS.
>> GREAT BASEBALL.
>> THAT BALL IS CRUSHED.
>> THIS IS GOING TO DO IT.
>> OH MY.
>> STRIKE THREE.
>> THAT WAS A GREAT PLAY.
>> THAT WAS REMARKABLE.
♪
>> SOMETHING LIKE THIS IS WHAT
THEY CAME FOR.
♪
>> YOU ARE MIC'ED?
I KNEW YOU WOULD BE THE ONE.
>> CHECK, CHECK.
>> DON'T LET HIM TOUCH IT.
NO PITCHERS ALLOWED.
>> I LIKE THAT FLARE IN THERE.
THATTA BOY.
SURE.
I BELIEVE YOU.
[LAUGHTER]
OH, SICK!
NOBODY HITS THE ROYALS.
HOW MANY OVATIONS IS HE GOING TO
GET?
HE'S LIKE BIG PAPI AND RIVERA.
EVERYWHERE WE GO.
EVERYBODY, PLEASE STAND FOR THE
FOURTH TIME TODAY.
I AM GOING TO BE SHALLOW CENTER.
WITH HIM I WILL BE SHALLOW
CENTER.
HE'S GOT A FRIDGE STRAPPED TO
HIM.
I DID NOT GET THE BEST JUMP, BUT
I HAVE GOTTEN WORSE JUMPS.
>> HE THROWS THAT FIRST SLIDER,
I KNOW HE'S GOING TO GO FASTBALL
AWAY.
>> I SHOULD HAVE GONE FIRST.
SALVY IS SOME KIND OF SPECIAL.
I NEVER CAUGHT HIM, SO I DON'T
KNOW WHAT IT FEELS LIKE AUGUST
26.
IT'S LIKE BARRY BONDS NOW.
HE WALKS AND HITS HOMER.
THIS BAT IS ROUND.
THE PELOTA IS ROUND.
SOMETIMES YOU MISS BY JUST THIS
MUCH.
YOU THIS YEAR HAVE NOT MISSED
VERY MUCH.
I LOVE THE WAY HE THINKS.
HIT ME ON THE SLAM.
COME ON, BABY!
LET'S GO, BABY.
J.P.!
GOOD AT-BAT.
BIG BODY.
DID YOU CALL IT?
LET'S GO.
SCOTT: SO MUCH GOLD THERE.
HE ALSO SNAPPED THE SECOND
LONGEST CAREER HOME RUN DROUGHT
FOR HIM, 47 GAMES.
JEREMY, YOU NAILED IT AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE GAME.
YOU ARE LIKE SOMETIMES YOU DON'T
REALIZE YOU HAVE THE MIC ON.
HE SAID ONCE OR TWICE I FORGOT.
DON'T WORRY, WE COVER IT UP IF
THERE IS ANYTHING WE NEED TO DO,
BECAUSE HE GAVE US PLENTY OF
EXCELLENT ONE-LINERS.
WHIT MERRIFIELD WITH A GRAND
SLAM TODAY.
THEY PLAYED TOUGH AGAINST THE
HOUSTON ASTROS ALL SEASON.
LAST PLAY AS WHIT MERRIFIELD AND
THE ROYALS FALL TO THE ASTROS.
LET'S RUN THROUGH IT.
THIS IS HOW THE GAME ENDED.
JAKE MEYERS OFF PAYAMPS.
A HOT SHOT FOR A PITCHER TO HAN
DLE.
GEOFF: GETTING THAT OUT AT FIRST
BASE DOES ABSOLUTELY NOTHING.
I THINK THE STUNNING ACTION OF
THAT BALL HITTING HIM THREW HIM
INTO A PANIC AND EVERYTHING WAS
OUT THE WINDOW.
THAT WINNING RUN IS WHERE IT'S
OUT.
JEREMY: WHEN THE PLAY HAPPENED,
I THINK IT GOT HIM GOOD.
I THINK IT HIT HIM PRETTY GOOD.
HE WAS FRAZZLED.
OBVIOUSLY IT WOULD HAVE BEEN A
NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE PLAY.
LOST A LITTLE BIT OF HIS SENSE
AS TO WHERE THE PLAY WAS AND
WHERE HE NEEDED TO GO.
SCOTT: WHAT HAPPENS IN THAT
SITUATION?
CAN HE TURN AROUND AND MAKE THE
PLAY?
GEOFF: IT WOULD HAVE BEEN A
FREAKISHLY MIRACULOUS BACKHANDED
FLIP AND YOU CAN GET TO ALEX
BREGMAN.
AS HARD AND FAR AS THAT BALL
RICOCHETED, THERE WAS REALLY NO
CHANCE.
SCOTT: UNLESS HIS ARM MOVES
WHERE IT IS NOT SUPPOSED TO
MOVE.
CREDIT TO JAKE MEYERS, THE
YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME.
HE GETS THE WHOLE TROPHY.
HIS 18TH GAME IN THE BIGS.
WE TAKE YOU AROUND THE MAJORS.
THE YANKEES HAVE WON 11 IN A
ROW.
THE ORIOLES DROPPED -- IS THAT A
MISPRINT?
19 STRAIGHT.
OOF.
YADI, CONGRATULATIONS ON
REUPPING WITH THE CARDINALS.
BRANDON BELT HONORS HIS
GRANDMOTHER WITH A FOUR HIT
PERFORMANCE.
HE WAS EMOTIONAL AFTER THE GAME.
HEADLINES GALORE IN THIS LEAGUE.
WHAT STANDS OUT TO YOU?
YANKEES.
THE YANKEES ARE FIRING RIGHT
NOW.
GEOFF: UP UNTIL THE TRADE
DEADLINE, EVERYONE SAID THEY
WERE DEAD IN THE WATER.
SOME OF THOSE YOUNG PITCHERS ARE
STEPPING UP.
BULLPEN ARE STARTING TO CLOSE
OUT THESE GAMES.
AS POWERFUL AS THE LINEUP IS,
IT'S A REAL THREAT IN THE EAST.
SCOTT: TOMORROW THE A'S START A
SERIES AT HOME AGAINST THE
YANKEES.
THE ASTROS ARE LIKE, GREAT.
[LAUGHTER]
I PUT YOU ON THE SPOT.
JEREMY: IT WAS LIKE WHAT YOU
SAID, IS THAT A MISPRINT?
TO SEE THE BALTIMORE 19 GAME
LOSING STREAK.
GEOFF: THEY HAD SOME ROUGH
LOSING STREAKS OVER FRANCHISE
HISTORY.
JEREMY: THAT ONE STANDS OUT TO
ME.
A LOT OF THINGS HAVE TO GO WRONG
FOR THAT TO HAPPEN.
GEOFF: THEY HAVE A ROAD LOSING
STREAK OF OVER 20 GAMES THIS
SEASON.
THERE ARE SOME AWFUL STREAKS FOR
THE BALTIMORE ORIOLES THIS
SEASON.
SCOTT: THE OTHER HEADLINE NOT
LISTED IS OUR GUY JEREMY GUTHRIE
BOOKING A FLIGHT A LITTLE TOO
EARLY ON A WEDNESDAY AFTERNOON.
ARE YOU GOING TO MAKE IT?
JEREMY: DO YOU SEE ME SWEATING?
I'M GOOD.
WE GOT THE BASES LOADED, 3-0
COUNT AND I'M THROWING BALLS
DOWN THE MIDDLE.
MAYBE WE CAN STILL GET THERE.
SCOTT: POLICE ESCORT, PLEASE.
THE MLB YOUTUBE GAME OF THE WEEK
COVERAGE BEGINS WITH OUR PREGAME
SHOW AT 3:00 EASTERN.
FOR OUR ENTIRE SUPERSTAR CREW,
I'M SCOTT BRAUN LOGGING OUT FOR
NOW.
IT'S THE ASTROS WINNING IN 10, A
WALKOFF W, 6-5 THANKS TO THE
ROOKIE JAKE MEYERS.
THANKS FOR HANGING OUT WITH US
TODAY WORLDWIDE ON YOUTUBE.
♪